ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
FOR TUESDAY JUNE TWENTY SECOND.
AS IS OUR NORMAL PROCESS OF A
START WITH SOME OF THE
LOGISTICS FOR TODAY WE ARE
STILL. PHYSICALLY DISTANCING
AND ENSURING THAT EVERYONE IS
WEARING A MASK TO BE IN THE
ROOM AND TO BE THROUGHOUT. THE
CAPITAL. EVEN THOUGH WE ARE
OPENING WE ARE STILL. UNDER
ORDERS FOR MAKING SURE WE'RE
PROTECTING EACH OTHER AND WE
WILL CONTINUE THAT TODAY
THERE'S LIMITED ROOM HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM. BUT WE ALSO
HAVE TELEPHONIC AND THE WITNESS
VIDEO ROOM THAT ARE AVAILABLE
FOR ANYONE WHO WANTS TO BE
CALLING IN FOR ADDRESSING THE
COMMITTEE IT LOOKS LIKE TODAY
WE PROBABLY WILL HAVE MORE
WITNESSES WHO ARE HERE IN THE
ROOM AND IN PERSON. AND IF YOU
ARE WANTING TO SPEAK ON A BILL
AS IT COMES UP JUST MAKE SURE
YOU RAISE YOUR HAND INDICATE
THAT YOU WANT TO SPEAK ON IT
I'LL INVITE YOU TO COME FOR TO
THE MICROPHONE ANYONE IN THE
ROOM. WHO IS WELCOME TO USE THE
MICROPHONE. THE IT AS A WAY. OR
OTHER TESTIMONY ON A BILL THAT
PLEASE DO NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE SO WE CAN KEEP IT AS
CLEAN AS POSSIBLE FOR EVERYONE
ELSE TO BE ABLE TO MOVE THROUGH
IN AN ORDERLY MANNER. SO FOR
THE PUBLIC WHO IS CALLING IN.
YOU SHOULD SEE THE CALL THE
NUMBER ON YOUR SCREEN IT'S ALSO
ON THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE. CALL
IN NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. THAT IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN AND THE PUBLIC
ACCESS. ACCESS CODE IS ONE
THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR TWO OH
TWO. AGAIN THAT'S. ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR TWO- TO SO AS WE
MOVE THROUGH THE HEARING. WILL
BE CALLING OPEN UP THE PHONE
LINES FOR. TELEPHONIC
WITNESSES. WERE OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC. WHO WANT TO
INDICATE SUPPORTER OPPOSITION
TO A BILL AND WE WILL BE USING
THE- THANKS TO THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION THE WITNESS
VIDEO ROOM THAT HAD BEEN SET UP
PREVIOUSLY IS NO LONGER
AVAILABLE. I THINK EVEN THOUGH
THAT HAVE BEEN SET UP FOR MOST
OF PANDEMIC IT WAS HARDLY EVER
IF EVER USE. SO WE'RE GOING TO
WE DO NOT YET HAVE A QUORUM
WE'RE GOING TO START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE WE HAVE A CONSENT
AGENDA AND SEVENTEEN ITEMS TO
BE HEARD SO WE HAVE QUITE A BIT
OF BUSINESS. TO DO TODAY. IN
FILE ORDER I SEE MISTER BECKER
IS HERE SENATOR BACKER. SO ONCE
YOU COME FOR THIS IS OUR ITEM
NUMBER TWO. SB FIVE NINETY WHAT.
SHARE. IT'S NOT ON. TESTING
HERE YES. TWENTY MISTER TANER
PRESENT TO THE SIMPLE JUDICIARY
FOR THE TIME. AT HOUSING MODELS
ADDRESS ISOLATION OFTEN SEEN IN
SENIORS. WELL SUPPORTING FOR
YOUTH AS A TRANS OUT OF THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM. AND
ESTABLISH A LIVES INDEPENDENT
ADULTS. THE CITY OF EMORY'S
MEMORY FREE HAS AN INTEREST
HOUSING. FOR THEIR COMMUNITY
THAT IS A 100% AFFORDABLE
INCLUDE SIXTY EIGHT UNITS
PROVIDE SENIORS AND TRANSITION
AGE YOUTH THE PROBLEM IS RIGHT
NOW. THAT FOR HOUSING PROJECTS
WERE SENIORS THAT USED TAX
CREDITS WHICH IS NEARLY ALL
SUCH PROJECTS. ARE PROHIBITED
FROM INCLUDING OTHER TYPES OF
FORMAL UNITS IN THE SAME
BUILDING. SO DESPITE WELL
DOCUMENTED SOCIAL AND HEALTH
BENEFITS FOR SENIORS AND YOUTH.
AFFORDABLE INTERGENERATIONAL
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS ARE
EFFECTIVELY PROHIBITED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS BILL ALLOWS
TAX CREDIT FINANCED AFFORDABLE
GENERATIONAL HOUSING PROJECTS.
A PROVIDED AT LEAST 80% UNITS
OCCUPIED BY SENIORS IN UP 220%
UNITS. ARE FOR TRANSITIONAL AGE
YOUTH. IT IS ENJOYED AND
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT SO
FAR AND HAS NO KNOWN OPPOSITION
AND RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE. ON SB FIVE NINETY ONE. ON
THE LINE WE HAVE COUNCIL MEMBER
JOHN DOUBTERS TO THE CITY OF
EMERYVILLE TESTIFY. THANK YOU
THAT IS THE ONE WITNESS THAT I
HAVE WITH US ON THE TELEPHONE
JOHN VOTERS ARE YOU WITH US.
MISTER CHAIR GOOD MORNING YOU
IN THE OF COMMITTEE AND REMARKS
WILL BE VERY GIVING YOUR LONG
CAL AND THE SUPPORT TO SPELL.
HAD THANK TO SENATOR. AND AS A
CAN THAT BEEN MORE VERY TO
BUILD A MORE INCLUSIVE BAY AREA.
AND ENSURE THAT WE PLACES FOR
ALL DEFERRED ON THE- SO TO THE-
WE ARE WE'RE INTEREST IN. JUST
OF A- THE SOCIAL BENEFITS OF
ENERGY. HOUSING CAN'T POSSIBLY
BE OLD. AND BE REALLY LOOK
FORWARD TO HOPEFULLY HAPPY-
OPPORTUNITY FOR TRANS AGING TO
THE ALONG. AND LEARN FROM AND
ALSO TEACH HOUSING ARE TO IN
THE FUTURE WE ARE WE ARE BOTH
I'M A- DANCE QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
NINETY ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE.
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
MOMENT WHILE WE GATHER THE LINE
NUMBER. ONE SEVENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS UNLESS I MEET AS
CALLING IN ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF OAKLAND BERKELEY PALO
ALTO HALF MOON BAY- THE
NONPROFIT HOUSING ASSOCIATION
OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA MID PENN
HOUSING AND T. H. HOUSING ALL
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU. I THANK YOU THERE
ANYONE I DON'T SEE ANY
INDICATION THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
SITE. SO WHEN I MOVED
OPPOSITION I DO NOT HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION LISTED IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE NINETY
ONE. SEEING NONE AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY SITE. SEE NON
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANY OPPOSITION TO SB.
FIVE NINETY ONE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE NINETY
ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE NINETY
ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN.
ZERO WE HAVE NO ONE IN THE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU. BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM YET SO
WE CAN'T TAKE A MOTION SORRY.
SENATOR YOU MAY CLOSE I THANK
YOU I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
APPRECIATE THE CUSTOMER FROM-
EMERYVILLE AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL IF YOU WE WILL TAKE
THIS UP ONCE WE GET A QUORUM.
OKAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
SURE THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
PRESENTING. RIGHT OFF THE FITS
AND STARTS. MS REYES HAS AJ ARE
SIXTEEN SO WE WILL MOVE AHEAD
WITH THAT. DISTRESS THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I PRESENT
TO YOU A J. R. SIXTEEN WHICH
CALLS ON THE U. S. CONGRESS AND
THE BARDEN HARRIS OF
MINISTRATION TO PASS SENSIBLE
IMMIGRATION REFORM THAT
PROVIDES A PATHWAY TO
CITIZENSHIP FOR THE ELEVEN
MILLION IMMIGRANTS PRESENT IN
THE U. S. CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO
THE LARGEST IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY
WITH APPROXIMATELY. 27% OF
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION BEING
FOREIGN BORN. HALF OF
CALIFORNIA KIDS HAVE AT LEAST
ONE PARENT. WHO IS AN IMMIGRANT
AND ONE OUT OF EVERY TEN
WORKERS IS UNDOCUMENTED. IT HAS
BEEN OVER THIRTY YEARS SINCE
THE LAST IMMIGRATION REFORM THE
SYSTEM IS OUTDATED. IT'S BROKEN
AND IT DOESN'T ADEQUATELY MEET
MEET THE PRESENT TODAY
CHALLENGES. WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
OUR FRIENDS OR FAMILY. AT
ESSENTIAL WORKERS IMMIGRANTS
CONTRIBUTE TO THE VIBRANCY OF
CALIFORNIA AND TO THE FABRIC OF
OUR SOCIETY THERE'S NO BETTER
TIME THAN NW TO PASS SENSIBLE
IMMIGRATION REFORM FOR FOLKS
WHO ARE IN EVERY WAY PART OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE GREATER
UNITED STATES. HERE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF A J. R. SIXTEEN
IS RITA MEDINA FROM CHIEFLAND.
RIGHT THANK YOU SO I DO HAVE
ONCE FOR WITNESS. LISTED FROM
CHIRLA READER MEDINA IS WITH US
ON THE TELEPHONE THIS MEDINA
ARE YOU HERE. WHAT ABOUT CAUGHT
OFF GUARD WITH THE FILE ORDERED.
OKAY IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF A J. R.
SIXTEEN. SEEING NONE OPERATOR
WOULD UTILIZE FOR ANYONE WHO'D
LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT FOR
HDR SIXTY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AJ ARE. ONE
MOMENT. SIXTEEN SO AGAIN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF A J. R. SIX. S. ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. GOOD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF A J. R.
SIXTEEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO
COMMENT IN THE QUEUE. THANK YOU
I MOVED TO OPPOSITION I HAVE NO
OPPOSITION LIZ. IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO'D LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF A J.
R. SIXTEEN. SEEING NONE I SEE
NOTED THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
SITE. OPERATOR WOULD UTILIZE
FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF A J. R.
SIXTY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION H.
A. R. SIXTEEN YOU MAY PRESS
ONE. AND THEN ZERO ACTUALLY I.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AGENT ARE.
IMAGE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
WE HAVE NO ONE IN THE QUEUE.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU YOU MAY
CLOSE THE LINES OPERATOR I WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU
MAKE CLOTHES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON SUCH AN
IMPORTANT PIECE OF. SUCH A
IMPORTANT RESOLUTION ASKING US
CONGRESS TO ACT AND NOW. INDEED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR PRESENT
WE WILL TAKE THAT UP ONCE WE-
END UP WITH A QUORUM. RIGHT
THAT TAKES US TO ITEM NUMBER
THREE SB THREE TWENTY THREE
SENATOR KABIR. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT S.
B. THREE TWO THREE WHICH WOULD
CREATE A HUNDRED TWENTY DAY
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS FOR
CLAIMS AGAINST WATER AND SEWER
AGENCY RATE SETTINGS FIRST I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK ON THE
BILL AND START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS THANK YOU.
WATER AND SEWER UTILITY BUDGETS
ARE FUNDED AS YOU KNOW BY
REVENUE COLLECTED THROUGH
SERVICE RATES THESE RATES
PROVIDE THE FUNDING NECESSARY
TO SUPPLY SAFE DRINKING WATER
UPGRADE AND IMPROVE AGING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND OPERATE
EFFECTIVELY EXISTING LAW ALLOWS
LAWSUITS THAT SEEK REFUNDS OR
SEEK TO INVALIDATE EXISTING
RATE STRUCTURES YEARS AFTER RE
TO BEEN ADOPTED IN COLLECTED.
THESE DELAYED LAWSUITS CAN
THREATEN AN AGENCY'S ABILITY TO
REPAY DEBT GUARANTEED BY
REVENUE FROM THE RATES DERAIL
ONGOING INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS
AND GENERALLY UNDERMINE
AGENCIES ABILITY TO MAINTAIN
STABLE BUDGETS NECESSARY TO
OPERATE EFFECTIVELY. LATELY
THERE HAVE BEEN A NUMBER OF
LEGAL CHALLENGES FILED AGAINST
WATER AND SEWER AGENCIES RATE
STRUCTURE STRUCTURES FOR SOME
OF THE AGENCIES THAT- HAVE BEEN
SUED THE ED THE CHALLENGE RATES
WERE ADOPTED FIVE YEARS PRIOR
TO THE LAWSUIT AND NOW WITH AN
ADDITIONAL STRAIN OF THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER PROHIBITING
WATER SHUT OFFS REGARDLESS OF A
CUSTOMER'S ABILITY TO PAY.
WATER AND SEWER AGENCIES ARE
UNDER CONSTANT FINANCIAL STRAIN
AND CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDS ARE AT RISK THIS BILL IS
MODELED AFTER A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY DAY STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS ENACTED IN TWO
THOUSAND. IN THIS BOOK ELECTRIC
RATES CHECK RATES OR CHARGE. SB
THREE TWENTY THREE ADDS
CONSISTENCY TO EXISTING LAW BY
AUTHORIZING A LOCAL AGENCY OR
INTERESTED PERSON TO BRING A
VALIDATION ACTION IN SPIRIT
COURT. TO DETERMINE THE
VALIDITY OF A FEAT FOR A
CHARTER CHARGE FOR WATER AND
SEWER SERVICE VALIDATION ACTION
IS NOT BROUGHT WITHIN THE
HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS. PARTIES
WOULD BE BETTER BARRED FROM
CHALLENGING THE VALIDITY OF THE
FEAR THE CHARGE. BY ALLOWING
CUSTOMERS TO BRING CHALLENGES
WITHIN A REASONABLE BUT LIMITED
PERIOD OF TIME THIS PROPOSAL
WOULD BALANCE THE INTEREST OF
THE RATE PAYERS WITH THOSE OF
THE PUBLIC WATER AND SEWER
AGENCIES. AND THE CURRENT
PRACTICE. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS CHRIS ANDERSON WITH
AQUA. AND PAUL COOK WHO IS A
GENERAL MANNER MANAGER OF
IRVINE RANCH WATER DISTRICT.
THANK YOU I DO HAVE THOSE TO
SUPPORT LIST WITNESSES LISTED
CHRISTOPHER ANDERSON. OF
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTY WATER
AGENCIES AND THEN PAUL COOK
FROM THE IRVINE RANCH WATER
DISTRICT. CHRISTOPHER ANDERSON
ARE YOU WITH US. YES I AM THE
MORNING CHAIR AND FROM MEMBERS
CHRIS ANDERSON ON BEHALF
ASSOCIATION INVOLVED WITH WATER
AGENCIES PROUD SPONSOR OF SB
THREE TWO THREE. FIRST JUST
WANT TO THANK COMMITTEE STAFFER
THE KIND THEY DEVOTED TO
WORKING WITH US ON THIS BILL.
ALSO WANT TO THANK SENATOR
CABALLERO AND HER STAFF FOR
THEIR DILIGENT WORK AS WELL
STE. SB THREE TWO THREE PASSED
THE SENATE LAST MONTH AND MOST
RECENTLY ASSEMBLY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE WITH BROAD
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT- IN PART
BECAUSE THIS BILL DOES NOT
PRESENT A NEW REVOLUTIONARY
IDEA. ALIGNS WITH LONGSTANDING
PRECEDENT EXISTING LAW HUNDRED
TWENTY DAYS STATURE LIMITATIONS
ALREADY PROVIDED FOR ME ALEXX
BREAKS XP'S ACTUALLY CHARGES.
ANOTHER LOCAL GOVERNMENT FEES
AND CHARGES THE LEGISLATURE
CREATED STATURE LIMITATIONS
FROM IMPORTANT PUBLIC POLICY
WE'VE- RECOGNIZE THE NEED TO
REDUCE FISCAL UNCERTAINTY FOR
PUBLIC AGENCIES THAT PROVIDE
ESSENTIAL GOVERNMENT SERVICES.
SB THREE TWO THREE SIX TO
PROVIDE SIMILAR PROTECTIONS TO
WATER AND SEWER SERVICE. AND
SIMPLY CLOSE THIS GAP IN
EXISTING LAW. AND NEVER TO
ADDRESS OF THE OPPOSITION
CONCERNS. CENTER MENTIONED
WE'RE TAKING AN AMENDMENT THAT
WOULD REQUIRE THE AGENCY TO
INFORM CUSTOMERS OF THIS NEW
LEGAL PROTECTION PRIOR TO THE
ADOPTION OF AN INFRASTRUCTURE.
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL
MAINTAINED DISCONTENT CUSTOMER
PROTECTION ALREADY AFFORDED AND
PROPOSITION TO ANYTHING. OF
NOTE THAT WHILE MANY OTHER
LOCAL GOVERNMENT EVEN CHARGES
HAVE THE PROTECTION OF A
HUNDRED TWENTY DAY SCHEDULE
IMITATIONS NONE ARE SUBJECT
PROP TO EIGHTEEN. AND NONE
REQUIRE AGENCIES TO PROVIDE
WRITTEN NOTICE OF THE STATUE
LIMITATIONS CUSTOMERS. THIS
MEANS THAT THIS THAT THERE WILL
BE AN UNMATCHED LEVEL
TRANSPARENCY AROUND WATER AND
SEWER RATES. IF SB THREE TWO
THREE BECOMES LAW. SIMPLY PUT
STILL STRIKES A BALANCE BETWEEN
PROTECTING THE RIGHTS OF
REPAIRS ON PUBLIC EIGHTY PUBLIC
WATER AND SEWER AGENCIES TO
AVOID UNNECESSARY FINANCIAL
UNCERTAINTY. THREE CENTS
REQUEST PRIVATE. HAPPY ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. M.
POWER COOK ALSO WITH THE- YES
GOOD MORNING CHURCH ON A MEMBER
I'M PAUL COOK OFFERS YOU FELT
DESK ASK THREE TWO THREE WITH
YOU TODAY. I'M THE GENERAL
MANAGER FOR WATER OR A PUBLIC
RETAIL AND AGENCIES SERVING THE
CENTRAL PART OF ORANGE COUNTY
AND ASSIST IN YOUR CONSIDER OF
A THREE TWO. I LIKE THIS THE
VERY INTO PROCESS OF THAT WE
UTILIZE IN A RANGE WATER TO.
PROP TO. REQUIREMENTS OUR IN
THE ANALYSIS EXTENSIVE BUT
THEY'RE ONLY OF OUR PROCESS.
BUT ALL WATER IN WHICH WE
AGENCY HIGHER TO BE THE BEGIN
THE RACING PROCESS A COST OF
SERVICE STUDY. THE DETAILS
EXPLAINS DOLLAR FOR HOW REYES
ARE SET AND HOW ARE ALLOCATE
AMONG. THE OTHER PART TO
EIGHTEEN STRICT OFFICE PRINT
PRINCIPLE. RESETTING IT TO
RIGHT TO ANY BY AND I IS WHERE
WE PUT A SPACE. FOR THE
PROPOSED. HIGHER TO BE THE
EXPLAINS RIGHT POLICY. BECAUSE
THAT'S AND PROPOSED THREE AND
IT PACKS AT. PUBLIC MEETING AT
LEAST NINE FOR A CURRENT RATIO
ACROSS. PARTNERING BEING
CONSIDERED FOR A- WE ALSO
MAILED EACH PROPERTY OR INCOME
IF TO A- NOTE. AT LEAST FORTY
DAYS. TO THE PUBLIC HEARING ON
THE BURKE RAISE. THIS WRITTEN
NOTE PROVIDED ON THE PROPOSED
RAISE ALONG WITH THE READ FOR
IT THE RACE. ONLY AFTER THE
PUBLIC EXTENT PROCESS ARE RIGHT.
FREON BUYER. BECAUSE IT IS VERY
TRANSPARENT. WE THAT IT HUNDRED
DAYSAFTER LIMITATION STRUCTURE
THE APPROPRIATE BALANCE. WORK
PROMPT REYES CHANNEL. AND ALLOW
YOU TO FISH TIME FOR A REPAIR.
DEGENERATES INCLUDE ELECTED
THANKS COVER YOUR FOR. AS THREE
TWO THREE I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT YOU SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY. AND I'M GLAD TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS MAY HAVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO ANY THIS IS WHO I
INDICATES SUPPORT FOR THREE
THREE OR ANYONE YEAH HERE ROOM
WHO LIKE TO AND OF FOR US THREE
TWO THREE. SEEING NONE THE
REMOTE TESTING CREATES. C. NONE
OPERATOR WHICH OPEN FOR ANY WHO
ELECTED TO SUPPORT FOR SB TWO
THREE WE ARE TO NAY OF PHILLY
AND SO ONLY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF SB THREE TWO THREE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
COME IN TO SUPPORT OF SB THREE
TWO THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE.
AND THEN ZERO. NINE FORTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS KAREN LAYING ON BEHALF
OF THE SOUTH SAN JOAQUIN
IRRIGATION DISTRICTS AND
SUPPORT THIS MORNING AFTER I
DON'T THINK YOU. NINE EIGHTY
NINE YOUR MIND IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING WITH YOU
SHARING COMMITTEE MEMBERS
CHOPPING CALANTZOPOULOS ALAMEDA
COUNTY WATER DISTRICT AND
STRONG SUPPORT ABOUT THE PEOPLE.
THREE TWO THREE. BOB LINES FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING SURE
MEMBERS DEREK ALL BE ON THE
HAVE THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
TWO THREE THANK YOU. NINE
SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CHEN MEMBERS
HERE ROBERT HALF OF THE THIRTY
SANTA ROSA AND THE COURTS BILL.
NINE ONE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I DON'T KNOW
BUT DIED WITH CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. LINE ONE OH FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. JEANNIE MINOR ON BEHALF
OF SANTA MARGARITA WATER
DISTRICT AND EASTERN MUNICIPAL
WATER DISTRICT IN SUPPORT THINK
OF MUCH. NINE ONE ELEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MISTER TURNER
MEMBER CALL THE AT THE LEAST
SHOP ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
SANTA MONICA IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NINE FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN BRUCE ERIKA
DAWN ON BEHALF OF THE ALL THE
LINDA WATER DISTRICT IN A
SUPPORTIVE AMENDED POSITION FOR
THE REASONS OUTLINED IN OUR
WATER THANK YOU. NINE SIXTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU CHANGE AND I
COULD WITH ADULTS CAN GILBERT
ROBESON SMITH ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU. NINE ONE OH
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WILLIAM THE NEXT
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AND
THREE MILLION ON BEHALF OF THE
MESA WATER DISTRICT AND THE TO
ALL THE UTILITIES DISTRICT WE
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
COMMITTEE ON THE AMENDMENT TO
THIS BILL HOWEVER WE STILL
RESPECT WE REMAIN IN A SPORT
AMENDED POSITION. AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU. NINE OH THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU CHAIR NUMBERS
GEOMETRY DAY ON BEHALF OF-
TIDEWATER DISTRICT IN FORT YOU.
NINE ONE OH SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WILL
RELOCATE ON BEHALF OF ONE NOT
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE SIXTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BY THE TIME KENNEDY WITH
THE RAINBOW MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT AND THE SANTA COUNTY
WATER AUTHORITY IN SUPPORT.
NINE NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
SURE NUMBERS NAMES AVAILABLE
OUT OF NOT BE HAPPY THAT HE
SCORED COUNTY WATER DISTRICT
AND THE CITY BREA TRACY AND
SANTANA ALL. THANK YOU. NINE SO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS NOT
SUCCESSFUL IN MARIN MUNICIPAL
WATER DISTRICT IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NINE SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NO
AUTOMATIC ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF RED CELL IN THE PARK. NINE
SIXTY FIVE YOUR NAME IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS BRYAN SANDERS WITH THE
CITY OF SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT
OF SB THREE TWO THREE THANK YOU.
NINE ONE OH ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CAROLINE JENSEN WITH KP
PUBLIC AFFAIRS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. ONE SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. AMONG
THE CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS JIM
LEACH WITH THE SANTA MARGARITA
WATER DISTRICT IN SUPPORT. NINE
EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR GREG MORRISON
REPRESENTING ELSER VALLEY
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT. LINE ONE OH TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ID PRINT WITH THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY WATER AUTHORITY IN
SUPPORT. EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING GREINER JACKING WITH
THE REGIONAL WATER AUTHORITY IN
SUPPORT. LINE ONE THIRTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS SHARON GREEN
WITH THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SANITATION DISTRICT AND I'M IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MY ONE
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN CLICK
ON. ALL GOOD MORNING DENNIS ALL
BE ON THE WOULD CALIFORNIA GETS
ON BEHALF OF SANTA CLARITA
VALLEY WATER AGENCY AND WE
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE ONE
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF HIS
STAFF A LOT SO ON BEHALF OF THE
INLAND EMPIRE UTILITIES AGENCY
AND CUCAMONGA VALLEY WATER
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT IN
Q. THANK YOU OPERATOR SO WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO. OPPOSITION
I HAVE TO OPPOSITION WITNESSES
LISTED VANESSA CHAVEZ OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS AND THEN SCOTT KAUFMAN
OF THE HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION. THE MESSAGE TRAVIS
ARE YOU WITH US. HEY GOOD
MORNING JERRY MEMBERS BUT AT
THE CHAVEZ WHAT THE CALIFORNIA.
OF REALTORS FIRST I WOULD LIKE
TO BEGIN BY THANKING THE
SENATOR AND HER STAFF THE CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE FACETED DILIGENT
WORK ON THE AMENDMENT. J. R.
HAS REVIEWED THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENT AS LISTED IN THE
CANADIAN OFFICE AND WILL BE
TAKING A NEUTRAL POSITION ON
THE BILLBOARD BE AMENDMENTS
AREN'T GRANT. AGAIN WE ARE
APPRECIATIVE OF THE AUTHOR
EFFORTS TO ADDRESS ARGUMENTS
PRESSING CONCERNS ON THE BILL
WHICH DEALT WITH PROVIDING YOU
TIME NOTICE TO HOMEOWNER AND
TENANTS OF THE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY DAYS AFTER THE- TO
CHALLENGE WATER AND SEWER RATES
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU. THE HOWEVER ARE A SCOTT
KAUFMAN. THE MORNING THANK YOU
FOR THE UP TO SPEAK WITH YOU-
PURPOSE OF ACT WERE PROVIDES
BILL OF PUBLIC BONTA ABILITY TO
SOUTH OTHER EVIDENCE OF
INDEBTEDNESS IT WAS NEVER MEANT
TO FORECLOSE OTHER CASES FROM
COURT. IN IN IN EQUITY IN THE
LAW TODAY WE FEEL VALIDATION
SET TO TURN OUR ON THIRD AND
I'LL DO PROCESS THAT EVEN THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT
ACKNOWLEDGED CAN HAVE THE
EFFECT. OF CEMENT INTO LAW
ILLEGAL GOVERNMENT ACTOR THAN
FOREVER INSULATED FROM JUDICIAL
REVIEW. THAT IS WHY I TO THEM
IN AGENCIES SHOULD BE REQUIRED
TO BRING ITS OWN VALIDATION
ACTION WITHIN A HUNDRED TWENTY
DAYS IN ORDER TO OBTAIN THE
PROTECTION. AND GIVE TAXPAYERS
PROPER NOTICE SHOULD ACTION BE
NECESSARY THE AGENCY WILL TELL
YOU THAT THIS IS COST
PROHIBITIVE. BUT IS FAR MORE
COST PROHIBITIVE FOR AN
INDIVIDUAL TAXPAYER TO BRING
SUCH AN ACTION AND EVEN MORE SO
FOR TAX. FOR RATEPAYERS TO PAY
POTENTIALLY ILLEGAL P.
INSULATED FROM CHALLENGES BY
THE ABSENCE OF ANY REVIEW BY A
COURT. WHY THE CANCER CASE
AGAINST EIGHTY EIGHTY ONE WATER
DISTRICT BEING USED TO JUSTIFY
THIS BILL. IS AN ANOMALY BEING
CHALLENGED ON JURISDICTION.
GENERALLY LITIGATING WATER RATE
IS INCREDIBLY CONSUMING AND
ISN'T DONE WITHOUT GOOD
MOTIVATION AND COMMUNITY
SUPPORT. THE SUPREME COURT
HASN'T AT VALIDATION STATUTES
AND CITY OF ONTARIO V. SUPERIOR
COURT. WHERE IT SAID THAT SOME
STATUTES WERE OF DOUBTFUL
CONSTITUTIONALITY. BUT RECENTLY
GRANTED REVIEW IN DAVIS HE
FRESNO UNITED. ARE FRESNO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND ANYONE ELSE
WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE
OPPOSITION TO SB THREE TWENTY
THREE ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. SEE NON REMOTE TESTIMONY
SITES. SEE NON OPERATOR WOULD
YOU OPEN ALLIANCE FOR ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO DECADE
OPPOSITION TO SB THREE TWO
THREE AND AGAIN WE'RE TAKING
NAME AFFILIATION AND- THAT THEY
ARE OPPOSED. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE TWO
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE TWO
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THE TIME. WE HAVE
NO ONE IN THE COMIC QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU OPERATOR
YOU MAY CLOSE THE LINES THEN
FOR SB THREE TWO THREE OFFERING
BACK TO. THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. CIGNA
SENATOR YOU MAKE. THIS DAVIS.
GOOD MORNING. THANK YOU SENATOR
I JUST WANTED TO LET YOU KNOW I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL
BUT I. ASK THAT YOU HOWEVER DO
WORK FOR THE OPPOSITION
ESPECIALLY WITH THE VALIDATION
CONCERNED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE RIGHT
SIGNAL ON SENATOR YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
PRESENT THIS BILL AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND THAT THE BOTTOM LINE
IS THAT- NOT CONTINUE TO WORK
AS YOU SEE ON BASED ON THE
REALTORS NEUTRAL POSITION
ANYTHING THAT I CAN DO TO MAKE
IT CLEAR THAT WE WANT
TRANSPARENCY WE WANT THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE THAT
ACTUALLY KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON-
AND DIED- ALTHOUGH PROPOSITION
TWO EIGHTEEN IS- CUMBERSOME.
AND HAS A NUMBER OF HEARINGS
AND NOTICE REQUIREMENTS- THIS.
THIS PROTECTS THE PUBLIC SO
THAT THEY KNOW EXACTLY WHAT'S
GOING ON MAY NOT LIKE THE FEE
INCREASE BUT THEY THEY WILL
HEAR NUMEROUS TIMES. AS MANY OF
US HAVE WHEN WE GET THE BILL
THAT TELLS US. WE'RE THINKING
ABOUT IT WE'VE DONE THE
ANALYSIS THIS IS WHAT IT'S
GOING TO COST WE WERE GOING TO
INSTITUTE THIS YOU HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY SHOW UP AND
PROTEST. AND NOW HERE HERE IT
IS AND WE'RE WORK IMPLEMENTING
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE BUT TODAY. THANK YOU CENTER
AND WE HAVE YET TO ESTABLISH
FORM SO WE WILL TAKE THAT UP
WHEN WE- FIRST GOT MORE THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU SENATE ARCHULETA OUR ITEM
NUMBER ONE SB. THREE NINETY
TWO. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. WOULD LIKE
TO START THANK IN THE CHAIR AND
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH ME ON
THIS BILL AND I'M HAPPY TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU. SENATE
BILL THREE NINETY TWO WILL
IMPROVE ACCESSIBILITY TO AN
IMPORTANT DOCUMENTS AND REDUCE
DELIVERY COSTS BY REQUIRING
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION TO
COMMUNICATE WITH HOMEOWNERS VIA
EMAIL UNLESS OF RESIDENT
CHOOSES TO RECEIVE
COMMUNICATION VIA ANOTHER
METHOD. SUCH AS TRADITIONAL
MALE CALIFORNIA COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENTS ARE GOVERNED BY
THEIR RESPECTIVE HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION WHICH ARE REQUIRED
TO FOLLOW THE REGULATIONS AND
GUIDELINES ESTABLISHED IN THEIR
INDIVIDUAL BYLAWS AND UNDER THE
STATE'S DAVIS STERLING COMMON
INTEREST DEVELOPMENT ACT. UNDER
THE DAVIS STARTING ACT
ASSOCIATIONS ARE REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE MEMBERS WITH NECESSARY
DOCUMENTS INCLUDING ANNUAL
BUDGETS POLICY STATEMENTS OR
NOTICES VIA FIRST CLASS MAIL
UNLESS ELECTRONIC DELIVERY IS
OTHERWISE REQUESTED BY THE
INDIVIDUAL. PREVIOUS
LEGISLATION THAT SOUGHT TO
PROTECT HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION
MEMBERS FROM EXORBITANT FEES
RELATED TO DOCUMENT DELIVERY BY
LIMITING THE AMOUNT OF
ASSOCIATIONS CAN CHARGE FOR
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
PROCESSING PREPARING AND
DELIVERING THESE DOCUMENTS.
ADDITIONALLY TO FURTHER
INCREASE INFORMATION
ACCESSIBILITY THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED SB THREE TO THREE AND
TWENTY NINETEEN WHICH REQUIRED
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATIONS TO
DELIVER MEMBERSHIP BOARD
ELECTION RULES BY INDIVIDUAL
DELIVERY OR BY POSTING ON A
WEBSITE. IN A POST COLD AT
NINETEEN WORLD INTERNET WEBSITE
AND EMAIL COMMUNICATIONS HAS
PROVEN TO BE EFFECTIVE AND
VITAL IN KEEPING THE PUBLIC
INFORMED AND IN TOUCH WITH ONE
ANOTHER. UNDER CURRENT LAW THE
DEFAULT DOCUMENT DELIVERY
METHOD IS TRADITIONAL MAIL. SB
THREE NINETY TWO MANDATES
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATIONS TO
ELECTRONICALLY DELIVER NOTICES
AND DOCUMENTS TO ITS MEMBERS
BEGINNING JANUARY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY THREE IF A RESIDENT POPS
IN TO RECEIVE EMAIL
COMMUNICATIONS IT FOR RESIDENT
CHOOSES NOT TO OPT IN THE
ASSOCIATION WILL CONTINUE TO
DELIVER THEIR DOCUMENTS BY MAIL.
THIS BILL IS PIVOTAL. TO
ENSURING THE DOCUMENT
DELIVERIES AT HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATIONS ARE KEPT UP AND
KEPT UP TO DATE WITH IN OUR
EVER CHANGING LANDSCAPE OF
INFORMATION SHARING AND NEW
TECHNOLOGIES. THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
PASSED OFF THE SENATE FLOOR
WITH NO NO VOTES FOR THESE
REGIONS I APPROPRIATE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. AND
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL IS JENNIFER CIVIC
REPRESENTING THE SPONSOR OF THE
BILL THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR I DO HAVE ONE
WITNESS LISTED JENNIFER SPECTOR
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS WITH US ON THE
TELEPHONE. JENNIFER JENNIFER
SUCKER YOU WITH US. I AM NOT
SURE THANK YOU. MISTER SHARE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
JENNIFER SLACK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE CHAIR AND- COMMITTEE
NOT- COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS FOR
ALL THEIR WORK ON THE BILL WE
REALLY APPRECIATE HIM UNTIL
HE'S SHOCKED IN THE BILL WE ARE
THE PROBLEM TO THE BEST BETWEEN
NINETY TWO. EXISTING LAW
REQUIRES PROPERTY OWNERS TO
ANNUALLY PROVIDE. AN H. AWAY
UPDATED CONTACT INFORMATION BUT
DOES NOT REQUIRE HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATIONS TO TRANSMIT
INFORMATION TO HOMEOWNERS VIA
EMAIL EVEN IF THAT IS THE
HOMEOWNERS PREFERRED DELIVERY
METHOD. SB THREE NINETY TO
RESOLVE THIS ISSUE BY
PERMITTING PROPERTY OWNERS TO
FIND EMAIL AS ONE OF THEIR TO
PREFERRED COMMUNICATION METHODS
WELCOME TELLING HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATIONS TO COMMUNICATE
WITH HOMEOWNERS VIA EMAIL. IF
THAT IS THEIR CHOICE. UNDER THE
MEASURE PER OWNERS CHOOSE
PROVIDING EMAIL TO THE
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION BUT MAY
ALSO REVOKE THEIR CONSENT TO
RECEIVING COMMUNICATION. BY
EMAIL AT ANY TIME. WHICH OF THE
GIVEN THE TECHNOLOGICAL
ADVANCES OVER THE LAST THIRTY
YEARS AND RESPONSE TO THE
GLOBAL PANDEMIC PANDEMIC WHICH
HIGHLIGHTED THE DEFICIENCIES IN
OUR PHYSICAL MAIL DELIVERY
SYSTEM. EMAIL DELIVERY MUST BE
AN OPTION DRIVEN BY HOMEOWNERS
NOT HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATIONS
PREFERENCE. SB THREE NINETY TWO
WILL IMPROVE ACCESSIBILITY TO
IMPORTANT DOCUMENTS WHILE
REDUCING DELIVERY COSTS BY
REQUIRING HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATIONS TO COMMUNICATE
WITH HOMEOWNERS VIA EMAIL. WITH
THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR ABOUT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU DON'T ANY OTHER WITNESSES.
LISTED IN SUPPORT IS THERE
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
INDICATE SUPPORT FOR SB THREE
NINETY TWO HERE IN THE CHAMBER.
RIGHT SEE NONE THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY SITE. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR SB THREE NINETY TWO.
ANYONE WANTING TO INDICATE
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
SB THREE NINETY TWO THOUSAND
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE NINETY TWO.
S. ONE AND THEN. ZERO ONE
MOMENTWHILE WE GATHER THE LINE
NUMBER. SHE. NINE SEVENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH THE FIFTY LLENA
MARINA DEL REY A FORMER BOARD
MEMBER AYE OPPOSED AB THREE
NINE TWO. AND THERE'S A LOT OF
STATIC ON THE LINE AND TIME
SOMEBODY WILL. TRY TO CONGRESS
EVERYTHING YOU SAY AND SOMEBODY
KEEPS ON MOVING BANKING ON THE
ON THE THANK YOU THANK YOU. SH.
ONE MOMENT WE DO HAVE- TWO MORE
LINES INTO. YOU. AND ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF ACTUALLY THREE NINETY TWO
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ONE NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS JACK
QUITE AND AS PRESIDENT OF THE
SEVEN HUNDRED UNIT HLA IN UNION
CITY ALAMEDA COUNTY I STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB THREE NINE ONE.
PLEASE VOTE NO ON THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND ONE
MORE MOMENT FROM MY NUMBERS.
NINE THIRTY TWO. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
THIRTY TWO YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SORRY I WISH
TO OPPOSED THEY TOLD ME TO
CHECK BACK IN THEM. OKAY THANK
YOU. NINE FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS GUS FEDERAL
BOARD. I MEAN H. O. A HOMEOWNER
AND FORMER ELECTED H. AWAY
DIRECTOR AND VOTER IN PLASTER
COUNTY- MY AFFILIATION WITH
BOTH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF RETIRED AMERICANS AND THE
CENTER FOR CALIFORNIA HOMEOWNER
ASSOCIATION LAW BOTH CONSUMER
PROTECTION ADVOCATE
ORGANIZATIONS SUPPORT IS IN
OPPOSITION CAN I ASK YOUR NO
VOTE ON THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. OKAY WELL TO NOT WE
HAVE NO MORE COMMON IN THE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
BEFORE WE MOVED OPPOSITION WILL
TAKE A POSITIVE STEP WAS A
QUORUM DID YOU CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE. YEAH HAVE. SALES DOWN
HERE. GALLAGHER CHAU CHIU
DAVIES GONZALEZ HOLDEN KALRA.
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN REYES HERE.
WE DO A REPORT THANK YOU RIGHT
WE WILL MOVE TO OPPOSITION OF
SB THREE NINETY TWO I HAVE ONE
OPPOSITION WHICH IS LISTED
MARJORIE MURRAY OF THE CENTER
OF OUR SERVICE. HE OPERATOR
THERE SO MANY- LINED UP AND DID
YOU. YOU COMPLETE. ONE MOMENT I
WILL SILENCE THAT LINE. THAT
LINE HAS. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING CAN YOU HEAR ME THIS IS
MARKET VERY YES GO CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES WE CARE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU HI GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN STONE AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. MARJORIE MURRAY
FROM THE CENTER FOR CALIFORNIA
HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATION LAW
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION TO SB
THREE NINE TWO- THIS BILL.
TRIES TO LAY OUT LEGALLY
ACCEPTABLE METHODS. FOR A
HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATION TO
DELIVER DOCUMENTS TO WITH. SO
THIS IS AN EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
BILL. THE BILL IDENTIFIES ONE
METHOD OF DELIVERY WHICH IS
EMAIL HOWEVER IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT THAT METHOD THE FRAME BY
THE STATE AND FEDERAL PRIVACY
LAWS GOVERNING ELECTRONIC
COMMUNICATIONS. WE THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR AMENDING THE BILL TO
DATE SO THAT IT AT LEAST
REQUIRED BASIC KIND OF PLANTS
BY THE HOMEOWNER. THE FOUR
DOCUMENTS CAN BE SENT
ELECTRONICALLY HOWEVER ONE
STATE AND FEDERAL PRIVACY LAWS
HAVE OTHER REQUIREMENTS.
GOVERNING ELECTRONIC
COMMUNICATION WHICH ARE NOT.
AND WHICH WILL SEND WHICH STILL
CONCERNED THAT. THE FIRST OF
THESE IS DISCLOSURE AS WE KNOW
FROM GETTING HANDLED. FROM OUR
BANKS AND FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS. WE HAVE TO GET A
NOTICE ANNUALLY ON HOW OUR
EMAIL ADDRESS IS GOING TO BE
USED BY THE PERSON OR ENTITY IN
POSSESSION OF IT. IN THE CASE
OF THE HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATION
HOMEOWNERS NEED TO KNOW TO WHAT
THIRD PARTY THE ASSOCIATION
MIGHT DISSEMINATE. OUR PERSONAL
PRIVATE INFORMATION THAT IS OUR
EMAIL ADDRESS. AS I SAID
THERE'S NOTHING FAKE AND
FEDERAL LAWS REQUIRE THAT THERE
BE AN ANNUAL PRIVACY NOTICE
DISSEMINATED BY ANY BUSINESS
ENTITY THAT COLLECT THIS
INFORMATION AND SB THREE NINE
TWO SO FAR HAVE NOT DEALT WITH
THIS ISSUE. OUR CORE IN
OPPOSITION WHICH IS THE
CALIFORNIA FOR RETIRED
AMERICANS BECAUSE THE FACTUALLY
CONCERNED. THAT THE EMAIL
ADDRESSES OF SENIORS BE
PROTECTED BECAUSE EMAIL ADDRESS.
AS HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED BY ALL
KINDS OF RESEARCH ON SENIOR
FRAUD. SENIORS EMAIL ADDRESS IS
A SURE ROUTE TO DESCRIBING
SENIORS OF IDENTITY PROTECTION
AND SO ON. AND FINALLY SB THREE
NINE TWO DOES NOT ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THERE ARE OTHER LAWS THAT
SPECIFICALLY REQUIRE CERTAIN
KINDS OF DELIVERY FOR CERTAIN
KINDS OF DOCUMENTS SPECIFICALLY
FOR ILLEGAL DOCUMENTS. AFTER
ALREADY IF THE REQUIREMENT THAT
LEGAL NOTICES LIKE I NOTICE OF
ASSESSMENT BLAME HE SAID IN A
PERFECT METHOD AND THAT METHOD
IS NOT EMAIL DELIVER. IT HAD TO
BE BY CERTIFIED MAIL SO ANY
LEGAL DOT. THE WITH A STEP
COLOR FOR COAL NOTE- NOTICE OF
AND ON NO ARE ALREADY LAID OUT
INSTEAD. AND WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE AT THREE NINE TWO OF TO.
THAT NO LEGAL DOCUMENTS HAVE
THEIR OWN. AND STATUTORILY
REQUIRED MODES OF DELIVERY-
UNTIL SUCH TIME AS WE CAN GET
THE BILL FURTHER AMENDED THREE
AND A CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR
RETIRED AMERICANS REMAIN IN
OPPOSITION. SO WE ARE HOPEFUL
THAT WE CAN GET THE BILL
FURTHER AMENDED. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE
TO INDICATE OPPOSITION TO SB
THREE NINETY TWO. RIGHT SEE
NONE. OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN
THE LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO. INDICATE OPPOSITION TO
SB THREE NINETY TWO AGAIN OR
TAKING NAME AFFILIATION. AND
OPPOSITION THAT WOULD BE IN
ADDITION TO THOSE WHO CALLED IN
ON THE SUPPORT LINE BUT WE'RE
ACTUALLY OPPOSE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB THREE
NINETY TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF THE THREE
NINETY TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
NINE THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THIS
IS GAIL MARTIN IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY- I AM ASKING YOUR TIRED
PERSON I AM A FORMER BOARD
MEMBER I. E. H. ANNIE. THANK
YOU WHERE I LIVE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. MY. NINETEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS THANK YOU I SPOKE EARLIER
IN THE ROUND SET SESSION THINK
I'LL WANT ONE OF YOUR- AND THEN
I. THANK YOU WE DID GET YOUR
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. NINE
FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
MARGARET SWEENEY AND I'M A
FORMER BOARD MEMBER AND I AM
OPPOSED TO DISPEL. THANK YOU.
NINE THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS LINDA BROWN
I'VE OWNED A CONDOMINIUM IN SAN
FRANCISCO SINCE NINETEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN AND SERVED ON THE
BOARD TWICE I OPPOSE THIS BILL
AS WRITTEN AND ENCOURAGE
APPROPRIATE AMEND THAT THANK
YOU. Q. NINE THIRTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS MEREDITH MILLER I'M A
HOMEOWNER IN MORGAN HILL SANTA
CLARA COUNTY I ALSO OPPOSE THIS
BILL IN ITS CURRENT FORM THANK
YOU. AND ONE MOMENT WHILE WE
GATHER A FEW MORE LINE NUMBERS.
MY TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU.
MISTER LAWRENCE LUCARELLI I'M A
HOMEOWNER AND ALSO SERVED ON
THE BOARD AT SPRING. ONE
SPRINGS HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION
IN SAN DIEGO CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY I'M ALSO A SENIOR AND
I DO OPPOSE THE BILL ENTRANCES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
NINE THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. NINE THIRTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES THIS IS LOUISE
BEACONS IN SAN MATTEO ARMA AND
H. AWAY RESIDENT- I OPPOSE THE
BILL AS WRITTEN AND I WOULD
LIKE TO SEE IT- RE WRITTEN I
THINK MARJORIE MARIE THANK YOU
OUTLINED IT VERY VERY WELL I.
DON'T THINK ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY AT THIS POINT JUST AN
INDICATION OF A POSITION. WHICH
YOU HAVE DONE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT IN Q. I THANK YOU I
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE THEN FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SINGER SENATOR DALE
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU WE DO
HAVE A MOTION. IS THERE A
SECOND. SECOND THANK YOU
SENATOR YOU MAY CLOSE YEAH
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS-
THIS BILL WILL MAINTAIN PRIVACY
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW THE
HOMEOWNERS TO HAVE THE OPTION
TO OPT IN OPT OUT IN UNDER
CURRENT LAW THAT THEY MAINTAIN
THE RECORDS OF THE HOMEOWNERS
AND PERSONALLY IDENTIFYING
INFORMATION- THE HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATIONS ALL HAVE BEEN
DOING A GREAT JOB WITH THAT
EMAILS ARE PART OF THAT
INFORMATION BUT THIS WILL OPEN
THE DOOR IF THEY WISH TO DO IT.
IN THAT MANNER AND- PROPERTY
OWNERS AND UNDER SB THREE
NINETY TWO WILL STILL HAVE THE
DISCRETION TO SELECT A
PREFERRED DELIVERY METHOD AND
THE ADDED BENEFITS SO THEY WILL
ALWAYS HAVE THAT CHOICE AND
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE STONE HI STONE AYE
GALLAGHER. CHAU CHIU. IES
DAVIES I'D GONZALEZ. HOLDEN
KALRA. KALRA AYE KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN REYES ON RACE I.
THE BILL NEEDS TO SO WE PUT IT
ON CALL. VERY GOOD THANK YOU
MEASURE THANK YOU. WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO OR ITEM NUMBER FOR SB
THREE THIRTY TWO SENATOR DODD.
THANK. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS SB THREE THREE TO
ESTABLISH AS A GROSS NEGLIGENCE
STANDARD TO PROTECT PRESCRIBED
FIRE BURN BOSSES FOR FIRE
SUPPRESSION COSTS RESULTING
FROM THE OCCURRENCE OF A
PRESCRIBED FIRE LET ME BEGIN BY
OFFERING THE AMENDMENTS
DESCRIBED ON PAGE EIGHT OF THE
ANALYSIS AND THANK THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS FOR THEIR
HELP AND FINE TUNING OF THE
LANGUAGE THE GORGING MORE USE
OF THE PRESCRIBED FIRE THAT
CURRENTLY OCCURS THIS STATE IS
THE GOAL OF SB THREE THREE TWO.
PRESCRIBED FIRES TYPICALLY DONE
OR SUPERVISED BY A BIRD BOSS
WHO IS QUALIFIED TO PLAN
ORGANIZE AND EXECUTE WHAT ARE
KNOWN AS PRESCRIBED OR
CONTROLLED BURNS. DESCRIBE
BURNING IS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT COST EFFECTIVE TOOLS
USED TO REDUCE WILDFIRE RISK.
WITH CALIFORNIA HAVING SUFFERED
MORE THAN A HUNDRED FORTY EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS OF WILDFIRE
LOSSES OVER THE LAST DECADE. IT
IS PARAMOUNT THAT WE EMPLOY
EVERY EFFECTIVE TOOL TO REDUCE
THE FREQUENCY INTENSITY IN THE
SCALE OF FUTURE WILDFIRES.
EXPERTS TELL US THAT CALIFORNIA
SHOULD BE TREATING A MINIMUM OF
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES OF
WILDLAND WITH PRESCRIBED FIRE
EACH YEAR. HOWEVER CALIFORNIA
STRUGGLES TO TREAT A FRACTION
OF THAT WHAT OTHER STATES SUCH
AS FLORIDA WHICH IS A GROSS
NEGLIGENCE STANDARD THREE AS
MUCH AS TWO MILLION ACRES
ANNUALLY. ONE MIGHT ASK WHY IS
CALIFORNIA LIKE WELL ONE OF THE
PRIMARY CONCERNS WERE
PRESCRIBED FIRE PRACTITIONERS
IS THAT THEY WILL BE BILLED OF
CAL FIRE OTHER AGENCIES PROVIDE
SUPPRESSION SUPPORT ON A BURKE.
THE CONCERNS OVER HIGH FIRE
SUPPRESSION COSTS ENCOURAGES
THE PRACTITIONER AND LANDOWNER
TO AVOID USING PRESCRIBED FIRE
IN THIS IS COUNTERPRODUCTIVE TO
GETTING MORE LAND TREATED. SB
THREE THREE TWO WOULD SPECIFY
THE TRAINED AND CERTIFIED BURKE
BOSSES- PERSONS THEY SUPERISE
PROPERTY OWNERS TO HIRE BIRD
BOSSES AND DATE OF AMERICAN
CULTURAL BURNERS ARE SHIELDED
FROM FIRE SUPPRESSION COSTS
UNLESS THEY CONDUCT A BURN IN A
GROSSLY NEGLIGENT MANNER. A
BIRD BOSS WOULD STILL BE LIABLE
FOR SUPPRESSION COSTS AT THE
ACTED RECKLESSLY BUT IF THE
BIRD BOSSES CONDUCTED WORK FOR
PUBLIC BENEFIT USING THE BEST
MANAGEMENT PRACTICES INC
CONSISTENT WITH A BURN PERMIT
THEY WILL NOT BE LIABLE FOR
THESE RARE. BUT COSTLY
SUPPRESSION CUT EXPENSES SB
THREE THREE TWO HAS BROAD
SUPPORT FROM ENVIRONMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBES THE TIMBER INDUSTRY
PROPERTY CASUALTY INSURERS FIRE
AGENCIES AND MORE RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR ABOUT. THANK YOU WE DO
HAVE A MOTION IS THERE A
SECOND. SECOND AND THE SECOND
THANK YOU WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT I HAVE. TO
LISTED MICHAEL WARA OF THE
CRIME AND ENERGY POLICY PROGRAM
AND LINDA QUINN DAVIDSON FOR
THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
PRESCRIBED FIRE COUNCIL.
MICHAEL WHERE ARE YOU ON THE
LINE. I AM CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
GO AHEAD PLEASE. OKAY GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OBJECTS RIGHT GOOD MORNING AND
THANK THE ARCHITECT BY TODAY ON
SB THREE THREE TWO MY NAME IS
MICHAEL WAR I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
THE CLIMB ENERGY POLICY PROGRAM
WHICH IS TYPICALLY ENVIRONMENT
AT STANFORD UNIVERSITY. I ALSO
SERVICE THE SENATE APPOINTEE TO
THE CALIFORNIA CATASTROPHE
RESPONSE COUNCIL THE OVERSIGHT
BOARD CALIFORNIA WILDFIRE. I
COMMON TODAY REFLECT MY OWN
VIEWS AND NOT THOSE OF MY
EMPLOYER THE WILDFIRE FIND. THE
CALIFORNIA EARTHQUAKE AUTHORITY.
PRESCRIBED FIRE PROVIDES LARGE
AND GROWING BENEFIT CITY
CALIFORNIA GET THE LIABILITY
REGIME WE HAVE TREATED
PRIMARILY AS AN ACTIVITY WITH
PRIVATE BENEFITS. THIS BILL
TAKE A MODEST STEP TOWARDS
CHANGING BY ALLOWING FOR BURNS
THEIR PLAN BY CERTIFIED BROWN
BOSSES AND RECEIVE ALL REQUIRED
PERMITS TO BENEFIT FROM CAL
FIRE SUPPRESSION. UNLESS THEY
ARE CONDUCTING A RECKLESS
MANNER. IT'S IMPORTANT
EMPHASIZED THE BILL CONTAINS A
NUMBER OF GUARD RAILS TO
PREVENT TO BROAD APPLICATION OF
THIS LIABILITY REALLY. I WON'T
BE ABLE TO GO SET FIRE TO A
PILOT BRUSH IN MY BACKYARD
CLEAN RELIEF UNDER THIS
LEGISLATION ONLY BURNS PLAN BY
EXPERTS AND CONDUCTED BY
EXPERIENCED PERSONNEL SUBJECT
TO ANY APPLICABLE PERMITS
REQUIRED TO CARRY. IN A LOCAL
AIR DISTRICT COVERED UNDER THIS
RELAXATION SIMPLE NEGLIGENCE
LIABILITY WHICH DISTRICTS AND
APPROPRIATE BALANCE BETWEEN
SOCIETAL GOOD BEING PROVIDED BY
PRESCRIBED FIRE PRACTITIONERS
OFTEN FOR LITTLE PAY OR ON A
VOLUNTEER BASIS. AND A MODEST
RISKS TO THE PUBLIC POST. SORRY
PUBLIC BUDGET BOTH BY CAL FIRE
RESPONDING TO AND LENDING
ASSISTANCE ON A PRESCRIBED FIRE
THIS KEEPS CONTAINMENT.
ASSEMBLY THE BILL WOULD
SOCIALIZE THE COSTS OF
FIREFIGHTING RESOURCES CALLED
TO THE SCENE OF A PRESCRIBED
FIRE THAT MEETS THE STRICT
CRITERIA LAID OUT NEW LANGUAGE
I HEARD YOUR SUPPORT. AS AN
IMPORTANT STEP TOWARDS CREATING
A WORKFORCE THAT CAN PROVIDE
GREATER SAFETY FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS WITH A LIVE IN
WILDFIRE COUNTRY OR ARE SUBJECT
TO TERRIBLE SMOKE IMPACTS THAT
WILDFIRES HAVE CREATED. OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO LAINNYA QUINN DAY ARE
YOU WITH US. AT I AM THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY MY
NAME IS LINDA KLIM DAVIDSON AND
I'M WITH THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA COOPERATIVE
EXTENSION AND WITH THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA PRESCRIBED FIRE
COUNCIL AND I'VE WORKED ON
PRESCRIBED FIRE ISSUES FOR MORE
THAN A DECADE AND IT REALLY
HELPED INSPIRE AND LEAD THE
GROUND FULL OF INTERESTED
UNFOLDED IN CALIFORNIA IN
RECENT YEARS ON THIS TOPIC AND
THE TIME HAS REALLY NEVER BEEN
MORE RIGHT TO ADVANCE THIS KIND
OF CRITICAL WORK. I DEFIER
PRACTITIONER I CAN TELL YOU
THAT LIABILITY IS ONE OF OUR
BIGGEST BARRIERS AND THE
PRESCRIBED FIRE HAS INNUMERABLE
PUBLIC BENEFIT CONCERNS OVER
LIABILITY REALLY KEEP US FROM
DOING MORE- WHERE I'D GO TO BE
BURNED FOR FEDERAL AGENCIES AND
WITH CAL FIRE ARE SUPPORTED AND
INDEMNIFIED IN THE RARE CASE
THAT SOMETHING GOES WRONG FIRE
EXPERTS IN THE PRIVATE CULTURAL
AN NGO SECTOR FACE IMMENSE
PERSONAL LIABILITY FOR OUR
WORK. SO WE SEE THAT ONLY THE
MOST PASSIONATE AND COMMITTED
AMONG AFTER LEADING THESE
EFFORTS BECAUSE WE RISK
EVERYTHING IF SOMETHING GOES
WRONG AND THAT'S REALLY NOT THE
WAY FOR CALIFORNIA TO ENABLE
MORE OF THIS WORK THAT WE ALL
RELY ON IN THE PROVIDE SO MUCH
PUBLIC BENEFIT. WE ROLL OUT
THIS NEW STATE CERTIFIED BURN
BOSS PROGRAM AND ALLOCATE MORE
STATE FUNDS FOR PRESCRIBED FIRE
EFFORT WE NEED TO ADDRESS THESE
CRITICAL LIABILITY CONCERNS IN
ITS ORIGINAL FORM THE BILL
ADDRESS CIVIL LIABILITY FOR
DAMAGES FROM PRESCRIBED FIRE
BUT IN ITS REVISED CURRENT FORM
AND TALK OF COST RECOVERY FOR
FIRE SUPPRESSION THESE ARE TWO
OF THE MOST CRITICAL FACETS OF
LIABILITY FOR PRACTITIONERS
LIKE ME AND I WISH WE COULD
ADDRESS BOTH I CAN ASSURE YOU
THAT THE BILL IN ITS CURRENT
FORM WILL BE HUGELY IMPACTFUL.
THIS BILL HAD SEVENTY FIVE
SUPPORT LETTERS FROM AN
IMPRESSIVELY BROAD BASED
RANCHERS TRIBES
ENVIRONMENTALISTS TIMBER
COMPANIES UNIVERSITIES
CONSERVATION ORGANIZATION HOW
OFTEN DO THESE GROUPS RALLY IN
SUPPORT OF A SINGLE ISSUE IT'S
REALLY PRETTY INCREDIBLE
THERE'S NO QUESTION TO THE
PEOPLE WHO USE PRESCRIBED FIRE
THAT THIS BILL IS AN IMPORTANT
PART OF THE SOLUTION I'M SO
THANKFUL TO SENATOR DODD FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP ON. THIS AND TO
YOU ON THE COMMITTEE FOR OUR
TIME TODAY. THANK YOU MUCH.
THANK RIGHT WE WILL THEM TO
OTHERS HE SUPPORT. I SEE
SOMEONE WANTING TO OFFER
SUPPORT SB THIRTY TWO IN
CHAMBERS AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING MISS GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS CHRIS MY
KAYLEE ON BEHALF OF THE
HUMBOLDT AND MENDOCINO REDWOOD-COMPANY'S IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. I'D SAY NONE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION SEEING THE-
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO DECADE SUPPORT FOR SB THREE
THIRTY TO. GET MORNING WE'RE
TAKING NAME AFFILIATION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
SB THREE THIRTY TWO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
THIRTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. NINE FIFTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CHRIS ROSA ON BEHALF OF
KELP FORESTS THE CALIFORNIA
FORESTRY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. NINE ONE THIRTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
JASON BRYANT ON BEHALF OF
WESTERN UNITED DAIRIES
CALIFORNIA'S GEHRY PRODUCING
FAMILIES WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU. ONE ONE
THIRTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
I'M SORRY NINE ONE THIRTY FOUR
FOR MAY HAVE YOU PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AGAIN AND WILL MOVE
TO LINE. ONE THIRTY FIVE NINE
ONE THIRTY FIVE. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD MORNING.
NINE ONE THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN BURST OF
RUNNING CAN BE A LITTLE SCREWS
WITH CHRISTIANITY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FORD ACTION FUND
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE ONE
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS BRIAN
SHOWED ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE AND
AGRICULTURE NETWORK IN SUPPORT.
NINE FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING TURN MEMBER STEVEN
MYERS ON BEHALF OF THE LAND
TRUST OF SANTA CRUZ COUNTY AND
SAVE THE REDWOODS LEAGUE IN
SUPPORT. NINE NINETY TWO. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WILL DIE OF PROMETHEUS FIRE
CONSULTING LLC IN SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL THREE THIRTY TWO
THANK YOU. NINE ONE THIRTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR MARK FENSTER MAKER FOR
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICT.
PENINSULA OPEN SPACE TRUST AND
WATERSHED RESEARCH AND TRAINING
CENTER ALL IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE THREE TWO THANK YOU. MY
NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS NOT
POLITICAL ARE ON BEHALF OF
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. NINE FIFTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MATT WEST JUGGLING
COUNTY BAR CITY COUNCIL AND THE
COMIC NUMBER COOPERATIVE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. NINE
SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
CHAIR MEMBERS PERFORMER HE
CALIFORNIA CATTLEMEN'S
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB THREE THIRTY TWO AND
URGING HERE I DON'T. LINE ONE
FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. JEFF
STACKHOUSE ON BEHALF OF THE
HUMBOLDT COUNTY PRESCRIBED BURN
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. LINE
ONE FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIRD
CHILDRESS- OF THAT COAST
DESCRIBER DISPOSITION AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE
THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MORNING
CARE MEMBERS CORRECT SILVA ON
BEHALF OF HERE FORCE LEGACY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB THREE
THIRTY TWO. MY ONE THIRTY FIVE
IF I MAY HAVE YOU PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AGAIN PLEASE. NINE
ONE TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS DEBBIE ROUTE I'M WITH
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
COOPERATIVE EXTENSION AND THE
CENTRAL COAST PRESCRIBED BURN
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU. NINE
NINETY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS FAIR GIPSON I AM A
CERTIFIED MECHANIC PRESCRIBED
BURN AND A RESIDENT OF
INTERVENTION ACCOUNT AND
INCLUDE A BREAKFAST THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING I'M SHERROD ALTERN
IF RIVATE FOR THE FAMILY IN
FRESNO CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. NINE ONE
FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CARE STONE AND MEMBERS AND
JOANNA ELSON AN INDEPENDENT
SCIENTISTS AND CERTIFIED R.
PRACTITIONER WITH LAND SEA
PLANT LLC IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. ONE ONE THIRTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
PERSON BRING WHITE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LICENSE FORCES
ASSOCIATIONS AND ALSO THE FORCE
LANDOWNERS OF CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB THREE
THREE TWO THANK YOU. ONE THIRTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY THIRTY SEVEN YOU
MAY BE ON MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AND MOVING ON TO LINE ONE FORTY
NINE FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
DANNY WRITER ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN PROPERTY CASUALTY
INSURANCE ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE THREE TWO
THANK. NINE ONE FIFTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ALEX ALANIZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CREW TRIED IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
CRISPY DR TO AS AMENDED THIS
MORNING THANK YOU. NINE ONE
TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR MEMBERS JULIA HALL WITH
YOUR PHYSICIAN CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU OPERATOR WE
WILL MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION I
HAVE NO OPPOSITION TO WITNESSES
WHO WOULD LIKE TO. YOU CAN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE THIRTY
TWO. SEEING NONE REMOTE
TESTIMONY SIGHT SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO INDICATE OPPOSITION TO SB.
THREE THIRTY TWO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB THREE
THIRTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB THREE
THIRTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. AND ONE MOMENT
WHILE WE GATHER THE LINE NUMBER.
YEAH BE JUST A MOMENT LONGER.
NINE ONE FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING- AND IT BRADBURY I AM
ACTUALLY IN THE PORT OF THE
BILL I JUST I THINK I GOT
MISTER EARLIER SO MANY READERS
CONSERVATION DISTRICT AND THE
PLAN WITH UNDERGRAD
COOPERATIVE. IMPORTED UP THANK
YOU THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU
RIGHT THANK YOU BRING IT BACK
THEN TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. RIGHT
SINGER SENATOR HE MAKE CLOTHES
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND THAT MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON NATURAL RESOURCES
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE HI
STONE AYE GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER
AYE CHAU CHIU. DAVIES DVI
GONZALEZ CONSULTS AYE HOLDEN
KALRA. KALRA AYE KILEY KILEY
AYE MAIENSCHEIN REYES. THE
BILLS OUT THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THANK YOU RIGHT OUR
ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB SIXTY TWO
SENATORS ARE ALSO. MY NAME IS
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. SB SIXTY TWO MAKES
CLEAR THAT A BUSINESS
CONTRACTING TO HAVE GARMENTS
MADE IS LIABLE FOR UNPAID WAGES
TO THE SKILLED WORKERS WHO MAKE
THOSE GARMENTS REGARDLESS OF
HOW MANY LAYERS OF CONTRACTING
THAT COMPANY MAY USE. OVER THE
LAST TWENTY YEARS IS THE
ORIGINAL GARMENT WORKER
PROTECTION ACT WAS PASSED THERE
ARE TWO UNDERLYING CAUSES OF
WAGE THEFT TODAY. THE CAUSE
CALIFORNIA TO ACTUALLY FALL
BEHIND AND IS BECAUSE WORKERS
TO RELY ON THE GARMENT
RESTITUTION FUND FOR THEIR
WAGES WHICH LEAVES TAXPAYERS TO
SUBSIDIZE WAGE THEFT. RIGHT NOW
THE FUND HAS A BALANCE OF SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS WITH
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS IN CLAIMS.
IN TWENTY NINETEEN SIXTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS WAS TRANSFERRED
INTO THAT FUND TO PAY FOR WAGE
THEFT FIRST FASHION BRANDS
CREATE POVERTY WAGES THROUGH
UNREALISTIC PRICING OF GARMENT
ORDERS. AND YET THEY HAVE NO
LEGAL LIABILITY SECOND. THE
ARCHAIC SYSTEM OF PAIN BY PIECE
RATE THAT IS THAT KEEPS MINIMUM
WAGE ALWAYS OUT OF THE REACH
FOR WORKERS. YOUR COULD THESE
ARE THE KINDS OF CONDITIONS
THAT EXISTED FOR EUROPEAN
IMMIGRANT WOMEN ALL OVER A
HUNDRED YEARS AGO I'M PROUD TO
RECOGNIZE. THAT A HUNDRED AND
FORTY FASHION INDUSTRY
BUSINESSES MOSTLY WOMEN LED
SMALL BUSINESSES ARE LEADING
THE CHARGE FOR ETHICAL
WORKPLACE AND SUSTAINABILITY
STANDARDS IN THE GARMENT
INDUSTRY. THEY ENDORSE THIS
BILL TO PROTECT HIGHLY SKILLED
GARMENT WORKERS FROM LOOPHOLES
THAT HAVE MADE THE INDUSTRY
HOSTILE TO ETHICAL GARMENT
COMPANIES. TRUMP WHO ARE TRYING
TO ELIMINATE SWEATSHOPS. THESE
BUSINESSES ARE TRYING HARD TO
ENSURE THAT QUOTE UNQUOTE MADE
IN THE USA REPRESENTS QUALITY
AND WORK STANDARDS ALL
COMPANIES SHOULD WANT TO
PROTECT THEIR IMAGE BRANDS HAVE
THE POWER TO END. THIS PROBLEM
AND FIX THEIR INDUSTRY THIS IS
NOT ABOUT A FEW BAD ACTORS
ESCAPING LIABILITY. THE US
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR UNCOVERED
WAGE VIOLATIONS THAT 85% OF
SEVENTY SEVEN LOS ANGELES
GARMENT SHOPS DURING RANDOMLY-
MADE INSPECTIONS IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND TWENTY SIXTEEN. AT
THE SAME TIME SOME BRANDS HAVE
REALIZED THE ADVANTAGE OF A
STRONG DOMESTIC MANUFACTURING
INDUSTRY IN REDUCING RISKS AND
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH INVENTORY
SHIPPING OVERSIGHT. WHICH WERE
ALL EXACERBATED BY COVERT
NINETEEN DISRUPTIONS TO THE
GLOBAL SUPPLY CHAIN FROM THIS
PANDEMIC HAVE MOTIVATED
COMPANIES TO SET UP SHOPIN LOS
ANGELES FOR THE BENEFIT OF
SKILLED LABOR. 65% OF RETAILERS
DECIDED THE ANSWER THE ANSWER
TO THOSE RISK WAS TO ESTABLISH
DOMESTIC MANUFACTURING. AS THE
LARGEST INDUSTRY OF ITS KIND IN
THE US THE APPAREL
MANUFACTURING INDUSTRY IN L. A.
COUNTY PRODUCES FOUR POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS IN TOTAL
ANNUAL OUTPUT. OUR GARMENT
WORKERS ARE TRULY THE ENGINE
THE KEEPS OF FASHION INDUSTRY
MOVING WE'VE HEARD FROM THESE
WOMEN ESSENTIAL WORKERS WHO
MADE THE COUNTRY'S MASKS FOR AS
LITTLE AS TWO CENTS APIECE
WORKING SIXTY AND SIXTY HOURS A
WEEK DURING COVERT. SB SIXTY
TWO IS THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS PRIORITY. WILL HELP
REGAIN MILLIONS A WEEK AND
WAGES STOLEN FROM WORKING WOMEN
THEIR FAMILIES AND THE SMALL
BUSINESSES WERE THEY SPEND
THEIR MONEY TODAY WE HAVE TO
EXPERTS- MISTER CHAIRMAN TO
EXPERTS ON THE WITNESS LINE.
NUMBER WORKER IS SOMEBODY
CASTRO. AND BUSINESS OWNER
KRISTIN FUND ARRAKIS FOUNDER
AND CREATIVE DIRECTOR FOR SINCE
THE TEMPLE THEY WILL BE
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT AND WE
HAVE ON THE LINE TO HELP ANSWER
QUESTIONS MONEY AVAILABLE SHARE
FROM THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR. RIGHT WE I DO HAVE
THOSE WITNESSES WITNESSES
LISTED KRISTIN FREDERICK IS AND
ISABEL CASTRO WHO HAS A
TRANSLATOR WITH HER SO WE'LL
START WITH KRISTEN FEDERAL
OFFICE. HI THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING CHARACTER AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS CHRISTIAN
CENTER I CAN'T THE FOUNDER AND
DESIGNER OF THE TENSILE A
CLASSICALLY INSPIRED LUXURY
LINE MADE IN DOWNTOWN LOS
ANGELES. I'M ONE OF THE HUNDRED
FORTY FIVE AND GROWING FASHION
INDUSTRY BUSINESSES AND SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL I SPENT OVER A
DECADE IN FOREIGN EXCHANGE
TRADING N WALL STREET AND THEN
LATER AND FINANCIAL POLICY IN
WASHINGTON DC AN AREA WHERE I
REMAIN ACTIVE SENSING NOW ON
ENVIRONMENTAL SOCIAL AND
GOVERNANCE ISSUES. I LOST MY
BUSINESS TO ADDRESS WHAT I FALL
WITH A LACK OF QUALITY CLOTHING
AND WHAT I DISCOVERED IS
INDUSTRY THAT IS FUNDAMENTALLY
BROKEN. IT'S AN INDUSTRY THAT
DEPEND ON LOW PRICES AND VOLUME
AND WHEN THE LARGE COMPANIES
MAKE THEIR CLOTHING IN
CALIFORNIA THEY DEPEND ON
PAYING BY THE MINIMUM WAGE IN
ORDER TO PRESERVE THEIR PROFIT
MARGINS FOR SHAREHOLDERS. WAGE
THEFT IS A SYSTEMIC ISSUE THAT
IS BUILT INTO THE BUSINESS
MODEL OF LARGE FASHION
CORPORATION. IT'S NOT AN
ISOLATED INCIDENT ALLOWING IT
TO CONTINUE TO TRADE CONSUMER
CONSUMER TRUST IN THE MADE IN
CALIFORNIA LABOR LATE LABEL.
AND IT FEELS FROM CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS. PASSING SB SIXTY TWO
YOU WILL HAVE NO EFFECT ON A
BUSINESS THAT IS ALREADY
FOLLOWING THE LAW BY PAYING A
MINIMUM WAGE. AND ASSIGNING
JOINT LIABILITY WILL HAVE NO
IMPACT ON A COMPANY THAT HAS
DONE THEIR DUE DILIGENCE ON
THEIR FACTORY SOMETHING THAT
MANY OF THESE COMPANIES. ARE
CLAIMING THEY HAVE ALREADY DONE.
COMPANIES TRY TO BREAK THE LAW
THAT BACK AND THEN THE WAGE AND
ORDERED OFFER. ARTIFICIALLY LOW
PRICED CAR YOU CAN HER COMPANY
LIKE AND AGAINST THE- WHO
BELIEVE IN. OF THE MANY
DIFFERENT IF. AS WELL AS THE
ACT. WE ALL KNOW THAT THE
MEETING HELD LATE HAS ECONOMIC
VALUE OTHERWISE THE COMPANY IS
WHAT BE TRYING TO CONVERT THE
LAW. AND OR THEY WOULD HAVE A
MOVE THEIR BUSINESSES-
OVERSEAS. ALLOWING THIS
BEHAVIOR TO CONTINUE HURT
COMPANY IF YOU BELIEVE IT AND
ALL THAT COULD BE MADE IN
CALIFORNIA LABEL MEANS. AND
WHAT CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURING
TO THRIVE. AT THE LARGEST
APPAREL MANUFACTURING HUB IN
THE U. S. FOR THE STATE TO
TRULY BE THE PROGRESSIVE LEADER
AND CLAIMS TO BE ON ON FIFTEEN
ABILITY. CALIFORNIA MARKET
PASSED AT THE TO KEEP YOU TO
LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD FOR
COMPANIES LIKE MINE. WE LIVE IN
A WORLD WHERE TEACHER THAT
TAKES AN HOUR TO GO COST AS
MUCH OF A COUPLE OF A LOT K.
THAT TAKES ONLY FIVE MINUTES TO
MAKE. WHEN THAT TEACHER DID
MADE IN THE LAST. THE MATH JUST
DOESN'T ADD UP. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR TIME I WISH. I FOR
YOUR THAT DEPORTED THE FELT.
THANK YOU. ISABEL CASTRO. IT
WILL. START FOUR O'CLOCK TODAY
OKAY YEAH I'M GONNA BE THE
RIGHT ONE WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
YEAH THERE'S- OKAY I'M NOT
AFRAID WOULD YOU BE WITHOUT AT
LEAST. THAT LINE IS NOT MUTED
THANK YOU CAN WE MOVE TO ISABEL
CASTRO PLEASE. YES WHEN IS THIS
I KNOW THE ASPEN RANGE THAT'S
BEEN ROOM ONE OF THE UP
SOMEBODY'S COVERS GONE IN THE
END OF THE CALL. I AM A CURRENT.
IS GOING AND GOING THE LIGHTS
ARE HOLDEN WAS GONNA. AND WHAT
THE DOWN YOUR NUMBER LOCAL
STUDENTS. YEAH MY MEDICAL I'M
MARKING THE COLLECTIVE. ONE
IMPERCEPTIBLE CLASSROOMS THAT
ONE NOT BEING SASSY CORKY
OFFENSE. HERO SPENT YOU HAVE
THE ANNUALLY NON COME YEAH.
OKAY THEN I'LL GO ON TO ALLOWED
YOU ORDERED. HIM TO PUT. YEP
THAT'LL WHAT ANNUAL YEAR THE
NUMBER YOU'RE NOT GOING TO LET
THAT WE- WILL NOTIFY YOU MAN.
ITS ALUMINIUM LEAH MARK THAT
NOW LAP SCHOOL IN KNOWN AND-
YEAH THANK DE FUNDAMENTAL COURT
CIENTOS ALRIGHT IN SPRING
THINK OUT OF ANGELES WITH ANTI
A FOR MY MOST OF SAN IN COURT
OF CANNELLA. IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
LEFT ON THEM YOU'RE NOT WHAT
DOES MY FATHER TRUCK BALANCE
OUT OF REPORTER INTERNET TO SEE
GALAXIA AND AT THE END OF
CREDIT YES WEAPONS BEGAN PEOPLE
BEER. BUT I THAT I HIGHLAND
WIND UP THE NAY BECAUSE GOD
MYSELF YES YEAH THIS IS NOT
MORE AIRLINE. THE MOM OF A
STROLLER KNOCKED ON SO WANT. NO
NINETY. PERCENT OF LOCAL BOOK
BUT ON THE OTHER LINE THANK YOU
THE EVENING BUT I COMMEND
ORIENTALS OF THE COMMUTER. HE
PUT ME FOR THE LOCAL COMPACT
AMERICA MONOCLONAL DEPENDS ON.
IT BUT I'LL ASK OUR FINAL
AMERICAN REPORTED IT THE NEW
ONE BLACK ONE YEAH I MEAN IF
YOU SEE OTHER. FOR ME SO IN THE
LAST KOREAN THEM HIS COMPANION
OF. M. REPORTER RON. ELEVEN
MARKET FRANKAMP CLUB OKAY IN
THE SHE AND ALLOW ATKINS VOTER
GUNMAN. HEY YOU'RE GONNA NEW
YORK MISS FOUR CAN ALSO BOTTOM
PORTION ALISON FOOT ASSEMBLY
LIST THE WHOLE CAMP FOR AUDIBLE
ENOUGH I WANT LET IN THEY LOOK
FINALLY NINE OR FOUR PM FOR
THAT YOU CAN LONG YOU CAN A LOT
MONICA WEARABLE INFO LET YOUR-
CHECK IT OUT AND I'M OF NEW YOU
CAN COMPANION- OF TWENTY THANKS
CALL ME. CONCLUDED THE KIND FOR
THE LAST YEAR GOOD ACTORS.
TODAY HAVE NOT CHANGED I'VE
NEVER EARNED AN HOURLY WAGE
ALWAYS PER PIECE. I WORKED FOR
YEARS FROM SEVEN AM TO SEVEN PM
MONDAY TO FRIDAY AND SATURDAY.
NIGHT MOSTLY OF MATING GARMENT
IN A WEEK WAS TWENTY YEARS AGO
WHEN I WAS PAID FOUR HUNDRED
DOLLARS IN MY THIRTY YEARS EVER
IN BETWEEN TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY TO TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
DOLLARS A WEEK FOR SIXTY FIVE
HOURS OF WORK. DURING THE
PANDEMIC THE DOORS OF THE
FACTORIES WERE CLOSED BUT
INSIDE PEOPLE ALWAYS WORKING
MAKING MASKS ON HOSPITAL
GROUNDS BY THE P. THREE. TO GET
A GOOD SALARY WE HAVE TO MAKE
SO MAY WE HAVE TO MAKE MANY
PIECES AND SOMETIMES WE DON'T
GO TO THE BATHROOM WE DON'T
HAVE A LUNCH. WE DON'T DRINK
WATER AND WE ARRIVE IN THE
SENTENCES. THIS CONTINUED
DURING THE PANDEMIC AS WELL.
NOW I AM. AND TO GO TO DALLAS
THREE A WEEK. I CAN ONLY WORK
TWO TO THREE DAYS A WEEK AND
EARNED ABOUT ONE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY DOLLARS. I USE A SALARY
FOR MY INCOME AND MY BILLS.
SORRY AS ASIDE FROM MY RENT AND
MY BILLS. I GO TO FOOD BANKS TO
GET MY FOOD. BECAUSE OF MY LOW
SALARY I SHARE A BEDROOM WITH
ANOTHER WHICH- I WORKED FOR THE
BRAND FOREVER TWENTY ONE WHICH
HAS BENEFITED FROM A LOWER.
SALARY AND THAT OF MY
COLLEAGUES. WOULD WANT BRANDS
TO TAKE RESPONSIBILITY BECAUSE
IT HAS BEEN PROVEN THAT THEY DO
NOT PAY ENOUGH. FOR THE WORK
FOR US TO EARN BETTER. THEY
MAKE MILLIONS BECAUSE THEY PAY
S. TEN. ASSEMBLYMEMBERS I ASK
THAT YOU PLEASE VOTE IN FAVOR
OF SB SIXTY TWO TO ELIMINATE
THE P. THREE AND HOLD BRANDS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR WHICH THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ON BEHALF
OF MYSELF AND MY COLLEAGUES TO
FORTY FIVE THOUSAND GARMENT
WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND I WILL NOTE
THAT WE ALSO HAVE BEEN WELL OF
TO SHARE ON THE LINE. FOR THE
CALIFORNIA. LABOR FEDERATION
WHO WAS ON STANDBY FOR
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT.
FOR SB SIXTY TWO PLEASE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS RENEE
BAYARDO THIS YOU KNOW CAL.
SUPPORT THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE.
I SEE NONE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION SEEING NONE OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR
THOSE WHO WOULD LOOK LIKE TO
INDICATE SUPPORT FOR SB SIXTY
TWO AGAIN WE'RE TAKING NAME
AFFILIATION AND SUPPORT ONLY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
SB SIXTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY
TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. NINE ONE
FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN. SHE HARO BUT THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINE ONE FIFTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IT IS GOOD NEWS MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS JUSTIN RAGA
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE ONE
SIXTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MAP BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEAMSTERS AND UNITE
HERE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE
ONE THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIR NUMBERS CAPITA AUSTIN
REPPERT THE OBJECT YEAH OF YOU.
WHEN CAL IN. NINE ONE SIXTY
YOUR IS OPEN GO AHEAD. WANT TO
SHARE NUMBER CHRISTOPHER OF
POLICY LESS CENTER ON LAW
POVERTY OR PRODUCT CLOSE OF THE
ALLERGIST. NINE ONE SIX TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS WHO PLAN TO WATER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC
PROPERTIES IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB SIXTY TWO. THANK YOU. NINE
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. CHAIR MEMBER CATALINA
SANCHEZ WITH CORBIN AND HI
THERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME CONSUMER
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINE EIGHTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. PAKISTAN ON BEHALF OF
THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA AND CHUCK THE PART.
NINE ONE SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS DIMITRIUS DEAL
WITH THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NINE ONE FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE
HAVE AN INTERN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS COOPERATE
WITH THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
STATE COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL
EMPLOYEES GOING IN SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL SIXTY TWO. I THINK.
NINE ONE SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME'S
ALEX BERLINER WITH THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND HEALTH
AND WE ARE ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY TWO THANK
YOU. ONE FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CAROLINA APPEARED ON BEHALF OF
ACLU CAPTAIN IN SUPPORT. NINE
ONE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NUMBER
MARKET THE RIVER REPRESENT LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NINE SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO YES IT IS. HI I'M SORRY-
HI MY NAME IS ELAINE MILLION
AMERICANS TURN TO DETAIN AND
RELEASE ALL FIVE FOR THE CHOICE
OF THAT THESE PEOPLE ARE
EXPERIENCING. ANYTHING HANDED
DOWN BY IN THE MORNING
TESTIMONY OKAY I'M SORRY I'M
SORRY ALEX YEAH- JUST WORK I'M
SUPPORTING. THEIR ADMIN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. ONE ONE FIFTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS MARCY
YEAH I'M NOT AND I'M I AM IN
THE STRONG SUPPORT OF S. B.
SIXTY TWO. THANK. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO OPPOSITION I HAVE TO
OPPOSITION WITNESSES LISTED
ACTUALLY HOFFMAN FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND SCOTT WILSON FROM YOU
STRIVE MANUFACTURING. AND WHO
IS IT SCOTT WILSON IS WITH US
ON THE TELEPHONE ACTUALLY HAVE
BEEN HERE IN THE CHAMBERS
PLEASE SEE YET MISTER WILSON
CAN GO FIRST THAT. ALL RIGHT
MISTER WILSON ARE YOU WITH US.
SCOTT WILSON. NO PLEASE PROCEED
WITH A TELEPHONE YOU MAY BE ON
MUTE. SCOTT WILSON YOU MAY BE
ON MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD. SCOTT
WILSON ARE YOU WITH US YOU'RE
NOT COMING THROUGH ARE YOU ON
MUTE. ARE YOU THERE YES. OKAY
SORRY I DON'T I'M MY NAME IS
SCOTT WILSON I AM- THE
PRESIDENT OF YOU STRIVE
MANUFACTURING I REPRESENT
STREETS THE CELEBES IN LOS
ANGELES. WE HAVE OVER TWO
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES WE ARE THE
ONLY CERTIFIED ORGANIC AND-
SOCIALLY COMPLIANCE T. EIGHT
THOUSAND MANUFACTURE IN IN-
NORTH AMERICA. IN FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN MY THIRTY YEARS IN
BUSINESS MADE USA ACTUALLY
MEANS SOMETHING TO BRANDS AND
CONSUMERS. THE LAST LAST YEAR'S
GLOBAL SUPPLY CHAIN CHAIN
DISRUPTION CREATE A POSITIVE
SHIFT TO DOMESTIC MANUFACTURING
ESPECIALLY HERE IN LOS ANGELES.
SINCE JANUARY THERE'S BEEN A
30% PLUS INCREASE IN BRAND
STARTING OR EXPANDING THEIR
DOMESTIC APPAREL PRODUCTION BY
PEERS AND I HAVE ISSUES WITH
THE BILL'S REQUIREMENT THAT
THESE BRANDS IN THEIR RETAIL
PARTNERS WILL BE HELD LIABLE
FOR THE SUPPLY CHAIN. APPEARS
IN CUSTOMERS MAIN CONCERN IS
THAT THIS WILL INCREASE
PRODUCTION COSTS THE MISTAKE
MAKE BOTH THE ALREADY PAYS
THIRTY TO FORTY DOMESTIC NAY
CLOTHING BRANDS ALREADY PAID
3240% MORE FOR PRODUCTION. AS
COMPARED TO THEIR CHINA OR
INDIA. MAKE COUNTERPARTS. AS
BRENDA ENTERTAINING SHIFTING
THE DOMESTIC PER FROM CHINA TO
THE U. S. ANY DECLINE IN
ALREADY LOW MARGIN WILL HURT OR
STOP THE CHANCE TO BE THE
CONTINUED MADE USA WE SHORING
APTRIX. THERE IS A MUCH EASIER
SOLUTION ONE SIX TO WHAT YOU
WANT CONCENTRATE YOUR CURRENT
OUTWARDS ON THE CONTRACTORS TO
MAKE THE CLOTHING FOR THE
NATION'S TOP THREE. RETAIL
DISCOUNTERS ANNUAL FINDER
INDUSTRY VIOLATORS. THERE IS NO
NEED TO PENALIZE THE WHOLE
INDUSTRY FOR THE ACTIONS OF A
FEW. IN A TIME OF HOPE THE LAST
THING THE INDUSTRY NEEDS IS
MORE UNLESS YOU'RE VERY COSTLY
LAWS OR REGULATIONS. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU. RIGHT ACTUALLY OFTEN
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
IS ACTUALLY HOFFMAN ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSITION SB SIXTY TWO IS A
JOB KILLER ON THE START BY
SAYING THAT WE IN THE
MANUFACTURERS AND BRANDS THAT
DO JUSTICE HEALTH FOR NOW SHARE
THE SAME GOAL IF SUPPORTERS OF
THIS BILL TO ELIMINATE THE
ENTITIES THAT ARE CIRCUMVENTING
THE LAW AND ENSURE THAT WORKERS
ARE LAWFULLY PAID BUT I WANT TO
MAKE TWO POINTS TODAY. FIRST
THE PROPONENTS OF THE BILL SAY
THAT THE EXPANSION OF JOINT
LIABILITY IS NECESSARY BECAUSE
BRANDS LIKE FOREVER TWENTY ONE-
OTHER FAST FASHION BRANDS THAT
PAY LOW PRICES FOR GARMENTS
CANNOT BE HELD LIABLE UNDER THE
LAW THAT IS NOT TRUE UNDER
LABOR CODE SECTION TWENTY EIGHT
TEN THAT LAW SAYS THAT ANY
ENTITY THAT ENTERS INTO A
CONTRACT FOR GARMENT
MANUFACTURING WHO KNOWS OR
SHOULD KNOW THAT THE PRICE IS
INSUFFICIENT TO PAY WORKERS OR
TREAT THEM LAWFULLY IS. IS
THERE A LIABLE UNDER THE LAW
FOR WAGES PENALTIES IN
ATTORNEY'S FEES SECOND I'VE
BEEN WORKING REALLY HARD OVER
THE PAST YEAR WITH MEMBERS OF
THE INDUSTRY WHO ARE AT THE
TABLE FOR DISCUSSIONS ON EIGHTY
SIX THIRTY THREE THEY SUPPORTED
AB SIX THIRTY THREE AND THEY
STILL DO THEY AGREE THAT BRANDS
WHO DO NOT PAY ENOUGH MONEY FOR
CLOTHING SHOULD BE LIABLE FOR
THE WAY THAT THEY CONDUCT
BUSINESS BUT THEY ARE EXTREMELY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE EFFECT ON
SIXTY TWO ON THEIR ABILITY TO
MAKE CLOTHING HERE. THIS IS A
STATEMENT FROM AN LA BASED
BRAND IT WAS A SUPPORTER OF SIX
THIRTY THREE INVOLVED IN
NEGOTIATIONS ON SIX THIRTY
THREE WHO'S UNABLE TO BE HERE
TODAY HE SAYS THE BIGGEST ISSUE
I SEE WITH THIS BILL IS A
REQUIREMENT THE RETAILERS TO
GET PURCHASE ORDERS TO
MANUFACTURERS PEOPLE LIKE ME
NOT SO IN CONTRACTORS WE HIGHLY
LIABLE FOR WAGES NOT PAID BY
THE SEWING CONTRACTOR THAT I
CHOOSE I ACCEPT I AM
RESPONSIBLE FOR MY SEWING
CONTRACTORS ACTIONS I ALREADY
AM UNDER SIX THIRTY THREE. BUT
OF A COMPANY NOW BECOMES LIABLE
BY GIVING ME A PURCHASE ORDER
THEY JUST WILL NOT DO BUSINESS
WITH ME ON ANY GOODS I MAKING
CALIFORNIA SINCE I MAKE 65% OF
MY GOODS IN CALIFORNIA I CANNOT
JUST MOVE ALL OF THAT OFF SHORE
BUT IT WILL MEAN THAT I HAVE TO
GO FROM A PREDOMINANTLY
DOMESTIC CLOTHING MAKER TO ALL
IMPORTS BECAUSE OF THIS BILL NO
PUBLIC COMPANIES GOING TO TAKE
ON THAT BURDEN THEY SIMPLY WILL
NOT DO BUSINESS WITH A COMPANY
THAT MAKES IN CALIFORNIA IF
THEY'RE GONNA BE HELD LIABLE
FOR THE MANUFACTURERS AND
STEAKS. THIS IS VERY DIFFERENT.
FROM HOW FASHION OF THE WORKS
THERE AND EAT CONVERSE RETAILER
WHO CONTRA. OUT FOR THE PRODUCT
THEY HAVE ON THE- AND THEY
SHOULD BE HELD RESPONSIBLE. FOR
THE BILL GOES THROUGH INTRIGUED
ALL RETAILERS LIKE FASHION OVER
I WILL LOSE MY MAJOR BUSINESS
AND THEY WILL NOT TAKE ON
RESPONSIBILITY NOR SHOULD THEY-
MAJOR STORES WILL NOT BY
MEETING CALIFORNIA GOODS AT
THEIR- IF THEY HAVE TO BE
RESPONSIBLE THEY JUST DO NOT
NEED US FIRST THAT LIABILITY
RISK. SO WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO INSTEAD FOCUS ON
TARGET REPORTS MINT. POLICING
OF THE REGISTRATION
REQUIREMENTS THAT MANY OF THESE
PROBLEMATIC ENTITIES AVOID-
RESTRUCTURING OF THE GOVERNMENT
FUNDS. AND ELIMINATION OF THOSE
ENTITIES THAT FAIL TO PAY THEIR
WORKERS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
SO IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WHO'D LIKE TO
INDICATE OPPOSITION TO SB SIXTY
TWO. SEEING NONE THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. THREE NINE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO LIKE TO
INDICATE OPPOSITION SB SIXTY
TWO AGAIN WE WILL TAKE NAME
AFFILIATION AND OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SB
SIXTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SIXTY TWO YOU
MAY PRESS ONE. AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. LINE ONE TWENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS WRANGLING
WITH THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
OPERATOR DID WE LOSE YOU.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE HI WE ARE
GATHERING NINE NUMBERS THANK
YOU. OKAY JUST A FEW MOMENTS.
AND FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE
CHAIRED MANY MEMBERS- I NEED TO
SHIP DURING- TAKING ON BEHALF
OF THE ALLEY CHAMBER AND WE ARE
STRONGLY OPPOSING SB SIXTY TWO
THANK YOU. FIVE SEVENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MORNING THIS IS MORE TO
GAIN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURING TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WHERE RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. NINE ONE FIFTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CHEN
MEMBERS JAMIE HOPPED WITH THE
CIVIL JUSTICE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN RESPECT
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL THANK
YOU. AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU ARE PRETTY
MAY CLOSE ALLIANCE OR SB SIXTY
TWO AND I WILL BRING YOU BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. RIGHT SINGLE
SENATOR YOU MAY QUOTE THANK YOU
VERY MUST MUCH MISTER CHAIR
AND- MEMBERS- I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR FOR YOUR AYE VOTE I-
I'M DISAPPOINTED TO HEAR THAT-
SOME OF WHO SPOKE AGAINST THE
BILL- CONSIDER THIS A
PENALIZING OF THE INDUSTRY
WHEN- AND UNNECESSARY COSTS ALL
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS MAKE SURE
THAT THE MEN AND WOMEN WHO WORK
IN THE INDUSTRY. GET PAID THEIR
LAWFUL WAGES SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU I AM LOOKING FOR A MOTIONS.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND THAT MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE STONE HI STONE I
GALLAGHER. CHAU CHIU. DAVIES
DAVIES NO GONZALEZ CONSULTS AYE
HOLDEN KALRA KALRA KILEY KILEY
NO MAIENSCHEIN REYES FIVE REZAI.
THE BILL WILL BE ON CALL IT
NEEDS TO MORE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MEMBERS THANK YOU. RIGHT
OUR ITEM NUMBER SIX SB FOUR
FIFTY TWO SENATOR GONZALEZ.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I TODAY I'M HERE TO
PRESENT SB FOUR FIFTY TWO WHICH
WILL ESTABLISH A CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT AND REFUGEE AFFAIRS
AGENCY TO SERVE IN A SISTER
STATES DIVERSE IMMIGRANT AND
REFUGEE COMMUNITIES BY
ESTABLISHING A PERMANENT
STRUCTURE WITHIN THE STATE TO
SERVE IMMIGRANTS AND REFUGEES
SB FOUR FIVE TWO WILL CREATE A
FRAMEWORK TO BETTER ASSIST
STATE AGENCIES IN EVALUATING
THEIR PROGRAMS. FOR
ACCEPTABILITY AND EFFECTIVENESS
IN PROVIDING SERVICES TO THIS
VERY UNDERSERVED POPULATION THE
OFFICE WOULD ALSO RECOMMEND
POLICY IN BUDGET PROPOSALS TO
BETTER BE THE STATE'S IMMIGRANT
AND REFUGEE INTEGRATION GOALS
CALIFORNIA AS WE KNOW IS HOME
TO APPROXIMATELY ELEVEN MILLION
IMMIGRANTS AND REFUGEES
COMPRISING NEARLY ONE QUARTER
OF THE STATE'S POPULATION AND
THIRTY PORT 4% OF OUR WORK
FORCE. MORE THERE ARE LOCAL
PROGRAMS IN GOVERNMENT OFFICES
OFFERING SIMILAR SERVICES TO
IMMIGRANTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
CALIFORNIA LACKS A CENTRALIZED
VOICE AND HELPING US MEET THE
NEEDS OF THE LARGE IMMIGRANT
AND RAFI REFUGEE POPULATION SB
FOUR FIVE TWO WILL SUPPORT
THESE EFFORTS TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT TODAY HAVE RUN THE
ORTIZ. MANAGING DIRECTOR AT THE
U. S. C. EQUITY RESEARCH
INSTITUTE AND ROSIE EDITORIAL
SENIOR PROGRAM MANAGER AT THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY FOUNDATION.
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK
HER NAY VOTE. THANK YOU I HAVE.
THREE WITNESSES LISTED ROUND
ORTIZ WITH US ON THE TELEPHONE
ROSE ZERO WITH US ON THE
TELEPHONE AND THEN ALSO JOSEPH.
OF THE A LOT FROM CHIRLA WHO IS
ON STANDBY FOR TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS CORRECT YES SO WE
WILL GO TO RUN TO WHERE SHE'S.
ONE CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE HAVE.
THANK YOU KAREN COMMITTEE
MEMBER COMBINING AGAIN RATHER
CHIEF AT THE WITH THE EQUITY
RESURGENT SECOND I'M HERE
BECAUSE IMPORTANCE OF THE NEED
FOR CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF
IMMIGRANT AFFAIRS. I CONFIDENCE
FROM DOING RESEARCH ON THAT
TOPIC IS AROUND THE COUNTRY FOR
CITY METRO AREAS EIGHT I'M IN
THE REPORT OPENING MINDS OPEN
DOORS OF THE COMMUNITY- IN
ADDITION WE HAVE AFFECTED
AFRICAN RECRUITING ELLIE CITY
AWAY AND HELPED DESIGN AND
START THE L. A. COUNTY SO I A
WITH THAT COUPON IMMIGRANTS
GRATION. AND WE HAVE SUPPORTED
STATEWIDE DIRECTION Ë
INTEGRATION OFFICE OF PLANNING
RESEARCH DURING THE DATA AND
WORKSHOPS TO HELP OUR NATION'S
PRESS AGENCY- NOW IS THE TIME
FOR CALIFORNIA WITH EVERYTHING
WE KNOW ABOUT HOW IMPORTANT
IMMIGRANTS ARE CALIFORNIA. THEY
ARE A FAMILY THAT COMMUNITIES
OUR STATE AND WE NEED TO CREATE
A POSITIVE INCLUSIVE
INTEGRATION EXPERIENCE AND WHY
IS THAT YEARS BECAUSE AN OFFICE
WILL HELP SHINE A LIGHT ON THE
LANDSCAPE OF IMMIGRANTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE SO WE KNOW
WHO ARE THE DIFFERENT IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES AND WHAT ARE THE
DIFFERENT NEEDS. AN OFFICE
ACCORDING TO STATE SERVICES NOT
TAKE AWAY SERVICES FROM
DEPARTMENTS BUT MAKE SURE THE
DEPARTMENTS ARE WORKING
TOGETHER TO BE MORE EFFICIENT-
THIS COULD HAVE BEEN HELPFUL
MOST RECENTLY TO CLEANING
EFFORTS TO RESTRICT THE CO
THERE. BUT ALSO OVER THE YEARS
AND LIKELY IN THE FUTURE AND
RESPONSE TO NATURAL DISASTERS
LIKE FIRES AND FLOODS- AN
OFFICE WILL PROVIDE GUIDANCE
FOR JURISDICTIONS THAT ARE TOO
SMALL TO CREATE THEIR OWN
OFFICES SO I THINK THAT'S
PRACTICES. AND MOST OF ALL WE
IN THE OFFICE BECAUSE WE ARE AN
IMMIGRANT STATE MORE THAN 25%
OF FOREIGN BORN ABOUT A THIRD
OF OUR KIDS HAVE AT LEAST ONE
IMMIGRANT PARENTS MINE
INCLUDED. OUR UNDOCUMENTED
POPULATION ARE EXTREMELY LONG
PEDDLED A GREAT MAJORITY ABOUT
67% HAVE BEEN HERE MORE THAN
TEN YEARS AND OF THOSE LIKE 25%
OF THE HUMAN IN TWENTY YEARS-
NEVER AGAIN NUMBERS OF PEOPLE
ARE LIVING IN NYC STATUS FAMILY
ABOUT 20% OF ALL PEOPLE UNDER
EIGHTEEN. I LIVE IN MIXED
STATUS FAMILIES SENT YOU THINK
WHERE THEY ARE AT WHERE EXACTLY
IN THEMSELVES. ARE LIVING WITH
SOMEONE WHO IS. BUT WE ARE
BEHIND ON THE CLOSE THIS IS THE
TIME FOR CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU. AND THEN
ROSY ARROYO. YEAH THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBER- MEANING YOU WOULD GET
ALL YOUR SENIOR PROGRAM OFFICER
FOR IMMIGRATION WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION. AND I AM HERE TO
EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT AT
THAT SPEED CORPORATE EACH YEAR
WHICH WOULD ADDRESS THE NEEDS
OF OVER TEN MILLION CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS. THANK THE
FICTIONALIZING IMMIGRATION AND
REFUGEE AGENCY. COMMUNITY IS A
THINKING. CONSUMER THAT SPANS
OVER HUNDRED ANY. POINT SIX
BILLION PER YEAR AND CONTRIBUTE
OVER THIRTY EIGHT BILLION.
DOLLARS AND STATE LOCAL AND
FEDERAL TAXES THEY ARE LONG
TERM RESIDENTS WITH DEEP ROOTS
IN THE REGION COUPLING FOR
COURT IN ANY PEOPLE PART OF THE
STATE'S ECONOMY. THE CALL THE
NINETEENTH ENDEMIC ELIMINATED
THE HEROIC WORK OF IMMIGRANTS
AND THEIR FAMILIES. WHO HELPED
OUR STATE MAKE IT THE ONE OF
THE TOUGHEST TIMES THAT OUR
COLLECTIVE HISTORY. IMMIGRANTS
WORKING MEETING WITH THE PRICE
PROVIDE CARE AND KEEP THE
ECONOMY AFLOAT EVEN AS BEING
AND THEIR FAMILIES SEPARATE
THEM OUT. ALL THIS HAPPENED
AGAINST A BACKDROP OF ANTI
IMMIGRANT RHETORIC AND FEDERAL
POLICY. ABOUT DISTRICT THEM
FROM OTHER FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS
AND HUMANITY. SO I THINK WE'VE
HAD A LONG HISTORY OF WORKING
WITH THE STATE AND PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS INCLUDING
THE CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT WITH
BILLION FINE. WHICH LEVERAGE
PUBLIC PRIVATELY FOR THIS
PROVIDE CASH ASSISTANCE
UNDOCUMENTED. CALIFORNIANS AND
THEIR FAMILIES WHO WERE
INELIGIBLE FOCAL THAT NINETEEN
FEDERAL RELIEF AND MULTI
EIGHTEEN AT PROGRAM. MOST
RECENTLY WE ARE ALSO PLEASED TO
BE PARTNERED WITH THE FAIR AND
THE STATE APPOINTED CALIFORNIA
DIGNITY FIND WHICH SPEAKS OF A
TWENTY MILLION. DOLLARS FROM
PHILANTHROPY TO MEET THE URGENT
HUMANITARIAN NEEDS OF MIGRANT
THAT THE THOUSAND CALIFORNIA
BORDER. AND SHOULD BE PROFIT BY
FILING THINKERS AND SUPPORT
THEIR INTEGRATION INTO
REPEATING COMMUNITY. AND
RESTORE THE DIGNITY OF THE
ASYLUM CROSSES. WITH THIS NEW
PLAN CALIFORNIA PHILANTHROPY IN
THE STATE WILL BUILD ON THE
PROGRESS OF OUR PARTNERSHIP IN
TWENTY TWENTY. ONE WE
COLLECTIVELY PROVIDED A
COMBINED A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION AN EMERGENCY CASH
ASSISTANCE. AND DOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS. DURING THE CALL THE
NINETEENTH AND THEN MAKE AND-
AND ALSO THE STATE FUNDED IS
ACTIVE IN THE THAT THE
COMPLAINANT AND FINISH IT. AND
SO WE BELIEVE THAT SB FOUR
FIFTY TWO IS A SHINING EXAMPLE
OF THE FUNDS THE GOVERNMENT
THAT FOCUS ON MEETING THE NEEDS
OF THE STATE. THAT WILL PAY
DIVIDENDS BY ENSURING THE
STABILITY OF CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES AND OUR ECONOMY.
CONTINUED PROSPERITY
PARTICULARLY DURING THE
CRITICAL PINE BUILDING ON
LESSONS LEARNED FROM OUR
EFFORTS TO SUPPORT. STATE WIDE
COUNTY WIDE- INITIATIVE WE KNOW
THAT CORD NATION CRUCIAL. IF WE
REALLY WANT TO MATCH. OUR
INVESTMENT AND- WE BASED TO
ENSURE THERE WILL REACHING.
BOTH ENTER. WITHIN THE STATE
AND WE'RE EXTERNAL. AND SO WE-
THAT IF THERE THE TIME FOR MAX
WEBER TO WERE ACROSS. AND
ENSURE EFFECTIVE IMPLEMENT. AND
IF WE THAT MENTAL NOW MORE THAN
EVER THE QUICK TIME. FOR THE
STATE SUPPORT THE- OF THE- AND
REFUGEE AFFAIRS INSURANCE WE
MATH. THE THREE FOURTHS. TO
PROTECT MOST VULNERABLE- READ
AND AMONG THE- AND MAKING WEEK
OR THAT EXCEPT FELT. WE WERE
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE-
AND- CAL THANK POPULATION AND-
OR YOU TO BUY. AT FORTY TWO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. RIGHT IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO DECADES. FOR
S. B. FORCES TWO PLEASE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR BIRDS NAY BY
OUR WITH AS- CALIFORNIA TRUNKS
WERE. THANK YOU ANYONE. RIGHT
SEE NONE- THE REMOTE TEST
STATION. SEEING NONE OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO DECADE
SUPPORT FOR SB. FOUR FIFTY TWO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
SB FOUR FIFTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
FIFTY TWO. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
LINE ONE SEVENTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN
MORNING JERRY MEMBERS
TECHNOLOGY DOTS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION AND THE LOS
ANGELES. MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI IN
SUPPORT OF. SB FOUR FIFTY TWO
THANK YOU. NINE ONE SEVENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MICHAEL RAT AGAIN ON
BEHALF OF THE SANTA CLARA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE ONE
SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS DIMITRIUS HE WOULD WITH
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ONE ONE SEVENTY THREE YOUR- MY
ONE SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE
SEVENTY THREE YOU MAY BE ON
MUTE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WELL
MANIFEST IF THE CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE IN SUPPORT.
WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. RIGHT THANK
YOU WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
OPPOSITION I DO NOT HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES LISTED IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO IT. SB FOUR FIFTY
TWO. RIGHT SIGNAL REMOTE
TESTIMONY SITE. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO'D LIKE TO
INDICATE OPPOSITION TO SB. FOUR
NINETY FOUR FIFTY TWO. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR FIFTY
TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN.
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR FIFTY TWO
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO
COMMENT IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU OPERATOR
YOU MAY CLOSE THE LINES THAT'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR. QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. THE
BILL. THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND. SENDIRI
MAKE LOVE THANK YOU- MISTER
CHEN MEMBERS JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU FOR THE MOTION AND
SECOND TO- I LOOK FORWARD TO
MOVING THIS ALONG- THIS IS
PARTICULARLY ALSO FOR REGIONS
THAT DON'T HAVE LOCAL SUPPORT
FOR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES AND
FOR THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND MOTIONS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE STONE HI STONE AYE
GALLAGHER. CHAU CHIU. DAVIES
DAVIES NO GONZALEZ CONSULT AYE
HOLDEN. KALRA KALRA AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN. REYES
FIVE YES I. THE BILL'S ON CALL
IT NEEDS TO MORE THANK YOU.
SENATOR LEONARD WILL MOVE TO
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB. FOUR FOUR
SEVEN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
AND GOOD MORNING- CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES- I'M PRESENTING
SENATE BILL FOUR FOUR SEVEN
WHICH EXTENDS OF VICTIMS RIGHTS
TO THE RIGHT OF THEIR LOVED
ONES TO PURSUE ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR HUMAN SUFFERING- EVEN AND
ESPECIALLY IF THEY DIE PRIOR TO
A CASE RESOLUTIONS- CALIFORNIA
IS JUST ONE OF FIVE STATES-
THAT ALLOWS VICTIM RIGHTS FOR
PAIN AND SUFFERING REDRESSED TO
DIE WITH THE VICTIM- SO THIS
IS- AN ISSUE OF JUSTICE IN. ANY
TIME BUT IN THIS CASE IT'S BEEN
PARTICULARLY EXACERBATED BY THE
COVERT PANDEMIC. AND ALL TOO
OFTEN DEFENDANTS TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF EXISTING LAW OF PROLONGING
COURT PROCEEDINGS IN HOPES
THOSE DELAYS WILL OUTLIVE THE
VICTIMS OF THEIR OWN NEGLIGENCE-
THIS IS WRONG AND THEY SHOULD
BE NOT REWARDED WHEN AN
INDIVIDUAL DOES NOT LIVE LONG
ENOUGH. TO HAVE THEIR DAY IN
COURT EVEN WITH THOSE WHO WERE
GRANTED A PREFERENCE TRIAL- I
HAVE BEEN WORKING ARE WITH
OPPONENTS ON THE POSSIBILITY OF
AMENDMENTS. ONE SET OF OPPOSING
AMENDMENTS WANT TO THE BILL
NARROWED TO ONLY APPLY TO CASES
WHERE AN INDIVIDUAL WAS GRANTED
PREFERENCE. FOR THEIR CASE AND
THE TRIAL WAS DELAYED DUE TO
COVERED. A NINETEEN HOWEVER-
ONE OF THE VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS THAT THAT AMENDMENT
WOULD CAPTURE FOR INDIVIDUALS
WHO WERE ELIGIBLE FOR
PREFERENCE WERE FILED A MOTION
FOR PREFERENCE. BUT DID NOT
LIVE LONG ENOUGH TO ATTAIN IT
SINCE THE COURTS WERE CLOSED
DUE TO COVERED. I CONCERNS HAVE
ALSO BEEN EXPRESSED AT THIS
BILL CREATES A DOUBLE DIP. BUT
AS THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
POINTS OUT THERE'S AN IMPORTANT
DISTINCTION BETWEEN THE
SURVIVORS ACTION BROUGHT ON
BEHALF OF THE DECEDENT. VERSUS
A WRONGFUL DEATH SUIT BROUGHT
ON BEHALF OF A SURVIVING FAMILY
MEMBER OF A PERSON WHOSE DEATH
WAS CAUSED BY THE NEGLIGENCE OF
ANOTHER. THEIR NON THE LESS
NALYTICALLY DISTINCT CAUSES OF
ACTION THAT SEEKS VERY
DIFFERENT TYPES OF- DAMAGES IN
FOR INFLICTED ON DIFFERENT
PEOPLE. I AM ACTIVELY ENGAGED
WITH OPPOSITION HOPE WILL
CONTINUE TO FIND COMMON GROUND
UNTIL THEN ARE THE
CONVERSATIONS WILL CONTINUE. SB
FOUR FOUR SEVEN REFLECTS THE
FACT THAT VICTIM SHOULD NOT
SUFFER DUE TO THE SYSTEM FOR
WHATEVER REASON. THE SYSTEM
THAT CANNOT ADJUDICATE THEIR
CRIMES PRIOR TO DEATH. VICTIMS
AND THEIR LOVED ONES DESERVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ATTEND
JUSTICE HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT VIA THE TELEPHONE LINE.
IS LAUREL HOW BERNIE ON BEHALF
OF THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA. ANTENA SCHWEIKERT
ABOUT A SPECIFIC CASE I THANK
YOU TO ALL OF YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR AN
IPHONE. THANK YOU I HAVE. THREE
NAMES LISTED LAURA HOW MANY. AS
A PRIMARY WITNESS CRISTINA
SWEAR OCCURRED AS A PRIMARY
WITNESS AND THEN ALSO
POTENTIALLY MARK BRAT WHO IS ON
STANDBY SO WILL TAKE TO
WITNESSES. OR A HOBBY. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS LAUREL HALL BENEATH AND
A BOARD MEMBER OF THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA WHICH
IS CO SPONSORING THE BILL ALONG
WITH THE CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA. AND ASKING YOU TO
PASS SB FOUR FORTY SEVEN AND
ELIMINATE THE DEATH DISCOUNT
FOR HUMAN SUFFERING DAMAGES.
EXAMPLES OF HUMAN SUFFERING
DAMAGES ARE DESTRUCTION OF THE
ABILITY TO WALK SEVERE AND
DISFIGURING BURNS MAYBE IT IS
BEST JUST CANCERS THAT SLOWLY
AND PAINFULLY CRUSHES THE
INTERNAL ORGANS OF THE VICTIM.
SENATOR LAYERED NOTED WE ARE
ONE OF ONLY FIVE STATES THAT
WHITE THAT THESE DAMAGES OF THE
VICTIM DOES NOT PUT SIMPLY
UNDER EXISTING LAW IF A PERSON
OR COMPANIES BAD PONDERED
BECAUSE OF INJURY. THEY GET A
WINDFALL IF THEIR INJURIES KILL
THEIR VICTIMS. THE DEATH
DISCOUNT FALL HARDEST ON PEOPLE
WHO DO NOT HAVE LOST INCOME
SUCH AS ELDERS AND STAY AT HOME
PARENTS AND PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES. BECAUSE MOST OF
THEIR DAMAGES ARE AT THE HUMAN
SUFFERING THAT THEY HAVE
RESULTS FROM THEIR INJURIES.
AND AS SENATOR LETTER ALSO
NOTED THERE IS A STRONG
FINANCIAL INCENTIVE FOR THE
LAWYER TO REPRESENT THOSE BAD
ACTORS TO DELAY AND OBSTRUCT
COURT CASES IN THE HOPES THAT
THE VICTIM WILL DIE BEFORE
TRIAL. AND THAT THE DAMAGES
WILL DIE WITH THEM. SB FOUR
SEVENTY SEVEN DOES NOT CHANGE
DAMAGES CAPS IT DOES NOT CHANGE
THE BURDEN OF PROOF IT DOES NOT
CHANGE THE RULES OF EVIDENCE.
IT'S SIMPLY ALLOW HUMAN
SUFFERING DAMAGES TO BE TREATED
LIKE OTHER KINDS OF DAMAGES
WHEN AN INJURED PERSON DOLLARS.
FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR YOUR I
THOUGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THEN CRISTINA SWECKER. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MY NAME IS CHRISTINA SCORECARD
I WAS MARRIED TO MY HUSBAND
GEORGE WHITE PARTS OF FORTY
EIGHT YEARS. ON FEBRUARY TWENTY
FIFTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE HE
PASSED AWAY FROM MESOTHELIOMA.
A TERMINAL CANCER CAUSED BY
ASBESTOS STUDENTS DIAGNOSED IN
JUNE OF TWENTY NINETEEN WHEN
THE DOCTORS TOLD THE BAD NEWS
THAT WAS ABSOLUTELY DEVASTATED
I WAS ANXIOUS AND SCARED OF
WHAT MY LIFE MIGHT BE LIKE
WITHOUT HIM BY MY SIDE. STE BUT
GEORGE SHOWED STRENGTH IN THE
CANCER DIAGNOSIS IN STRIDE. HE
WAS A FAMILY MAN IT WAS THE
TIME TO DO WHATEVER TREATMENT
NECESSARY TO BE WITH ME AND.
OUR DAUGHTER. HE WAS A ROCK-
MILLION DOLLAR FOR VERY
DIFFICULT PROJECT. HE NOT
RESPOND TO THIS. HE WAS
NAUSEOUS. VERY TIRED AND-
COMPLETELY LOCKED HAPPENS. AND
YOU MERELY LAST THIRTY POUNDS.
THE DOCTORS WOULD START YOU MAY
NOT TREATMENT WELL WE SIMPLY
FOLLOW BETTER I TO THE WAS
PROGRESSING SITE HE COMPLAINED
TO ME ABOUT INCREASED PAIN OVER
TIME WOULD HAVE A HARD TIME
BELIEVING IF ACTUALLY THEY PUT
HIM ON OXYGEN. IT'S DEVASTATING
TO SEE SOMEONE YOU LOVE BECOME
A SHELL OF WHAT THEY ONCE WERE
AS. YOU WATCH THE LIVE STREAM
OUT OF THEM. HE THEN STARTED-
CERTAINLY WHAT IMPACT AND THEN
DISTRIBUTE STEP DOWN AND HE WAS
ON SALE TREATMENT FOR THE REST
HIS LIFE. DAYS AFTER HAVING
RECENT HOSPITAL FIFTY BUT THE
PAIN. AND GEORGE'S RELENTLESS
DEFINITELY AND- THE MIGHT OF
CONTINUES A VERY LIVE ALL. WEST
MINOR WORK WITH CHILDREN OF PER.
HE SAID IN THE US NAY AND THEN
WORKED FOR DECADES FOR NISSAN
AT THE PARK MANAGER. SEVERAL
SAN DIEGO EVERY DAY. DURING THE
TIME AND THE FUNDING WANT TO.
STEP OF THINGS ARE PRETTY. HIM
ANY WITH REGULAR EXPOSE TO PASS
OF DEBT. WE DELIVERY THIS
DOCUMENT WE- TO HIS TERM CANCER.
HIS THIRD FILED THIS ACTION
BECAUSE HE WANTED TO- NISSAN
ACCOUNTABLE AND GET A STAND
COURT. WE WERE GRANTED A
PREFERENTIAL TRIAL DATE. IN
JUNE OF TWENTY TWENTY. TWO HIT.
TO HIS OWN THIS BUT THE CODE
NINETEEN PACKED THEM. TO CLOSE
THE COURTS. OKAY THE LADY OVER
OVER SERGEI GET INTO ANSWER.
AND ANGERED ME TO THINK THAT
AFTER. TOWARDS WEST ALL THE
PAIN I WAS A AND ALL EMBRACE.
THE NEEDS ARE NOW NEVER BE
HELPFUL ACCOUNTABLE BECAUSE NOT
LONG ENOUGH. TO MAKE IT TRIAL.
IF SOMEONE ASSOCIATE THAT THE
DAY BEFORE THEY TRIAL THE
COUPLE TO COME ALL THE- ARE
SHOULD NOT BENEFIT. CANNOT BE
JEFF. I YOU TO SUPPORT BILL
FOUR. TWO ENABLE FOR. SO WHO.
THAT LED. ONLY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND CONSIDER. THANK
YOU. FOR IS THERE ANYONE IN
HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK AND- OF SB. FOUR FOUR
SEVEN. GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN BURST MIKE
WEST ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL ALSO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
IN THE HEARING ROOM. SEE THAT
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR THOSE WHO'D
LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT FOR S.
B. FOUR FOUR SEVEN AND AGAIN
WE'RE TAKING NAME AFFILIATION
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB OR FORTY SEVEN. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
TWENTY SEVEN YOU MADE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. NINE ONE SIX THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MAP BROUGHT
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NINE ONE ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MEMBERS YES
SHE ARE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PLAN THAT WHERE THE
FIFTY. NINE SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CURTIS PLAYING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR FOUR
SEVEN THANK YOU. NINE ONE FIFTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. DANIEL GOOD CARRIED ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA
PROBLEM BECAUSE BOXES OF THE
MEASURE. SIX NINE EIGHTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. EIGHTY EIGHT YOU MAY BE
ON MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD. CHECK
THE TURN ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER TRADE WITH CALIFORNIA
AND ALSO OFFERING THE STATE
DEPARTMENT BEHALF OF UFCW AND
THE EXPECTED SUPPORTERS SPOKE
SIXTEEN RETIREE THANK YOU. WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT TO YOU
AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT- WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO OPPOSITION I HAVE
TO OPPOSITION WITNESSES LISTED
RIGHT BELOW HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. AND THEN ALICIA WAGON
WITH THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION ON THE PHONE. MIKE
BELOW. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
AM LIKE BELOW SPEAKING TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CIVIL JUSTICE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE CALIFORNIA DEFENSE COUNSEL.
YOU KNOW I HAVE THE HIGHEST
PERSONAL AND PROFESSIONAL
REGARD FOR SENATOR LAYERED AND
WE ARE HAVING CONVERSATIONS
WHICH IDEA WAS PRODUCTIVE. WAS
ALSO GREAT NALYSIS LAYING OUT
THE POLICY ISSUES. WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT BOTH THE
BREADTH AND SCOPE OF THE BILL.
THE PRESENT BILL APPLY TO
ESSENTIALLY EVERY TORT CLAIM
WHERE THE PLAINTIFF DIES PRIOR
TO JUDGMENT EVEN IF THERE'S
ABSOLUTELY NO RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THE UNDERLYING TORT.
AND THE DEATH OF PLANO. YOU
COULD HAVE A WRONGFUL
TERMINATION CLAIM FOR EXAMPLE
AND THEN FOLLOWED BY A CAR
ACCIDENT THAT RESULTED IN THE
PLAINTIFFS DEATH. OBVIOUSLY NO
ONE WAS ATTEMPTING TO DELAY
ANYTHING HOPING THAT THE
PLAINTIFF DIED IT WAS A RANDOM
EVENT. BUT THIS BILL WOULD
APPLY. WE'RE ALSO CONCERNED
ABOUT THE SKULL. AT THIS POINT
WITH THE- THE SO CALLED SUNSET
CLAUSES OF BASED ON A CRUISE
ACTIONS BEFORE TWENTY TWENTY
SIX IT WILL APPLY TO EVERY
EXISTING CLAIM. BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY THOSE OF APPROVED BY
NOW WILL ALSO APPLY TO
EVERYTHING THAT ARISES DURING
THE FOUR YEAR PERIOD. PLUS THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS APPLE
COUPLED WITH THAT UNDERLYING
TORT. WAS THE TIME TO GET TO
STYLE SO IT'S NOT A FOUR YEAR.
PERIOD IT'S A VERY LONG PERIOD
COULD BE TEN TWELVE FOURTEEN
YEARS. EFFECTIVE THIS WILL
DRIVE UP- DAMAGE AWARDS
DRAMATICALLY IN RECENT YEARS
WELL RESPECTED PUBLIC CLAIMS
FOR EXAMPLE THE NUMBER HAS
GROWN SLIGHTLY BUT THE SIZE OF
THE AWARDS HAS GROWN GREATLY.
PRIMARILY IN THE NON ECONOMIC
AREA THIS IS A VERY SUBSTANTIAL
CHANGE IN THE LAW AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO TALK TO SENATOR
LAYERED. BUT. AT THIS POINT WE
ARE OPPOSED THANK YOU. I YOU.
THEN ONLY SHOW WHITEMAN THE
PHONE PLEASE. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING MR JERRY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME'S ALICIA
WAGNER ON AND I AM THE DEPUTY
GENERAL COUNSEL OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
AND I AM ALSO HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE COALITION OF TWENTY SIX
HEALTHCARE PROVIDER FACILITY IN
KERRY ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL UNLESS IT'S
AMENDED. AT A TIME OF PROVIDERS
HAVE BEEN ON THE FRONT LINES
CARRYING FOR KOBE NINETEEN
PATIENTS AND PATIENTS WILL
CONTINUE TO NEED ACCESS TO
VITAL SERVICES. THIS BILL AS
IT'S WRITTEN WOULD PLACE YET
ANOTHER FINANCIAL BURDEN ON
PHYSICIAN PRACTICES AND HEALTH
FACILITIES ABILITY TO CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE CRITICAL CARE TO
PATIENTS. THE BILL WILL RESULT
IN A FUNDAMENTAL CHANGE IN
DAMAGE OF ON CALIFORNIA AND A
LOT AND I'VE NORTE UNDERLYING
RATIONALE UPON WHICH DAMAGE
AWARDS ARE BASED. AND WHILE THE
BILL DOES NOT CHANGE THE MICRO
STATUTES EXPRESSLY THE AFFECTED
WILL HAVE A MEDICAL CASES THAT
THE POTENTIAL. POTENTIALLY
DOUBLING AWARD AMOUNTS TO CLEAN
UP. WHICH CARDS PROVIDER
LIABILITY INSURANCE PREMIUMS TO
SUBSTANTIALLY INCREASE.
CREATING AN IMPACT ON OUR
MEMBERS ABILITY TO CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE CARE TO ALL OF
CALIFORNIA'S PATIENTS AND
PARTICULARLY THOSE MOST
VULNERABLE. SB FOUR FOUR SEVEN
WILL GIVE RISE TO INCREASE THE
COST TO HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS
AND PATIENTS MORE LITIGATION
CLOGGING OUR COURTS SYSTEM. AND
UPENDING THE LONGSTANDING
POLICY IN CALIFORNIA THAT PORT
DAMAGES ARE INTENDED TO
COMPENSATE THE PERSON WHO
SUFFERED THE INJURIES DIRECTLY.
CURRENTLY THE ONLY WAY TO
FAIRLY ESTABLISH EVIDENCE THE
PAIN AND SUFFERING WOULD BE
THROUGH TESTIMONY OF THE
INJURED PERSON AFTER PERSON
DOES THAT EVIDENCE OF WHAT
AMOUNT TO HEARSAY TESTIMONY
WHICH IS SECONDHAND
INFORMATION. THAT COULD NOT BE
SUBSTANTIATED. UNDER A
LONGSTANDING LONG CALIFORNIA
PLAINTIFFS AND THEIR HEIRS HAVE
SEVERAL OPTIONS AND AVENUES TO
BE COMPENSATED FOR THEIR LOSSES
IN A WAY THAT BALANCES THE
PUBLIC POLICY INTEREST. OF
PRESERVING ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE SERVICES WHILE PROVIDING
APPROPRIATE COMPENSATION TO
THOSE WHO WERE INJURED.
EXISTING LAW IN CALIFORNIA ALSO
PROVIDES FOR TRIAL PREFERENCE
FOR ANYONE WHO IS NOT EXPECTED
TO SURVIVE. THROUGH TRIAL AND
LITIGATION. THE HEALTHCARE
COMMUNITY RECOGNIZING THE
BACKLOG THAT COATED NINETEEN
HAS CREATED IN THE COURT SYSTEM.
AS OFFERED AMENDMENTS THAT
WOULD ALLOW FOR ANY PERSONAL
INJURY ACTION FILED IN IN WHICH
THE PLAINTIFF REQUEST TRIAL
PREFERENCE. AND THE
CONSIDERATION OF THAT REQUEST
WAS DELAYED DUE TO THE PANDEMIC.
TO ALLOW THE SURVIVORS TO
RECOVER INTERCEPT THE LEGAL
RATE ON ANY JUDGMENT OBTAINED
CALCULATED FROM THE TIME OF
FILING THE REQUEST THE TRIAL
PREFERENCE. IF IT PROCEEDS ALL
AGES THE ISSUE AND
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT HANNAH
PROVIDE THE PLAINTIFFS FAMILY
WITH ADDITIONAL RELIEF AND
AWARDS AND AT THE SAME TIME
KEEPS THE PAIN AND SUFFERING
AND NON ECONOMIC DAMAGES
PRESIDENT INTACT FOR PURPOSES
OF THESE LAWSUITS. WITHOUT
AMENDMENTS THAT LIMIT THE
APPLICABILITY OF THIS BILL. SB
FOUR FOUR SEVEN WILL BE A LOT
MORE TO EXPANSION OF DAMAGES
FOR INJURIES GOT TO FIX THAT
YOU'RE INTERESTED NOT IN KERR.
AS WELL AS ANOTHER VAGUE
SUBJECTIVE AN UNLIMITED SOURCE
FOR LARGER WORKING TENEMENTS
PERSONAL. INJURY CASES IN
CALIFORNIA. ENABLING PLAINTIFFS
LAWYERS WHO TYPICALLY OF COURSE
OF THE SETTLEMENT TO COLLECT
MORE FEES. THE RESULTING
SETTLEMENTS IN PERSONAL INJURY
CASES WILL BE BORNE BY
CONSUMERS HAVING TO PAY HIGHER
PRICES FOR HEALTH INSURANCE AND
RISK PATIENT SOUTH AFRICA CARE.
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES. FOR THESE
REASONS OUR COALITION OF
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS FACILITIES
IN CARRIERS MUST RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE. SB FOUR FOUR SEVEN AT
THIS TIME AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR NO VOTE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD
LIKE TO DECADE OPPOSITION DOES
BEFORE. FORTY SEVEN. SEEING
NONE THE REMOTE TESTIMONY SITE.
SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR THOSE WHO'D
LIKE TO INDICATE OPPOSITION TO
SB FOUR FOUR SEVEN AGAIN WE'RE
TAKING NAME AFFILIATION HAVE
OPPOSITION ONLY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN A POSITION OF SB FOUR FORTY
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WHAT
BEGAN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. OR FORTY
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. NINE ONE EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU- BRAINSTEM JOB HALF
THE CALIFORNIA PODIA ETTRICK
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION. NINE ONE EIGHTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS STATE MORTGAGE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY. RESPECTFULLY ALIGNER
COMMENTS BUT THOSE THAT MR
BELOW RESPECTFULLY. NINE ONE
EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NUMBER CAN BE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT ALSO. NINE
ONE SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING ZACHARY CORBEAU WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION LIKE TO ALIGN OUR
POSITION WITH SEJAK IN CMA WE
ARE ALSO RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED THANK YOU. WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT IN Q.
THANK YOU OPERATOR YOU MAY
CLOSE THE LINES THEN FOR US
BEFORE FOR SEVEN I WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. THIS
KALRA. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER SURE AND THANK YOU
CENTER FOR BRINGING THIS
LEGISLATION FORWARD I THINK-
THE REALITY IS THAT IT IS
COMMONLY OKAY IT'S A COMMON
TRIAL PRACTICE- FOR- SILVA
DEFENSE ATTORNEYS TO PLAY THE
LONG GAME PLAY OUT FOR THE
SPECIFIC PURPOSE. OF- THE ROLE
OF WAITING IT WAITING OUT
SOMEONE THAT IS TERMINAL- AND-
IT'S YOU KNOW I THINK IT'S A
MORAL ASPECT OF WHAT WE SEE
SOMETIMES MAY NOT BE ILLEGAL
BUT I CERTAINLY THINK THAT-
THEY REALLY CALLS INTO
QUESTION- OUR SYSTEM WELL IN
THAT KIND OF PRACTICES CONTINUE
TO ALLOW TO HAPPEN WITHOUT-
TRUE COMPENSATION- FOR THE PAIN
AND SUFFERING. AND SO I
APPRECIATE YOU BRING THIS FOR
YOU KNOW IT'S NOT AN EASY PIECE
OF LEGISLATION TO BRING FORWARD
TO- GETTING KNOW GIVEN- YOU
KNOW THAT THE OPPOSITION MAY
FACE BUT I THINK WHEN IT COMES
TO CREATING A SYSTEM THAT
ACTUALLY THE LEAST ATTEMPTS TO
FIND JUSTICE. FOR THOSE THAT
ARE THAT ARE OF VICTIMS I THINK
IT DOES GO A LONG WAY IN THAT
REGARD AND FOR THOSE THAT HAVE
SUCH GREAT CONCERN ABOUT
INCREASED INSURANCE RATES. I
HAVE SOME IDEAS ABOUT THAT AS
WELL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE- I'D MISS REYES I
WASN'T SURE THAT MR GALLAGHER.
THANK YOU SENATOR I'M REALLY
GLAD THAT YOU DID BRING AND I
THINK ONE OF THE HARDEST THINGS
AS A PLAINTIFFS ATTORNEY. WAS
HAVING PLAINTIFF DIED AND THEN
TELLING THE FAMILY THAT.
BASICALLY THE CLAIM FOR THE
MAJORITY OF THEIR CLAIM TO
VALUE THE CLAIM DIED WITH THEIR
FAMILY MEMBERS WITH THEIR LOVED
ONES. I THINK THE FACT THAT YOU
PUT A- A SUNSET ON IT I THINK
SOUNDS LIKE A GOOD COMPROMISE
TO- TRY THIS OUT FOR A WHILE
HI. THE FACT THAT WE ARE ONLY
ONE OF FIVE STATES. THAT DO NOT
ALLOW THAT IS A GREAT CONCERN
SOMETHING THAT. FOR MANY YEARS
NEEDED TO BE ADDRESSED I
APPRECIAE YOUR WORK ON IT AND
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT YOU'RE
WORKING WITH OPPOSITION TO TRY
TO FIND WAYS TO MAKE THIS IS.
GOOD LEGISLATION POSSIBLE
NOBODY'S GOING TO BE COMPLETELY
SATISFIED WE ALL KNOW THAT BUT
THE FACT THAT YOU HAVE.
INTRODUCED THIS AND ARE MOVING
FORWARD WITH THAT. I THINK IS.
A WONDERFUL THING FOR MANY OF
THOSE. AS I SAID WHO WILL LOSE
THEIR LIFE DURING THE PENDENCY
OF THE CLAIM. I THANK YOU FOR
THAT. AND WITH THAT I WOULD
MOVE THE MOVE TO GET THE BILL
THANK YOU WE DO AS A MOTION IS
THEIR SECOND. AND THE SECOND
THANK YOU MR GALLAGHER AND THE
MISTAKES- CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND
THE GOOD INTENTIONS BEHIND THIS
BILL SENATOR- AND HOW KNOWING
YOU AS I DO- I KNOW THAT-
YOU'RE TRYING TO. ADDRESS AN
ISSUE THAT THE TO EITHER
SOMEONE ELSE BROUGHT HERE THAT
YOU'RE SEEN IN THE SYSTEM- I
THINK THE ISSUE HERE IS THAT
THERE'S A REASON WHY WE'VE
ALWAYS HAD THIS LEGAL.
DISTINCTION WHERE. YOU KNOW IF
A PERSON PASSES AWAY THE PROPER
CLAIM IS. A WRONGFUL DEATH
CLAIM. THE PAIN AND SUFFERING
BECAUSE THAT'S YOU KNOW FOR THE
VICTIM IT IS IT IS STILL LIVING
IT'S NOT THAT THERE AREN'T
REMEDIES BECAUSE THERE ACTUALLY
ARE- IN WRONGFUL DEATH CLAIMS
THERE'S INCLUDING PUNITIVE
DAMAGES- AND MANY OTHER
DIFFERENT REMEDIES THAT. DO
RESULT IN COMPENSATION. FOR THE
AGREED FAMILY THAT'S LOST- THE
FAMILY MEMBER- IN TERMS OF
ABUSES IN ANOTHER UNETHICAL
PRACTICES WE SEE THEM ON ALL
SIDES OF. THE LITIGATION SYSTEM
AND WE ALSO HAVE TOOLS ALREADY
IN OUR- LEGAL SYSTEM TO DEAL
WITH EITHER FRIVOLOUS MOTIONS
OR DELAY TACTICS- WE HAVE THOSE
IN OUR CIVIL PROCEDURE CODE TO
PUNISH THOSE WHO ARE DOING
UNETHICAL THINGS TO KEEP
PEOPLE. FROM DELAYED FROM
DELAYING JUSTICE- SO. YOU KNOW
I CAN'T SEE A REAL STRONG
REASON FOR CHANGING THAT LEGAL
DISTINCTION WHICH AGAIN STILL
GIVES EITHER THE AGGRIEVED
PARTY THE VICTIM WHO- IS
CURRENTLY GOING THROUGH PAIN
AND SUFFERING THE CHANCE TO
PROVE THEIR DAMAGES- IN COURT
OR IF YOU HAVE A PLAN OF WHO
HAS PASSED AWAY FOR THE FAMILY
STILL TO PROCEED WITH. A
WRONGFUL DEATH ACTION AND GET-
COVERAGE- THE COUPLE QUESTIONS
I JUST HAVE FOR YOU IS- THIS TO
ME THIS WHERE TO GO FOR HOW
DOES ONE PROVE DAMAGES- OF PAIN
AND SUFFERING IF THE IF THE
PERSON HAS NOW PASSED AWAY- WHO
HOW IS EVIDENCE GOING TO BE
INTRODUCED. TO PROVE THAT PAIN
AND SUFFERING AND THEN WHAT
WOULD BE THE- YEAH THE ABILITY
TO CHECK THE ACCURACY OR TO
CROSS EXAMINE- THAT EVIDENCE N
THE COURT OF LAW AS A PRACTICAL
MATTER WHAT ROW AS A PRACTICAL
MATTER YOU'VE GOT TO A HEART OF
THE CONUNDRUM. WHICH IS THAT.
ARE THERE IS A DELAY IN HEARING
THE PEOPLE THAT COULD PREVENT
THE EVIDENCE ARE NOT ABLE
PRESENTED ARE NOT ABLE TO DO
IT. AND THEN IT MOVES IT INTO A
DIFFERENT CATEGORY BECAUSE
THERE WAS THAT DELAY. AND THE
REAL GOAL IS TO NOT HAVE THAT
SO THAT IN FACT YOU CAN HAVE
THE EVIDENCE AS BEST YOU CAN IN
PERSON WITHOUT HAVING TO SHIFT.
TO THE NEXT STEP OBVIOUSLY YOU
WOULD USE WHATEVER MEANS YOU
HAVE TO INTRODUCE THE EVIDENCE
AND GET TO THE FACTS. TO READ
THEM TO YOU CAN RUN INTO ISSUES
LIKE HERE SAVE FOR INSTANCE-
AND. YEAH I GUESS IF YOU'RE
HAVING MAYBE A DOCTOR. TESTIFY
AS TO WHAT THEY YOU KNOW HAD
SEEN YOU KNOW WHAT'S THE
ABILITY TO. AND AGAIN LIKE
THERE ISN'T A REMEDY TAKEN AWAY
BECAUSE AGAIN NOW THE CASE IF
SOMEONE PASSES AWAY AND THAT IT
FORTUNATE CIRCUMSTANCE WHICH
DOES HAPPEN. TRADITIONALLY THAT
BECOMES A WRONGFUL DEATH CLAIM.
AND NOW THE FAMILY IS BRINGING
THE CLAIM AND THERE AND
INCLUDED IN THAT IS ALL OF THE
THINGS THAT THEY HAVE LOST AS A
RESULT- BUT THE PAIN AND
SUFFERING IS REAL AND IT IS
DISTINCT AND WHAT HAPPENED IS.
I MEAN IN NINETEEN WHATEVER THE
YEAR WAS- SIXTY ONE THE
LEGISLATURE SET THIS UP AND
THEN THE CALIFORNIA LAW REVIEW
A COMMISSION ACTUALLY
RECOMMENDED THREE DIFFERENT
THINGS INCLUDING THIS IN THE
LEGISLATURE CHOSE. TO LEAVE
THIS OUT AND IT'S THE REASON
THAT WERE ONE OF JUST FIVE
STATES- THAT DOES IT THIS WAY
IT IN THE FOR THE ANALYSIS
RAISES A FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION.
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT- THIS IS
ABOUT ON UNDERLYING IN JUST A
CERTAIN UNDERLYING THING THAT
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED FOR ABOUT
COVERED AND IT IS ACTUALLY
ABOUT BOTH BECAUSE THE
UNDERLYING JUSTICE NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED IN IS SOMETHING THAT
WOULD BE ADDRESSED BY THIS
BILL. IT WAS MAGNIFIED BY COVE
IT IT WAS IN EVIDENCE BY THE
FACT THAT THE COURT SHUT DOWN.
THAT PEOPLE COULD NOT APPLY
EVEN IN A TIMELY WAY FOR
PREFERENCES THE PREFERENCES
WERE LIMITED IN CERTAIN WAYS
WHETHER IT WAS AGE SEVENTY OVER
OTHER THINGS AND IF SOMEBODY
HAD A PAIN AND SUFFERING ISSUE-
THEY WERE NOT AFFORDED THE
ABILITY TO FULLY HAVE REDRESS.
IT IN THE TIME OF OUR FORTUNES
HAVE. DO YOU HAVE ANY DATA ON
HOW MANY CASES WERE DELAYED
DURING THE CODE EMERGENCY AND
DIDN'T GET A PREFERENTIAL-
TRIAL DATE OR HAVE FAILED TO
HAVE THEIR TRIAL- I CAN SEE IF
THERE IS DATA FROM THE COURTS
THERE IS ANECDOTAL EVIDENCE I
MEAN WE HAD SOMEBODY TESTIFY.
ONE PERSON JUST TO DEMONSTRATE
HOW THAT IN FACT HAPPENED I
DON'T KNOW IF IT WAS
ACCUMULATED IN A DATA. AMANDA
TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE IT BUT
WE'LL CHECK WE'LL SEE IF
ANYTHING EXISTS WILL PROVIDE
WELL I THINK I THINK THAT WOULD
BE IMPORTANT TO HAVE ESPECIALLY
AS WE'RE SITTING HERE TRYING TO
MAKE POLICY THAT WE THINK IS.
THE BEST WAY BETTER TO HAVE
LIKE THE- YOU KNOW THE- THE
NUMBERS WE KNOW FOR A FACT THAT
HAPPENED. WE KNOW FOR A FACT IT
HAPPENED THAT'S WHAT THE
WITNESS TESTIFIED TO WE CAN TRY
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THE NUMBERS
WERE. OF HOW IT HAPPENED BUT WE
KNOW IN FACT IT HAPPENED RIGHT
BUT WE'VE KNOWN FOR. YEARS THAT
THIS HAPPENS IT WE DO HAVE
PLAINTIFF TO PASS AWAY DURING
THE PENDENCY OF LITIGATION. AND
WHAT HAPPENED AND WHAT IS WHAT
WE HAVEN'T HAD A PANDEMIC IN
WHICH THE COURTS ESSENTIALLY IN
SOME PARTS OF THE STATE SHUT
DOWN. OR DELAYED IN SUCH A
SUBSTANTIAL MORE AND THAT'S MY
POINT IS IF THIS IS A CODE THAT
ISSUE THEN WE SHOULD HAVE SOME
DATA. IT WOULD BE GOOD FOR US
TO HAVE SOME DATE ON HOW HOW
MANY CASES ARE WE TALKING ABOUT
OR IS THIS. SIMILAR TO WHAT WE
HAVE SEEN THAT THERE ARE CASES
WHERE THIS DOES OCCUR- WE WILL
WORK WITH YOU TO CSS- AND THEN
I MEAN THE INSURANCE WANTED
INSURANCE ISSUE IS I THINK
SOMETHING THAT'S ON EVERYONE'S
MINDS IT INCLUDES. AT THE
PUBLIC AGENCIES THAT ARE
TESTIFYING HERE TODAY. YOUR DO
YOU HAVE AN IDEA OF WHAT. THE
INCREASE IN PREMIUMS MIGHT BE
SEEN IF THIS WAS NOW. CHANGE IN
THIS WAY AND TERMS HOW'S THAT
GOING TO AFFECT. NO COVERAGE NO
I DON'T THINK THAT THAT THERE.
HAVE BEEN ACTUARIAL SORE THINGS
RUN BASED ON ON WHAT IT IS BUT
ONE THING IS CLEAR THAT I WAS
GONNA DRESSED IN THE CLOTHES
THAT CAME UP IS THAT THIS DOES
NOT IN ANY WAY ALTER MICRO THE
CAP EXISTS TO CAP IS NOT
ALTERED. AND SO TO READ
ANYTHING INTO THAT IN REGARD TO
INSURANCE RATE IS NOT CORRECT.
OKAY WELL I'VE I APPRECIATE
THOSE ANSWERS AND AGAIN I KNOW
THIS IS COMING FROM A GOOD
PLACE AND WELL INTENTIONED AND-
CERTAINLY CAN UNDERSTAND AND
SYMPATHIZE WITH THE SITUATIONS.
WHERE THIS HAPPENS I GUESS JUST
WHERE I FALL AS I THINK WE
CURRENT HAVE CURRENT REMEDIES
TO PROVIDE COMPENSATION. I
DON'T THINK IT IS TRUE THAT YOU
LOSE YOUR ENTIRE CLAIM YOU
ACTUALLY JUST NOW HAVE A
DIFFERENT CLAIM IN OR NOT
REPRESENTING YOU LOSE YOUR
ENTIRE CLIENT MORE REPRESENTING
THAT YOU LOSE THE PEACE THAT IS
PAIN AND SUFFERING. RIGHT AND
SO I THINK THAT THERE ARE STILL
THOSE ARE AND FOR ABUSES IT
WHICH I CERTAINLY. I THINK WE
ALL OF WAR IF THERE ARE ABUSES
WE ALSO HAVE REMEDIES. YOU KNOW
FOR THAT IN THE SYSTEM AS WELL
AND I JUST I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
SOME MORE DATA ON. THOSE TWO
ITEMS- BUT- THANK YOU CENTER I
APPRECIATE. YOUR COMMENTS.
THANK YOU MISS DAVIS. THANK YOU
SENATOR AB REALLY JUST KIND OF
THEM TO- FROM MY COLLEAGUE MY
CONCERNS ARE JUST HAVING DATA
AND KNOWING YOU KNOW HOW MANY
CASES- YOU KNOW WHERE FAILED
DURING CULTIVATED I THINK WAS
MARCH TWENTY TWENTY A NOT TO BE
HEARD OR RESOLVED BEFORE THEN
JUST TO SEE IF I WAS LATE THIS
IS A SENSITIVE ISSUE BUT YOU
KNOW IS IT FIVE IS A FIVE
HUNDRED I MEAN WHEN YOU'RE
LOOKING AT LEGISLATION LIKE
THIS I'D LIKE TO KNOW IF WE CAN
FIGURE OUT HOW MANY CASES WERE
DENIED DURING THAT TIME. AND
THEN AGAIN WHEN IT COMES TO
BECAUSE- WHEN IT COMES TO COST
ESPECIALLY WITH INSURANCE MY
CONCERN IS IT USUALLY ENDS UP
GOING DOWN TO THE CUSTOMER ONE
WHERE THE OTHER STARTS HERE AND
THEN THIS IS WHERE IT'S GOING
TO AND IS YOU KNOW THE HOUSE IS
GOING TO BE A COST EFFECTIVE SO
I THINK JUST DATA WOULD BE-
WOULD BE WONDERFUL IF YOU'LL BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE THAT TO MY
STAFF AND MY OFFICE. A. N. I
THINK JUST TO REPEAT TO AND
MAYBE EVEN EXPAND IN SOME CASES
THIS DATA WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
COLLECTED IF SOMEBODY WAS NOT
ALLOWED TO FILE FOR PREFERENCE
FOR WHATEVER REASON THEY'RE NOT
IN THE SYSTEM FOR NOT HAVING
FILED PREFERENCE IT'S LIKE WE
COULD SEE IF PEOPLE COULD COME
FORWARD AND SAY I WAS NOT
ALLOWED TO DO THAT BUT- BUT IT
IT WOULDN'T EXIST IN A STANDARD
WAY OF COURT STATISTICS TO BE
ABLE TO GET TO THE BOTTOM.
HAVING SAID THAT WE WILL LOOK
AND SEE WHAT'S AVAILABLE. THANK
YOU AND WELCOME. THANK YOU
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
SENATOR I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I AGREE
THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT AND NOT
TO CONFLATE IS YOU
APPROPRIATELY STATED THIS IS A
CODE ISSUE THE APPLE FIBER CODE
BUT THERE IS AN UNDERLYING
ISSUE THAT EXIST REGARDLESS.
AND SOME OF THE SPECULATION ON
INSURANCE RATES IS JUST THAT
IT'S SPECULATIVE AND IN A NOTE
REALLY WHAT THAT IMPACT WAS
GOING TO BE BUT BECAUSE THESE
ARE UNDERLYING EXISTING.
LIABILITIES THAT DOES NOT
CHANGE THE CALCULATION REALLY
HOW LONG IT WOULD BE. AND FOR
THOSE ON THIS COMMITTEE WHO
PARTICIPATED HEARINGS THAT WE
HAD JOINTLY WITH THE SENATE.
EARLIER IN THIS YEAR YOU KNOW
THAT THE DATA THAT WE'VE BEEN
COLLECTING FROM THE COURTS HAS
BEEN. A BIT SPARSE AND TRYING
TO COLLECT EXACTLY THESE KINDS
OF DATA IS WHAT WE HAVE BEEN
ASKING FOR TO UNDERSTAND IMPACT
SOUGHT. THE TWO LADIES AND-
WHAT HAPPENED WITHIN THE COURT
SYSTEM AND ONE THING THAT WE DO
KNOW IS THAT DIFFERENT COUNTIES.
THE COUNTER DIFFERENT IMPACTS
AND THERE THERE'S A WIDE
VARIETY OF CROSS CALIFORNIA BUT
THAT SHOULD NOT DISTRACT US
FROM THE NEED. TO LOOK AT THE
UNDERLYING POLICY OF WHETHER OR
NOT. THESE KINDS OF REMEDIES
DIE WITH THE PLAINTIFFS AND
THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE GETTING AT
AND I THINK THIS IS VERY
APPROPRIATE LEGISLATION AT THIS
POINT AND A SIGNIFICANT CHANGE
OF POLICY. FOR THE BETTER FOR
CALIFORNIA AND FOR THOSE WHO
HAVE BEEN. GRIEVOUSLY INJURED
OR- IN THIS CASE DIED BECAUSE
OF INJURIES SUSTAINED. OKAY SO
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND SENATOR YOU MAY CLOSE
I'M ACTUALLY GONNA TAKE YOUR
COMMENTS THAT THE-
FUNDAMENTALLY HAS TO CLOSE IT
JUST SAID PRITCHARD EVERYBODY
ELSE'S COMMENTS WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK IT'S AN ISSUE
OF FAIRNESS I SAT IN THIS ROOM
WITH YOU IN THE JOINT HEARING
OF JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. ON THE
BACKLOG IN THE COURTS AND LOTS
OF THE THINGS YOU SAID WERE THE
EVIDENCE OF THAT HERE SO I
WOULD ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE.
THANK YOU. DO MOST THE SECOND
MOTION TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE AYE STONE AYE
GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER NOTE CHAU.
TWO FIVE TWO BY DAVIES. DAVEY
SNOW GONZALEZ RIGHT GONZALEZ I
HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE KALRA. KALRA
AYE KILEY KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN
REYES. RAYSIDE. THE BILLS OUT
THANK YOU SENATOR. GREAT
SENATOR MITCHELL WILL MOVE TO
ITEM NUMBER NINE SB. THREE
NINETY ONE. THANK YOU TEARS
DOWN THANK YOU TWO NUMBERS
COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU TO
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH US ON THIS BILL. SB THREE
NINETY ONE IS AN EMERGENCY
MEASURE NARROWLY TAILORED THAT
AUTHORIZED IS- COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENT BOARDS INCLUDING
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATIONS TO
SAFELY MEET VIA TELECONFERENCE
DURING EMERGENCIES AND
DISASTERS AND ENSURES THAT FAIR
PARTICIPATION IN THESE MEETINGS
IS ACCESSIBLE MEMBERS. IN
RESPONSE TO THE ONGOING
PANDEMIC THE GOVERNOR ISSUED AN
IO LAST YEAR ALLOWING LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND STATE AGENCIES
TO MEET AND VOTE REMOTELY. YET
NO SIMILAR ACTION HAS BEEN
TAKEN FOR HOAS LEAVING THEM
WITH NO GUIDANCE OR PROCEDURES
DURING THIS UNUSUAL TIME. THE
DAVIS STERLING COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENT ACT REQUIRES HOAS
TO PROVIDE A PHYSICAL MEETING
LOCATION FOR ALL TELECONFERENCE
MEETINGS. WHICH AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE HAS POSED A SIGNIFICANT
HEALTH RISK IN THE MIDST OF THE
ONGOING PANDEMIC. IN THE PAST
YEAR MANY HOAS HAVE FOUND THAT
ORGANIZING IN PERSON MEETINGS
AS CURRENTLY REQUIRED UNDER
EXISTING LAWS. HAS BEEN
IMPRACTICAL UNSAFE OR EVEN
ILLEGAL. IN RESPONSE TO THIS
THE CALIFORNIA LAW REVISION
COMMISSION WORK LAST FALL TO
CRAFT A VERY NARROW POLICY
RECOMMENDATION THAT SETS BEFORE
US TODAY. SB THREE NINETY ONE
SIMPLY WAIVE THE REQUIREMENT TO
PROVIDE AN IN PERSON MEETING
LOCATION FOR TELECONFERENCE
MEETINGS DURING A DECLARED
EMERGENCY OR DISASTER. TO
ENSURE PARTICIPATION IS
ACCESSIBLE TO ALL NUMBER
SOMETHING THAT IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO ME THIS BILL
REQUIRES HOAS TO FULFILL
CERTAIN REQUIREMENTS. THEY MUST
PROVIDE CLEAR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
TO PARTICIPATE. THE MEETING
NOTICE MUST INCLUDE THE
TELEPHONE NUMBER AND EMAIL THE
PERSON WHO CAN PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE WITH THE
TELECONFERENCE PROCESS BOTH
BEFORE. AND DURING THE MEETING.
THEY MUST ENSURE THAT EVERY
DIRECTOR AND MEMBER HAS THE
ABILITY TO PROCESS IT PURCHASE
WITH THE SAME ABILITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE MEETING THAT
WOULD EXIST IF THE MEETING WERE
HELD IN PERSON. ANY VOTER THE
DIRECTOR SHALL BE CONDUCTED BY
ROLL CALL VOTE AND LASTLY
PARTICIPANT SHALL BE GIVEN THE
OPTION OF PARTICIPATING BY
PHONE. FROM OFFERS TO GLOBAL
PANDEMICS RECENT EMERGENCIES IN
CALIFORNIA HAS SHOWN THAT IS
NOT ALWAYS POSSIBLE OR SAFE.
FOR ASSOCIATIONS TO PROVIDE IN
PERSON MEETING LOCATIONS. THAT
IS WHY SB THREE NINETY ONE A
PERMISSIVE BILL THAT SIMPLY
GIVES HOAS ANOTHER OPTION TO
MEET SAFELY DURING TIMES OF
EMERGENCIES. THE SAME OPTION
THAT HAS BEEN GIVEN THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND STATE AGENCIES
IS SO URGENTLY NEEDED. TODAY WE
HAVE WITH US TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY BRIAN HEY BEAR. OF
THE CALIFORNIA CLAREVIEW
COMMISSION PAPER I'M SORRY YOU
BURKE- INTERTEXTUAL A COMMUNITY
ASSOCIATION ATTORNEY FROM
ORANGE COUNTY. WHOSE FIRM
PROVIDES LEGAL COUNSEL FOR
HUNDREDS OF ASSOCIATIONS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WE DO A MOTION
IS THEIR SECOND. AND THE SECOND
THANK YOU SO I DO HAVE TWO
WITNESSES LISTED BRIAN HUBERT
AND DIRK PATCHELL BRIAN HUBERT.
YES THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. I AM BRINGING
A BIRD ON THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA LAW
REVISION COMMISSION AND WE ARE
IN A STATE AGENCY THAT CONDUCTS
ITS BUSINESS AN OPEN PUBLIC
MEETINGS SO. THE PANDEMIC STAY
AT HOME. POSED A SIGNIFICANT
OPERATIONAL PROBLEMS FOR US BOB
THAT'S BECAUSE THE BACK
LOOKING- ACT APPLIES TO STATE
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES REQUIRES
THAT TELECONFERENCE MEETINGS
INCLUDED IN PERSON COMPONENTS-
THAT PROBLEM WAS SOLVED BY IT
FOR US BY THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER FOR THE
DURATION OF THIS EMERGENCY. BUT
WE KNEW THAT THE SAME PROBLEM
EXISTED FOR COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENTS AND THAT THAT HAD
NOT BEEN SOLVED- SO THE
COMMISSION DECIDED TO ACT
QUICKLY TO PREPARE A NARAL
RECOMMENDATION. THAT WOULD
SIMPLY WAVES THE IN PERSON
REQUIREMENTS FOR COMMON
INTEREST DEVELOPMENT MEETINGS.
DURING A DECLARED EMERGENCY IF
THE H. AWAY FOLLOWS A CERTAIN
BASIC PROCEDURAL REQUIREMENTS
THAT WERE DESIGNED TO ENSURE
THAT MEMBERS HAD. THE SAME
RIGHTS TO OBSERVE AND
PARTICIPATE THAT THEY WHAT
HAPPENS TO MEETING WERE HELD IN
PERSON WHICH- I AM HERE TODAY
MOSTLY JUST TO- PROVIDE-
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND ANSWER
QUESTIONS IF YOU HAVE ANY- I
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THERE WE
ALSO TOOK PARTIAL. ARE YOU WITH
US. I AM WITH YOU- CHAIRPERSON
STONE AN ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY
NAME IS DARK PATCHELL- I AM A
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY AND YOU ARE
CURRENTLY AT A TEAM OF
ATTORNEYS THAT REPRESENT MANY
HUNDREDS OF COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENTS ARE C. ID'S IN THE
SOUTHERN HALF OF THE STATE.
ABOUT SIXTEEN MONTHS AGO WITH
THE ONSET OF OUR COVERT
EMERGENCY WITH OUR OUR
COMMUNITIES FACED WITH REALLY
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES. CID
COMMITTEE AS WE KNOW ARE
GOVERNED BY OUR VOLUNTEER
HOMEOWNER BOARDS WHO ARE
REQUIRED TO ACT IN PART THROUGH
OPEN MEETINGS OF THE BOARD.
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES THAT OPEN
MEETINGS PROVIDE FOR A PHYSICAL
LOCATION FOR ASSOCIATION
MEMBERS TO ATTEND HOWEVER AS WE
KNOW STATE AND LOCAL MANDATES
PROVIDED PREVENTED- GATHERING
AND EVEN IF THEY TECHNICALLY
WERE NOT PROHIBITED VOLUNTEER
BOARD MEMBERS RESIDENTS AND
PROFESSIONAL MANAGEMENT HAD
SERIOUS CONCERNS ABOUT HOLDING
PHYSICAL LOCATION OPEN FOR
MEETINGS. AS SUCH AT A REALLY
CRITICAL AN EXTREMELY BUSY TIME
IT WAS VERY DIFFICULT FOR OUR
VOLUNTEER BOARDS TO DO THEIR
JOBS. AND SO. AS WE ALL KNOW BY
NECESSITY THE BROWN ACT IN THE
OTHER STATE LAWS WERE QUICKLY
MODIFIED OR SUSPENDED HOWEVER
THE C. ID'S DID NOT SEE THAT
RELIEF NONETHELESS EVEN WITHOUT
THAT CHANGE THE OPEN MEETING
ACT AT THE TIME THE CáC ID'S
DRIVEN BY THE SAME NECESSITIES
AS GOVERNMENTAL AGENCIES. AND
WITH SOME PROTECTION FROM OUR
GOVERNOR'S ORDER STARTED
CONDUCTING THOSE MEETINGS BY
VIDEO CONFERENCE WITHOUT
PHYSICAL LOCATION AND THAT
ENABLED US TO FOR OUR COMMUNITY
TO CONTINUE TO FUNCTION WELL WE
PROTECT. ALL INVOLVED FROM THE
COVETED ISSUES. THEN WE GOT
REALLY INTERESTING HAPPENED. A
THE BOARD WE TALKED. AT AND
INVOLVEMENT SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASED A COUPLE OF EXAMPLES
FROM SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WE'VE
BEEN AGE RESTRICTED COMMUNITY-
FIFTY FIVE PLUS COMMUNITY AS
MANY KNOW THEM. ABOUT A
THOUSAND DOORS THAT'S REPORTING
A MORE THAN A 100% INCREASE IN
THE NUMBER OF THE PARTICIPATION
AT THAT MEETING BUT THEIR
INVOLVEMENT IN THE COMMUNITY.
WITH ANOTHER AGE RESTRICTED
COMMUNITY OF APPROXIMATELY
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED DOORS THAT
SAYING THAT INCREASE WAS ALMOST
THREE HUNDRED PERCENT. SO SB
THREE NINETY ONE IS VERY SIMPLY
ADDRESSES THIS ISSUE FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES DURING TIMES OF
EMERGENCY. AND ALLOW THEIR
COMMUNITIES TO CONDUCT THEIR
BOARD MEETINGS WITHOUT A
PHYSICAL LOCATION IN A MANNER
JUST LIKE THIS CALL. ALL WHILE
INCORPORATING ENHANCED NOTICE
REQUIREMENTS ENHANCED TECHNICAL
SUPPORT REQUIREMENTS AND ALL
WHILE FULLY MAINTAINING ALL PRE
EXISTING COMMUNITY RECORD
KEEPING REQUIREMENTS SO. BASED
ON ALL OF THAT I PERSONALLY
URGE ALL OF YOU TO SUPPORT SB
THREE NINETY ONE WITH YOUR VOTE
TODAY. I THANK YOU ALL VERY
MUCH I'LL REMAIN ON THE LINE TO
ADDRESS ANY QUESTIONS THAT MAY
ARISE. THANK YOU. WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO OTHERS WHO WANT TO
INDICATE SUPPORT FOR ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM WHO'D IKE TO
INDICATE SUPPORT FOR SB THREE
NINETY ONE. SEEING NONE IN THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR THOSE WHO'D
LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT FOR SB.
THREE NINETY ONE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
NINETY ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN PART OF SB THREE
NINETY ONE. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE WHILE WE GATHER THE LINE
NUMBER.
NINE SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
IRWIN TOTALLY OPPOSITION TO THE
SALE. MY NAME IS ELENA CONRAD
LOAN AND MARINA DEL REY-
AFFORDABLE MEMBER AND I'M
TOTALLY OPPOSED TO THE BILL
THANK YOU. NINE ONE EIGHTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. JENNIFER WATER ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF COMMUNITY MANAGER INSTACART.
ONE MOMENT WHILE WE GATHER
ANOTHER LINE NUMBERS.
NINE ONE
FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
ABOUT SUPPORT AND I'M A BOARD
MEMBER AND BECAUSE OF THE
MEETING AND- THE LAND THERE IN
THE CHAT I FIRMLY OPPOSE WELL
AND I. REALLY THINK YOU SHOULD
THINK ABOUT THAT BOB THANK YOU.
WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT IN
CUBA. THANK YOU. WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO OPPOSITION I HAVE TWO
WITNESSES LISTED TOM SAWYER
FROM THE CENTRE CALIFORNIA
HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATION LAW AND
DOUGLAS ALEXANDER. AN ATTORNEY
IN PRIVATE PRACTICE BOTH WITH
US ON THE TELEPHONE. SO FIRST
TOM SIR. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS TOM SIR LINE ON THE
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE OF THE
CENTER FOR CALIFORNIA
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION LAW.
RETIRED SUPERIOR COURT
COMMISSIONER AND I'M ALSO A
RESIDENT OF A THREE THOUSAND
UNIT- RETIREMENT COMMUNITY
GOVERNED BY NATURE HEY. IN
SOLANO COUNTY I'VE BEEN IN
TOUCH WITH- COLONEL ALEXANDER
WHO WAS SCHEDULED TO TESTIFY IN
ADDITION AND HE IS THAT THE
YIELD GIVE TIME TO ME SO THAT
WE MAY PRESENT. A MORE COHERENT
AND DETAILED STATEMENT TO THE
COMMITTEE I'M SORRY THAT IS
SEVEN WE DO DOES NOT ALLOWED
YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES. THREE
MINUTES OKAY WE THANK THE
AUTHOR AND CONTINUE TO THANK
YOU FOR TAKING THE HELP FOR
AMENDMENTS TO SP THREE NINETY
ONE. HOWEVER ONE TROUBLING
ISSUE REMAINS. AND THAT IS THE
PRINT VERSION THAT LITERALLY
BELIEVES TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY IN ASSOCIATION
LECTIONS. WHETHER THE ELECTIONS
ARE FOR BOARD DIRECTORS ORDER
SET SPECIAL ASSIGNMENTS THE ONE
REMAINING OBJECTIONABLE
PROVISION CREATES A NEW
OPPORTUNITY. FOR ABUSE OF THE
ELECTION PROCEDURE BY INCUMBENT
BOARDS BY PERMITTING
CANCELLATION OF THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE IN PERSON
NEEDING TO WITNESS THE OPENING
AND TABULATION OF BALLOTS.
OFTEN WANT TO BUILD BEFORE A
COMMITTEE WE CAN ONLY SPECULATE
ON ITS FUTURE IMPACT BUT NOT SO
WITH THIS BILL. BECAUSE
ASSOCIATIONS ARE ALREADY
BEHAVING AS THEY ATTEMPTED TO
NINETY ONE THE LAW AND
HOMEOWNERS ARE REPORTING TO US
THE ABUSES THAT DIDN'T GENERATE.
WE OFFER DO. LEETON EXAMPLES OF
THE KINDS OF ABUSES THAT OCCUR.
WHEN IN PERSON WITNESSING IS
ELIMINATED. A BOARD ELECTION IN
VENTURA COUNTY ASSOCIATION
WHERE MEMBERS SHOULD MEETING
WAS HELD LIKE TRONIC MEDIAN
SPECTER OF ELECTIONS PAID A
BRIEF APPEARANCE THEN THE-
CAMERA SWITCHED AWAY FROM THE
INSPECTOR WHILE THE ACTUAL
OPENING AND COUNTING OF BALLOTS
TOOK PLACE TO COUNTY THE WAY
SHE- AND THEN CAME BACK ONLY TO
ANNOUNCE THE RESULTS. JACKET
ABOARD ALEXION IN LOS ANGELES
WHERE THE BOARD PRESIDENT WAS
HOSTING IT NEEDED ONLY FIVE
MEMBERS THAT REVIEWS THAT THAT
THE OTHER HOMEOWNERS AND THE
CAMERA SHOWED ONLY THE TOP OF
THE INSPECTORS HAD TO THAT
POINT NO ONE COULD SEE WAS
ACTUALLY BEING. DONE AND THE
WORST EXAMPLE HAVE HEARD OF.
THAT OCCURRED LAST MONTH WHEN A
LOS ANGELES CA TO WAKE COUNTY
VOTE. ON THE PHONE WITH NO
VIDEO AT ALL. AND THE DECLARED
RESULT OF THIS SUPPOSED THE
BOOK WAS APPROVAL OF A SPECIAL
ASSESSMENT OF SIXTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER OWNER. WE OFFER THE
THREE EXAMPLES BUT SURMISED
THAT THE PRACTICE. OF SHUTTING
HOMEOWNERS OUT OF NEEDING
JOHNNY DOT WIDESPREAD. AND
DIFFICULT ONLY RIGID MIGHT BE
CUTTING DEMOCRATIC PRACTICE. AN
EARLIER DRAFT TO THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS STATED THAT THIS
STANDARD OPPOSED THREE NINETY
ONE QUOTE BECAUSE IT ISN'T
UNDIMMED ANTI DEMOCRATIC POWER
GRAB DESIGNED TO UTILIZE THE
GUYS OF EMERGENCY TO TRAMPLE
THE RIGHTS OF HOMEOWNERS. IT'S
NOT HERPES. BUT RATHER THESE
ARE THE WORDS WITH COMMITTEE
STAFF AND IN FACT THE- AND NOW
TO HAVE BEEN RE WRITTEN AND
THAT DIDN'T- EXERCISE HOWEVER
GIVEN THE REPORTED WE HEAR. THE
ANALYSIS MAY INDEED BE
ARTICULATING IMPACT OBSERVATION.
SOME PROPONENT THAT SB THREE
NINE ONE KNOWINGLY PROMOTE
MISCONDUCT. ABAI H. AWAY
ELECTION OFFICIALS WERE
SUPPOSED TO BE RUNNING CLEAN
AND FAIR ELECTIONS- WHETHER
THEY'RE ELECTIONS FOR BOARD
DIRECTORS OR SPECIAL
ASSESSMENTS OR ANY OTHER MATTER
IF YOU THEIR QUARTERS THE
COMMITTEE TO VOTE NO. ON AT THE
THREE NINETY ONE THANK YOU. I
DO HAVE DOUGLAS ALEXANDER-
LISTED IN THERE IS INDICATION
HE MAY NOT BE ON THE LINE GIVEN
THE OPPORTUNITY DOUGLAS
ALEXANDER ARE YOU WITH US. AND
DOUGLAS ALEXANDER IF YOU ARE ON
THE LINE PRESS. START AND THEN
ZERO. I DON'T SEE HIM AS BEING
ON THE LINE OKAY WE WILL MOVE
TO OTHER OPPOSITION IN THE
HEARING ROOM OPPOSITION SB.
THREE NINETY ONE. SEEING NONE
OF THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
SEEING NONE RIGHT OPERATOR OPEN
THE LINES FOR ANY OTHER
OPPOSITION TO THE SP THREE
NINETY ONE WE'RE TAKING NAME
AFFILIATION AND OPPOSITION ONLY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU DO
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THE SP. THREE NINETY. AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB THREE NINETY ONE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. MINE. ONE SIXTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN MOMENT PLEASE.
TWENTY ONE THIRTY EIGHT IF YOU
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS GAIL MARTIN IN
SAN DIEGO COUNTY- I AM A SENIOR
CITIZEN LIVING IN A YEAR
SKINNER SAID AND HRA. I'M SORRY
MEMBER OF THAT INJURY THEN AND
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. NINE ONE
SIX FOUR YOUR LINE IS A PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I'M MARGARET SWEENEY
FOR. AIDE TO A MY AND I AM A TO
THIS. MIND YOUR LINE IS PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS SIMON
HOMEOWNER IN HILL- SENECA
COUNTY I'M A CO TO THIS THANK
YOU. MY MOM NINETY YOUR LINE IS
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MY
NAME IS A CASH AND A HOME AND
BOARD MEMBER OF CIVIC BRIDGE
NEIGHBOR ALMOST THOSE. HERE IN.
THEN THE COUNTY. YEAH AND
OPPOSE. THIS THANK YOU. NINE
ONE NINE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MONOCLE
LOOKING IN. A STORM NUMBER AND
I AM ENGAGED I. TO THIS DAY.
THANK YOU. IN MY ONE FIFTY SIX
YOUR LONG IS OPEN GO AHEAD.
HELLO GO AHEAD. THEY WON THANK
YOU I WATCHED. SIXTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS THANK YOU I'M SORRY
WE'RE NOT HAPPY WITH THIS NO
TESTIMONY THIS TIME. NO NOT ON
THAT IS THAT. WE HAVE THAT
THANK YOU. HELLO HELLO. OKAY
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO GO AHEAD
PLEASE. HI MY NAME IS LINDA
BROWN I HAVE OWNED A
CONDOMINIUM A SIXTY UNIT
CONDOMINIUM IN SAN FRANCISCO
ONE NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN FOR
FORTY FIVE YEARS I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS WRITTEN
BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
AND ULTIMATELY ANOTHER LEFT TO
TAKE A PERSONAL TESTIMONY THIS
POINT BUT WE WILL REGISTER YOUR
OPPOSITION. NINE SEVENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN YOU MAY BE ON.
SORRY. YEAH I AM- CONRAD ONE-
MARINA CLUB AND- FORMER BOARD
MEMBER AND I'LL TALK COMPLETE
1% THIS BILL. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. AND WE DID HAVE A FEW
PARTIES THAT WERE NOT ABLE TO.
COMMENT IF YOU WERE IN AN UPSET
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE NINETY
ONE AND DID NOT GET A COMMENT
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. NINE FIFTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU- CHAIRMEN STONE HAND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS GUS PETRA
BOARD. I MEAN EACH AWAY
HOMEOWNERS AND FORMER ELECTED
DIRECTOR AND VOTER IN PLASTER
COUNTY MY AFFILIATION HERE IS-
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF RETIRED AMERICANS AND THE
CENTER FOR CALIFORNIA.
HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATION LAW BOTH
THE CONSUMER PROTECTION
ADVOCATE ORGANIZATIONS AND I'M
CALLING TODAY IN OPPOSITION AND
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE NO ON THIS
BILL THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. I THINK YOU'RE
PRETTY MAY CLOSE THE LINES ON
SB THREE NINETY ONE BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. THE STATE SENATOR
MAN I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THAT
THIS WOULD REALLY JUST BE IF
THERE WAS A STATE OF EMERGENCY
CORRECT SO THE BILL YES SO
FIRST- IT ALLOWS FOR VIDEO
CONFERENCING OR
TELECONFERENCING IF THERE IS A
CLEAR ITS EMERGENCY WITH
RESPECT TO THE ELECTIONS THAT
IS EVEN NARROWER SO WE TOOK
AMENDMENTS WE ARE ALSO
CONCERNED ABOUT POTENTIAL
MISCONDUCT ELECTIONS. AND WE
AMENDED THE BILL TO SAY THAT
VIRTUAL ACTIONS CAN TAKE PLACE
ONLY WHEN CERTAIN CONDITIONS
ARE MET FIRST THE PROCLAIMED-
DISASTER EMERGENCY MAKES IT
UNSAFE OR IMPOSSIBLE FOR PEOPLE
TO GATHER IN PERSON THAT IS A
NARROWER SUBSET FURTHERMORE THE
MEETINGS AT WHICH BALLOTS ARE
RECOUNTED IN TABULATING
TABULATED MUST BE DONE BY VERY
VIDEO CONFERENCE AND A CAMERA
MUST BE PLACED IN A LOCATION
SUCH THAT MEMBERS CAN WITNESS
THE INSPECTOR OF ELECTIONS
COUNTING IN TABULATING EACH
VOTE. I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT I
WOULD DISAGREE WITH THE
TESTIMONY FROM THE OPPOSITION
WITNESS THAT WHAT HAPPENED IN
THESE ELECTIONS DID NOT TAKE
PLACE BECAUSE OF OUR BILL IT
TOOK PLACE BEFORE WE EVEN TALK
ABOUT THIS BILL BEFORE THIS
BILL WAS PROPOSED ALL OF THIS
WAS TAKING PLACE BECAUSE HOAS
ANOTHER C. ID'S DID NOT HAVE
ANY PROCEDURES TO ME THEY CHOSE
TO MEET VIRTUALLY AND ALL OF
THE PURPORTED ELECTION
MISCONDUCT TOOK PLACE IN THAT
ENVIRONMENT OF A WILD WEST WITH
NO PROCEDURES. ARE BILL WOULD
CREATE PROCEDURES TO- TO LOOK
AT THESE VOTES TO TABULATE THE
VOTES AND HAVE THEM VISUALLY
INSPECTED IF THESE PROCEDURES
WERE NOT FOLLOWED IT GIVES THE
RESIDENTS OF ANY C. AIDID
RECOURSE THE SAME LAWS AND
PROCEDURES THAT EXIST FOR ANY
VIOLATION OF H. SHOW A
PROCEDURE SO WE PROVIDE SOME
PROCEDURES AND RECORDS THAT
DON'T EXIST RIGHT NOW AND THE
CONDUCT IT WAS DESCRIBED BY THE
OPPOSITION WITNESS WOULD NOT BE
ALLOWED TO BE A LEGAL UNDER
BILL. GREAT I CAN TLL YOU THAT
I SERVED ON MY BOARD FOR TEN
YEARS AND WAS PRESIDENT- DURING
CALVET AND IT WAS- THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE TO
ACTUALLY ATTEND THESE MEETINGS
BECAUSE A LOT OF THEM ARE OLDER
OR THEIR WORK SCHEDULE WASN'T
WORKING BUT THAT SO I THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND I
WOULD BE- UNDER TO BE A CO
AUTHOR. THANK YOU SO MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND WILL LOOK
TO ADD YOU TO PROBE TIME COMMENTS.
SENATOR YOU MAY CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND THAT MOTION IS TO
PASS AND I WILL NOTE THAT THIS
IS AN EMERGENCY BILL CALDWELL
PLEASE STONE HI STONE AYE
GALLAGHER. CHAU. TO DAVIES
FIFTY SECOND SALAS GONZALEZ I
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE KALRA. KALRA
AYE KILEY MAIENSCHEIN REYES
RESIDE. THE BILL IS OUT OF
NUMBER TEN SB SIX FIFTY FOUR.
ALL RIGHT YEAH. THANK YOU SO
MUCH I'M SORRY AND I PRESENTING
SIX IF YOU WANNA GO HEAD THANK
YOU SO MUCH AGAIN CHAIR STONE
THANK YOU TO COMMITTEE STAFF
AGAIN SB SIX FIFTY FOUR CREATES
NEW PROTECTIONS AND EXAMS
EXTENDS EXISTING SAFEGUARDS FOR
CHILDREN IN FAMILY COURT
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL DOES TWO
THINGS THAT I THINK ARE LONG
OVERDUE FIRST SB SIX FIFTY FOUR
PREVENTS A CHILD'S TESTIMONY-
FROM BEING GIVEN IN THE
PRESENCE OF THE PARTY SEEKING
CUSTODY SUCH AS A CHILD'S
PARENTS UNLESS IT IS SEEN AS
NECESSARY. THAT WOULD REVERSE
THE ORDER OF THE PRIORITIZATION
RIGHT NOW WITH THE DEFAULT IS
OFTEN- THE IDEA THAT THE CHILD
WILL GIVE TESTIMONY IN FRONT OF
PARENTS SOMETHING THEY CAN BE
VERY TRAUMATIZING- SECOND- AND
I THINK IT IS. YOU KNOW CLEARLY
USEFUL AND NECESSARY FOR
CHILDREN TO TESTIFY. SOMETIMES
IT IS NECESSARY TO FOR THOSE
THESE CHILDREN TO TESTIFY IN
FRONT OF THEIR PARENTS. BUT
ATTORNEYS AND CHILD ADVOCATES
HAVE REPORTED ACROSS THE BOARD
THAT. I'M GENERALLY SPEAKING
TESTIFYING IN FRONT OF ONE'S
PARENTS AT THIS AGE IN IN THESE
CONTENTIOUS. CUSTODY BATTLES
CAN CAUSE LONG TERM EMOTIONAL
DISTRESS AND HARM. CHILDREN
HAVE A RIGHT TO BE HEARD BUT WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS SHOULD BE
DONE IN SAFE ENVIRONMENTS AND
SO AS SUCH THE FIRST COMPONENT
THIS BILL ENSURES THAT
CHILDREN. ARE ONLY PLACED IN A
SITUATION WHERE THEY'RE FORCED
TO TESTIFY FROM THEIR PARENTS
WHEN IT'S DEEMED NECESSARY. AND
ALSO CLARIFIES THAT CHILDREN
HAVE A RIGHT TO CHANGE THEIR
MIND ABOUT HOW THEY WISH TO
PROVIDE INPUT. SECONDLY SB SIX
FIFTY FOUR TAKES EXISTING
SAFETY MEASURES. USED RELATED
TO CHILD CUSTODY DETERMINATION.
AND EXTENDS THEM TO
UNSUPERVISED VISITATION.
CURRENTLY JUDGES MUST CONSIDER
A HISTORY OF ABUSE OR DRUG
ADDICTION WHEN PLACING CHILDREN
IN THE CUSTODY OF. INDIVIDUALS
WITH THESE BACKGROUNDS. AND IF
A JUDGE PLACES A CHILD IN THE
CUSTODY OF INDIVIDUALS WITH AN
ABUSIVE. BACKGROUND THEY MUST
STATE THEIR REASONS ON THE
RECORD- THIS STATUS QUO INSURES
THAT DOCUMENTATION OF THESE
DETERMINATIONS ARE CAPPED. A
DECISION IS MADE IN THIS HELPS
TO SAVE LIVES. BUT THE SAME
REQUIREMENT DOES NOT APPLY TO
UNSUPERVISED VISITATIONS WHICH
CAN BE EQUALLY PROBLEMATIC AND
EVEN DEADLY. A TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN STUDY BY THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE OF JUSTICE. FOUND
THAT 47% OF CUSTODY EVALUATORS
CONTINUE TO RECOMMEND. AND
SUPERVISED VISITATION WITH THE
PARENTS. EVEN WHEN THERE ARE
REPORTS OF VIOLENCE IN AT HOME.
UNSUPERVISED VISITATIONS CAN
LAST DAYS AND OFTEN PUT
CHILDREN IN DANGER. A TWELVE
YEAR NATIONAL STUDY SHOWS THAT
MANY CHILD HOMICIDE VICTIMS.
WERE MURDERED BY DIVORCING OR
SEPARATED PARENTS. DURING COURT
ORDERED UNSUPERVISED VISITATION
WITH THE MURDER. DESPITE THE
FACT THAT THE COURTS WERE
NOTIFIED AWARE OF A HISTORY OF
ABUSE. AND EVIDENCE OF THREATS
TO HARM THE CHILDREN. SB SIX
FIFTY FOUR EXTENDS THE SAME
SAFETY REQUIREMENTS CURRENTLY
APPLY TO CHILD CUSTODY TO
UNSUPERVISED VISITATION. IT'S
CONSISTENT WITH EXISTING
PRACTICES. AND WHAT MAY SEEM
LIKE A MINOR CHANGE THIS IS A
CHANGE WE BELIEVE WILL SAVE THE
LIVES OF MANY CHILDREN. TODAY I
HAVE WITH ME DOES TESTIFYING
SUPPORT KIM ROBINSON A FAMILY
LAW ATTORNEY. AND TRACY FELL
OVER THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR.
FOR YOLO COUNTY C. A. S. A.
THANK YOU WE DO A MOTION AND A
SECOND SO I HAVE TWO WITNESSES
LISTED KEN ROBINSON AND TRACY
FARMER. JIM ROBINSON PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES THANK YOU BUT AS THE
SENATORS STATED- I IN FAMILY
LAW ATTORNEY WITH OVER THIRTY
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE- MANY OF MY
CASES ARE HIGH CONFLICT BECAUSE
THEY ARE INVOLVED. ISSUES OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND CHILD
ABUSE- THIS BILL DOES TOO- TWO
IMPORTANT THINGS ONE IS THAT IT
REQUIRES ANY COURT THAT'S GOING
TO ALLOW. UNSUPERVISED
VISITATION BETWEEN A CHILD AND
A PARENT WITH A HISTORY OF
VIOLENCE OR ABUSE THAT THAT THE
COURT MUST ISSUE WRITTEN
FINDINGS AS TO HOW SUCH AN
ARRANGEMENT SUCH VISITATION
WOULD BE IN THAT CHILD'S BEST
INTEREST. AND THAT IT WOULD NOT
JEOPARDIZE THE CHILD'S SAFETY
EXISTING LAW DOES NOT PUT THAT
REQUIREMENT UPON THE COURT-
SECONDLY THIS BILL- AMEND
FAMILY CODE SECTION THREE ZERO
FOUR TWO WHICH IS A STATUTE
THAT ALLOWS CHILDREN TO GIVE
TESTIMONY TO THE COURT
REGARDING. THEIR CUSTOM ORDEAL
PREFERENCES MOST CHILDREN IN
MOST CUSTODY CASES DO NOT WISH
TO TESTIFY THEY DON'T WANT TO
BE INVOLVED BUT IN THOSE FEW
CASES WHERE THEY DO THIS BILL
REQUIRES THAT THE COURTS TO.
ESSENTIALLY SET UP ACE FOR
CHILD FRIENDLY SETTING IN WHICH
THE CHILDREN CAN SPEAK OPENLY
AND HONESTLY ABOUT THEIR
CUSTOMER DEAL- PREFERENCES AND
THE CIRCUMSTANCES- GOING ON IN
THEIR LIFE THAT THE COURT MAY.
TAKE INPUT. AND MAKE BETTER
ORDERS. THANK YOU AND I'M
AVAILABLE ANY. THANK YOU WOULD
YOU IDENTIFY YOURSELF FOR A
RECORD PLEASE. I YES I DIDN'T
KIM RBINSON I AM A FAMILY LAW
ATTORNEY IN OAKLAND YES THANK
YOU. AND THEN TRACY FARMER. YES
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN STONE AND
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS TRACY FATHER I AM A
LICENSED CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER
AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF YOLO
COUNTY CASA. AN ORGANIZATION
THAT ADVOCATES FOR THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE VIEWS THAT THEY
COLLECTED CHILDREN. TODAY WE
UNDERSTAND THE HEALTHY
DEVELOPMENT OF THE BRAINS AND
BODIES OF CHILDREN BETTER THAN
EVER BEFORE WE NOW KNOW THAT
TRAUMATIC STRESS IN EARLY
CHILDHOOD. AS A RESULT OF
ADVERSE CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES
OR ACES. HAS A PROFOUNDLY
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON HEALTH AND
WELLBEING IN CHILDHOOD. AND
THROUGHOUT THE LIFE LIFE COURSE.
A GROUNDBREAKING ACES STUDY
PUBLISHED IN NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT BY DOCTORS SINCE IT'S
ALREADY OF KAISER PERMANENTE A
AND ROBERT ON THE OF THE CDC.
AND SUBSEQUENT RESEARCH AROUND
TRAUMATIC STRESS IN CHILDREN
HAS DRAMATICALLY HIGHLIGHTED
THE IMPORTANCE OF REDUCING THE
EXPOSURE AND DOSE OF TRAUMATIC
STRESS CHILDREN EXPERIENCE. SB
SIX FIFTY FOUR WILL ENSURE THE
COURTS TAKE THIS KNOWLEDGE OF
THE NEGATIVE IMPACT OF
TRAUMATIC STRESS OF CHILDREN
INTO ACCOUNT WHEN TAKING THEIR
TESTIMONY IN FAMILY COURT.
ORDERED WHEN MAKING DECISIONS
ABOUT UNSUPERVISED VISITATION
IN CASES WHERE EVIDENCE OF
ABUSE BECAUSE THIS. ENSURING
THAT CHILDREN ARE NOT JUST
PHYSICALLY BUT ALSO EMOTIONALLY
SAFE DURING COURT PROCEEDINGS
AND THE SEPARATION OF THEIR
PARENTS IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
TO THEIR IMMEDIATE AND LONG
TERM WELL BEING. CASA
VOLUNTEERS WHO ACCOMPANY
CHILDREN TO COURT HAVE A UNIQUE
PERSPECTIVE ON THE TOXIC STRESS
THAT CHILDREN EXPERIENCE WHEN
APPEARING IN COURT EVEN WHEN
SPEAKING UP FOR THEIR NEEDS. IF
IT MAY BE PERCEIVED AS AGAINST
THE WISHES OR DESIRES SOME
PARENTS. YES CHILDREN ARE
FREQUENTLY VERY WILLING TO BE
OPEN AND HONEST ABOUT HOW THEY
FEEL WHEN THEY FEEL SAFE. IT IS
TIME FOR THE ADULTS IN THE ROOM
TO CREATE THE RIGHT CONDITIONS
FOR THE CHILD RATHER THAN
EXPECTING THE CHILD TO ADAPT TO
THE CONDITIONS SET BY THE
ADULTS IN THE ROOM. LET US
ENSURE THAT CHILDREN ARE
PROTECTED PROTECTED FROM ABUSE
NEGLECT AND CONTINUED PAKCIK
STRESS WHENEVER WE ARE ABLE TO
DO SO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
RIGHT THANK YOU. WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO OTHERS IN SUPPORT IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX FIFTY FOUR.
SEEING NONE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION. SEEING NONE OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR
THOSE WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB. SIX FIFTY FOUR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
SB SIX FIFTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
FIFTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE.
AND THEN ZERO. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. NINE SEVENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU THIS IS ALICE KESSLER
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIPS AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN SUPPORT OF
SB SIX FIFTY FOUR THANK YOU.
NINE NINETY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
CAPTURING CAMPBELL WITH
CALIFORNIA PROTECTIVE PARENTS
ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE IN FULL
SUPPORT OF SB. SIX FIFTY FOUR.
NINE ONE SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
IMMEDIACY WERE WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE TWO
HUNDRED AND FOUR OR TWO OH FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. TWENTY VALENTINE
REPRESENTING ADVOCATES FOR
CHILD EMPOWERMENT AND SAFETY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SIX FIFTY
FOUR THANK YOU. NINE FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH MICHELLE VIRGINIA
REPRESENTING. MOTHERS OF LOST
CHILDREN IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU. NINE TWO
OH NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
ANDREA RANSDELL ON BEHALF OF
THE INCENTIVIZE OUR SPEAKERS
BUREAU CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SIX FIVE FOUR. MY
NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MELISSA KNIGHT
SIGN WITH LEGISLATIVE COALITION
TO PREVENT CHILD ABUSE BILL
SPONSOR I ASKED DR VOTE. AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO OPPOSITION
I DO NOT HAVE ANY OPPOSITION.
WITNESSES LISTED IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SIX FIFTY FOUR.
SEEING NONE AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR OPEN THE LINES FOR
OPPOSITION TO SB. SIX FIFTY
FOUR. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB SIX FIFTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. SB SIX FIFTY
FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. WE HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU. I THANK YOU- BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SEEING NONE CENTER
YOU MAY CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR ABOUT THANK YOU WE DO
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND THAT
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CULTURAL PLEASE
STONE HI STONE HI GALLAGHER.
CHAU TO. DAVID DAVIES HI
GONZALEZ. HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE
KALRA KALRA KILEY MAIENSCHEIN
REYES FIVE REYES I. GONZALEZ ON
SB SIX FIFTY FOUR HI GONZALEZ I.
THE BILL WITHOUT THANK YOU WHEN
I GO TO ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SB
FIVE SEVENTY TWO CENTER
HERTZBERG. AND SENATOR I MUST
APOLOGIZE I DO UNDERSTAND YOU
WERE IN THE ROOM WHEN I CALLED
UP CENTER MID I DID NOT NOTICE
SO THAT WAS MY MISTAKE. THAT'S
NO PROBLEM THEY DON'T NEED TO
CHANGE I THINK YOU AND WATER
LIKETHAT I KNOW THAT KNOWING
HIS BUSY SCHEDULE BUT PLEASURE
MYSELF MANY TIMES NO NO PROBLEM
AT ALL THANK YOU. VERY BRIEFLY
ON. THE LABOR COMMISSIONER.
WHEN TEY- ONE VIOLATES IN
ORDER OR- GAUGES IN A WAGE
VIOLATIONS HAS A PROCESS
WHEREBY THEY- GO THROUGH
HEARINGS AND THEN THEY- GET A
LIEN AGAINST SOMEONE'S PROPERTY
IF THEY HAVE A LIEN. THE
PROBLEM IS THAT THE CURRENT
LAWS VERY. OLD FASHIONED
DOESN'T WORK VERY WELL WE HAVE
TO GET AN ABSTRACT OF JUDGMENT.
AND SO IN ORDER TO MAKE THE LAW
WORK MORE EFFICIENTLY TO GO
AFTER. FOLKS WHO OFTEN WILL
SELL A PIECE OF PROPERTY OR
OTHERWISE ENCUMBERED AS WERE
DELAYED IN THE PROCESS. THIS
ALLOWS A DIRECT APPLICATION BY
THE- COMMISSIONER TO GO WITH TO
GET LEAN AGAINST IT. EMPLOYER
WHO HAS AN ORDER AGAINST THEM.
AND WITH THAT AS MY WITNESS I
LOST I HOPEFULLY HE WILL I BY
THE WAY IS AMENDMENTS EXCEPT
THE AMENDMENTS. AT THE
COMMITTEE WANTED THERE WAS SOME
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS- I DON'T
KNOW IF RABIOT ALWAYS IS ON THE
LINE OR NOT HE WAS HERE BUT HAD
TO GO TO. TICKETS PICK UP HIS
CHILDREN FROM SCHOOL AND ALSO
IS TECHNICAL. CATHERINE LEóN
FROM. THE LABOR COMMISSIONER'S
OFFICE FOR TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
THE YOU I DO HAVE RENEE BAYARDO
WHO DIDN'T THAT I WANT TO CALL
AND SO HOPEFULLY HE'S THERE.
AND THEN. LEóN WHO IS ON
STANDBY FOR TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
FOR NAY BAYARDO DID YOU WERE
YOU ABLE TO CALL IT. NABIRE
DOES NOT ON THE LINE HOWEVER WE
DO HAVE CATHERINE LEAH. OKAY
DEFINITELY ON WOULD YOU LIKE TO
MAKE STATEMENT OR YOU YOU'RE
HERE FOR QUESTIONS. I THANK YOU
THIS IS CATHERINE LEON I'M AN
ATTORNEY WITH THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER OFFICE- I AM IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND I AM
HERE FOR ANY QUESTIONS I WILL
BE THERE BUT EVERY TIME UNTIL
THE END IF PEOPLE HAVE
QUESTIONS. OKAY NO WORRIES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH RIGHT WILL
MOVE TO OTHERS IN SUPPORT
ANYONE HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM.
SB SIX FIVE SEVEN TWO. C. NOT
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATIONS.
SEEING NONE SIR ANYONE ELSE
WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT
FOR SB FIVE SEVENTY TWO ON THE
PHONES OPERATOR OPEN LINES
PLEASE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE SEVENTY TWO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
SEVENTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE.
AND THEN ZERO. NINE ONE NINETY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MISTER JOHN MEMBERS
ONE OF TO SAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE SEVENTY TWO.
NINE ONE FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIRMAN BIRTH MERRY GO YOUR
SHE HARD WITH THE CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS EACH AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. RIGHT THANK YOU WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO OPPOSITION I
HAVE NO OPPOSITION LISTED IS
THERE ANYONE HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE SP
FIVE SEVEN TWO. SEEING NONE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION THERE
ARE NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO. SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE SEVENTY
TWO. YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB FIVE SEVENTY TWO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE
SEVENTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN. ZERO WE HAVE NO
COMMENT IN Q. THANK YOU I WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
THANK YOU IF YOU HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND. SENATOR YOU MAY
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK ROBERT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER BUSH
WE DO HAVE A MOTION IT IS. TO
PASS BECAUSE I BELIEVE THE
AMENDMENTS WERE TAKEN EARLIER
THEY WERE CLOSE IT IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS KALRA PLEASE
STONE AYE STONE AYE GALLAGHER
CHAU CHIU. DAVIES DAVIES I
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ HI HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I KALRA KALRA AYE KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN REYES RESIDE
BECAUSE OF THE BILLS OUT THANK
YOU RIGHT I REMEMBER ELEVEN SB
SIX SIX ZERO CENTER NEWMAN.
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS-
I'M HERE BEFORE TODAY TO
ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF SB SIX
SIXTY. IT'S PROVISIONS WILL
PROHIBIT COMMON PRACTICES IN
THE GATHERING OF SIGNATURES FOR
BALLOT MEASURES WHICH
INCENTIVIZE THE WILLFUL
DECEPTION VOTERS IN DOING SO SB
SIX SIXTY WILL TAKE NECESSARY
AND IMPORTANT STEP TOWARD
SAFEGUARDING THE INTEGRITY OF
CALIFORNIANS. INITIATIVE
REFERENDUM AND RECALL PROCESSES
AS THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS NOTES
A RECENT ACCEPTED AMENDMENTS TO
STRENGTHEN THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S ROLE IN PROSECUTING
PROSPECTIVE VIOLATION UNDER THE
BILL'S PROVISIONS WHEN ENACTED-
AND OUT OF THE BILL IN CHIEF.
AS YOU MAY BE AWARENESS TO
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS NOTES
CALIFORNIA'S ONE OF A NUMBER OF
STATES WHOSE CONSTITUTIONS
EXPRESSLY PROVIDED CITIZENS
WITH TOOLS TO DIRECTLY REDRESS
ABUSES OF GOVERNMENT OR
MALFEASANCE BY PUBLIC OFFICIALS
IN OUR CASE IN THE FORM OF THE
INITIATIVE. THE REFERENDUM AND
THE RECALL FIRST SOME
HISTORICAL BACKGROUND AND
CONTEXT THESE ADMIRABLE AND
USEFUL CONSTITUTION DIRECT
DEMOCRACY PROVISIONS DATE BACK
MORE THAN A CENTURY AND ARE THE
LEGACY OF A GROUP OF
PROGRESSIVE REFORMERS LED BY
THEN GOVERNOR HIRAM JOHNSON.
WHO THEN WENT ON TO BECOME
CALIFORNIA'S LONGEST SERVING
REPRESENTATIVE UNITED STATES
SENATE UNTIL HIS TWENTY EIGHT
YEARS IN OFFICE RECENTLY
ECLIPSED BY OUR OWN STANDARD
DI<c.cyan> FEINSTEIN. AS A RESULT</c>
OF THE EFFORTS OF GOVERNOR
JOHNSON AND HIS SUPPORTERS
CALIFORNIA'S CONSTITUTION
THROUGH THE INITIAL REFERENDUM
AND RECALL MAKES EXPLICIT
PROVISIONS THAT ALLOW FOR THE
CITY'S REACH SURGERY TO TAKE
ACTIONS OUTSIDE OF THE NORMAL
ELECTION. AND LEGISLATIVE
PROCESSES IN ORDER TO ENACT OR
REPEAL LEGISLATION OR TO REMOVE
A CORRUPT OR MALFEASANCE
ELECTED OFFICIAL FROM OFFICE-
I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT RIGHT
NOW- THAT THIS BILL WILL HAVE
NO IMPACT WHATSOEVER ON THE
CURRENT EFFORT. TO RECALL
GOVERNOR NEWSOM- IF ENACTED IT
WILL BE WELL AFTER THAT ALL
TAKES PLACE. TO THE ORIGINAL
FRAMERS WAY OF THINKING THE
INITIAL REFERENDUM AND RECALL
REPRESENTED A MEANS FOR THE
LITTLE GUY TO ACHIEVE DIRECT
CURATIVE AND REFORMIST ACTIONS
THAT ELECTED INVESTED INTEREST
MIGHT OTHERWISE FORT BECAUSE
THE FRAMERS OF THE INITIATIVE
REFERENDUM AND RECALL REGARD.
THESE PROCESSES AS POP LIST. OF
LESS RESORT THE- PROVIDE THAT
ORDER TO. FOR THE BALLOT THE
PROPONENTS OF ANY OF THESE
DIRECT TO THE VOTERS PLEASE
BESIDES. WOULD FIRST BE
REQUIRED TO GATHER A SUFFICIENT
NUMBER OF VOTER SIGNATURES TO
VALIDATE THE LEGITIMACY AND
POPULAR SUPPORT FOR SUCH AN
ACTION. OVER THE YEARS
ESPECIALLY IN IN RECENT DECADES
HOWEVER SOMETHING VERY
DIFFERENT THAN THE FRAMERS
INTENDED HAS TRANSPIRED. THESE
TOOLS OF DIRECT DEMOCRACY HAVE
IN FACT BEEN EFFECTIVELY CO
OPTED BY THE VERY MONEYED
INTERESTS THEY WERE ORIGINALLY
INTENDED. TO OFFSET. AS WELL
FUNDED GROUPS WITH INCREASINGLY
EXPLICIT SELF INTERESTED
MOTIVATIONS HAVE BECOME EVER
MORE ADEPT AT USING INITIATIVE
REFERENDUM AND RECALL PROCESS
IS TO THEIR BENEFIT. SOMETHING
OF AN ARMS RACE AROUND THESE
PROCESSES HAS ENSUED ESPECIALLY
AS IT PERTAINS TO SIGNATURE
GATHERING. AT THE CENTER OF
THESE EFFORTS A SMALL NUMBER OF
SPECIALIZED FIRMS WITH
EXPERTISE IN SEIZURE GATHERING.
HAVE RISEN TO THE FORE OFFERING
THEIR SERVICES TO PROPONENTS
SEEKING TO PLACE A MEASURE ON
THE BALLOT. ONE OF THE
PRINCIPAL TACTICS USED BY THE
SPECIALIZING TOGETHER INFERENCE
IS THE DEPLOYMENT OF WELL
TRAINED PROFESSIONAL SIGNATURE
GATHERERS TYPICALLY IS USED THE
SIGNATURE GATHERS. ARE PAID ON
A PER SIGNATURE OR COMMISSION
BASIS ALSO KNOWN AS A BOUNTY.
AT A RATE DETERMINED BY THE
MARKET AS IT IS ASSESSED AT THE
TIME. DEPENDING ON THE NATURE
OF THE ISSUE OF THE
CHARACTERISTICS OF THE
DISTRICT. THE TIME OF YEAR OR
COMPETITION WITH OTHER NATIONS
AT A GIVEN TIME TO COST
PROCEDURE CAN VARY WIDELY FROM
AS LOW AS TWO DOLLARS PER
STRING TOGETHER TO AS HIGH AS
TWENTY DOLLARS. AND BECAUSE
BOUNTY PAID SIGNATURE GATHERS
ARE INCENTIVIZED TO OPTIMIZE
THEIR YIELD BASED ON OW
RAPIDLY THEY CAN SECURE
SIGNATURES FROM VOTERS. THEY
FRANKLY TRAFFIC MISDIRECTION
MISLEADING INFORMATION AND
OUTRIGHT FALSEHOODS IN ORDER TO
INDUCE AS MANY VOTERS AS
POSSIBLE TO SIGN IN THE MINIMUM
AMOUNT OF TIME. AGAINST THIS
BACKDROP THE DETERMINING FACTOR
GETTING A MEASURE ON THE BALLOT
TOO OFTEN HAS LESS TO DO WITH
ITS POLICY MERITS. THEN WITH
THE DEPTH OF HIS PROPONENTS
POCKETS OF COURSE THIS IS
EXACTLY THE OPPOSITE OF WHAT
THE FRAMERS HAD IN MIND. AS A
DIRECT RESULT OF THESE PERVERSE
INCENTIVES THE PAPER SIGNATURE
SYSTEM HAS SUBVERTED THE
ORIGINAL IDEALISTIC CONTENT. OF
CALIFORNIA'S FOUNDERS WHO
ENVISIONED A PEOPLE POWER IT'S
JUST OF REF. AND VALIDATED BY
DEMONSTRATED PUBLIC SUPPORT AND
WHICH WOULD SUCCEED OR FAIL ON
THEIR MERITS NOT ON HOW WILL
THE SYSTEM. MIGHT BE GAME. THE
INITIATIVE REFERENDUM AND
RECALL PROCESS HE SHOULD AND-
CAN AND SHOULD PLAY AN
IMPORTANT VALUED ROLE IN
CALIFORNIA POLITICS AND
GOVERNMENT. IT HAS BECOME CLEAR
HOWEVER THAT UNDER THE CURRENT
SYSTEM DRIVEN BY PROCEDURE
BOUNTIES THERE ARE SCANT
PROSPECTS. FOR DETERRING BAD
ACTORS WHO WILLFULLY MISLEAD
VOTERS AT THE EXPENSE. OF THE
INTEGRITY OF THE ELECTORAL
PROCESS SB SIX SIXTY ADDRESSES
THIS ISSUE. BY PROHIBITING THE
PRACTICE OF PAYING SIX
TOGETHERS ON A PERSONAL BASIS
WHEN COLLECTING SIGNATURES TO
PLACE A STATE. OR LOCAL
INITIATIVE REFERENDUM A RECALL
ON THE BALLOT. AS THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS CORRECTLY NOTES THIS
MEASURE WOULD NOT PROHIBIT IS
PAYMENT FOR SIGNATURE
GATHERING. IN OTHER WAYS
TOGETHER STILL COULD BE PAID AN
HOURLY WAGE RATE SALARY OR
OFFER BONUSES BASED ON THEIR
PERFORMANCE. THIS GOOD
GOVERNMENT MEASUREMENT WILL
SERVE. TO STRENGTHEN A RECALL
REFERENDUM ISSUE PROCESS BY
ENSURING THAT VOTERS ARE AWARE
OF EXACTLY WHAT THEY'RE SIGNING
AND NOT BEING DECEIVED I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR OUTLOOK
TODAY. THANK YOU I DO NOT HAVE
ANY SUPPORT WITNESSES LISTED SO
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. OF SB. SIX SIXTY.
SEEING NONE REMOTE TESTIMONY
SITE. SEEING NONE OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR
SUPPORT FOR SB. SIX SIXTY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
SB SIX SIXTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
SIXTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AND
THEN ZERO. NINE ONE NINETY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
NUMBERS MAKING PAPERS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS PLEASED TO BE IN
SUPPORT. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
OPPOSITION I HAVE ONE WITNESS
LISTED SURE MUHAMMAD FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
WHO'S HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM.
GO AHEAD PLEASE THANK YOU
AUDIBLE YOUR MEMBERS- MINUS
WHAT MUHAMMAD WITH CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE SB SIX
SIXTY SB SIX SIXTY PROHIBITS
SIGNATURE COLLECTION ON A PER
SIGNATURE BASIS FOR STATE OR
LOCAL INITIATIVES- BUT BY
BANNING SIGNATURE GATHERING ON
PAYPOINT PER SIGNATURE BASIS
THIS BILL DOES COMPEL PEOPLE TO
BEAR THE COST OF HIRING HOURLY
EMPLOYEES OR CONTRACTORS WITH
HOURLY EMPLOYEES TO COLLECT
THOSE SIGNATURES. AND
DISINCENTIVE EYES OF THOSE
WORKERS IN COLLECTING
SIGNATURES BY DOING THIS THE
BILL NOT ONLY SLOWS DOWN THE
SIGNATURE GATHERING PROCESS BUT
DOES MAKE IT PROHIBITIVELY
EXPENSIVE TO CIRCULATE IN
ADDITION IF RECALL FOR NEXT TO
IMPOSSIBLE TO PROPOSE A
REFERENDUM. SB SIX SIXTY ALSOMIXES CALIFORNIA BALLOT PROP
MEASURES WITH THE RISK OF
PRIVILEGE WITH PRIVILEGE
LITIGATION BY CREATING A
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION TO
ENFORCE ITS PROVISIONS THIS
WOULD HAVE A CHILLING EFFECT ON
CALIFORNIA'S BALLOT PROCESS
FINALLY THE BILL ONCE FOR
DEMONSTRABLE PROOF OF FRAUD
STEMMING FROM SPECIFICALLY FROM
THE PAYMENT PER SIGNATURE
METHOD OF COLLECTION
INFORMATION FROM THE SECRETARY
OF STATE INDICATES THAT. IN THE
LAST TWENTY SEVEN YEARS ONLY
FIFTY FIVE CASES FOR POTENTIAL
PETITION FRAUD WERE REFERRED
FOR PROSECUTION- CONSIDERING
THESE ISSUES- WE MUST-
RESPECTFULLY. OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US TODAY.
THEY YOU. THIRTY ONE ELSE LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB
SIX SIXTY IN THE HEARING ROOM.
EEING THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
SITE. SEEING NONE OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR
OPPOSITION FOR SB SIX SIXTY AND
WE WILL TAKE NAME AFFILIATION
AND OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION SB SIX SIXTEEN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB SIX SIXTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE.
AND THEN. ZERO NINE TO FIFTEEN.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD- THANK YOU SO MUCH WITH
THIS AND MY OTHER FRIENDS AND
FAMILY JUST- GAVE ME A TEXT
MESSAGE AND THEY SAID. A RIGHT
NOW AT THIS MOMENT- THE PEOPLE
THAT. ARE IN CHARGE OF OUR
LEGISLATURE OR WHATEVER THE
COUNTY OR CITY AT THIS IS A
STATE. STATE THING THAT THEY
WANT TO RESOLVE AND- OUR
PROPERTY IN CALIFORNIA. SO IF
YOU MA'AM MA'AM YEAH. THAT IS
NOT THE SUBJECT OF. THIS BILL
AT THIS POINT. THIS IS IT IS
NOT THAT THEN WHAT. WELL WHAT
IT WHAT IT IS FOR THIS IS FOR
SENATE BILL SIX SIXTY. AT THE
END WHAT IT THAT TRANSLATES I
AM OUT OF YOUR LIFE AND- ALL
RIGHT I'M SORRY I THINK YOU
HAVE THE WRONG. HEARING RON
COMMITTEE- WELL I'M SURE I DO
BUT BUT- WELL WELL THANK YOU
FOR TELLING ME THAT ALL I
WANTED TO SEE IF- YOU KNOW
WHOEVER YOU ARE. NO LONGER
TAKING TESTIMONY ON THIS BILL
JUST YAKKING ISING SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION FOR IT HI I AM
SORRY. OPERATOR COULD YOU GO TO
THE NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. NINE ONE
NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
LESLIE VASQUEZ WITH THE LEAGUE
OF WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU ARE PRETTY MAKE CLOSE
ALLIANCE FOR SB SIX SIXTY. NO
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SEE
NONE SENATOR MY CLOTHES AND I
APPRECIATE THE LIVELY
TESTIMONY. AT A PARTICULAR
AROUND THE ISSUE OF ZONING
THAT'S MISTER CHAIR- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU I'M LOOKING FOR A MOTION IT
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED. THANK
YOU. TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE. STONE I DON'T I
GALLAGHER. CHAU CHIU. AB AND
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN HOLDEN I.
CALLER I KILEY. KILEY NO
MAIENSCHEIN REYES. THAT NEEDS
TO MORE ARE WITH BILL THANK YOU
MEMBERS THANK YOU OUR ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE SB THREE ONE FIVE
SENATOR ROUGH. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- AS YOU KNOW
FOR MANY OF CALIFORNIA'S
HOMEOWNERS REAL PROPERTY IS THE
ONLY ASSET THAT. THEY CAN PASS
TO THEIR ERRORS ONE WAY TO
CONVEY PROPERTY TO AN ERROR
ISRAEL WILL OR TRUST BOTH OF
WHICH- FREQUENTLY REQUIRE
PROBATE OR ESTATE PLANNING
ATTORNEY CONSULTATION AND
SOMETIMES THAT CAN BE COST
PROHIBITIVE. ONE OF THE OTHER
WAYS PARTICULARLY FOR THOSE
WITHOUT RESOURCES. IS THE
SUBJECT OF THIS BILL THE
REVOCABLE TRANSFER ON DEATH
DEED. IRREVOCABLE TRANSFER ON
DEATH DEED PROVIDES A MUCH MORE
ACCESSIBLE AND AFFORDABLE
MECHANISM OTHER THAN PROBATE.
IT'S JUST ANOTHER TOOL FOR
THOSE WITH LIMITED ASSETS
UNCOMPLICATED HOLDINGS. AND
SIMPLY A HOME. THE REVOCABLE
TRANSFER ON DEATH DEED WAS
CREATED BY THIS LEGISLATURE IN
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AB ONE
THIRTY NINE. TO ALLOW OWNERS OF
REAL PROPERTY TO TRANSFER THEIR
PROPERTY UPON DEATH OUTSIDE OF
THE NORMAL PROBATE PROCEDURE.
THIS PILOT PROGRAM PROGRAM HAS
A CURRENT SUNSET DATE AS YOU
KNOW OF JANUARY. TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY TWO. THIS BILL SENATE
BILL THREE ONE FIVE IS
SPECIFICALLY BASED ON THE
RECOMMENDATIONS. CONTAINED IN A
REPORT COMPLETED BY THE
CALIFORNIA LAW REVISION
COMMISSION. AND IF ADOPTED WILL
EXTEND THE SUNSET DATE UNTIL
JANUARY. ONE TWO THOUSAND
THIRTY TWO. ALLOW THE USE OF A
REVOCABLE TRANSFER ON DEATH
DEED TO TRANSFER REAL PROPERTY
TO A PUBLIC ENTITY IF THEY
CHOOSE TO ACCEPT IT. I WOULD
NONPROFIT ENTITY OR TRUST
STRENGTHENED TRANSFER OR AND
BENEFICIARY PROTECTIONS SUCH AS
REQUIRING THE DEED BE SIGNED BY
TWO WITNESSES REQUIRING THE
BENEFICIARY GIVE NOTICE TO THE
TRANS FORCED ERRORS WHEN THE
TRANSFER DOES AND ALLOW COURTS
THE DISCRETION TO DETERMINE THE
TRANSFERS INTENT. IF THERE'S
AMBIGUITY AN ISSUE ARISES
SIMILAR TO THE WAY THOSE ISSUES
ARE DEALT WITH TODAY WITH
RESPECT TO WILLS AND TRUSTS
RESTRUCTURE THE RULES THAT
GOVERN THE BENEFICIARIES
LIABILITY FOR THE DECEASED
TRANSFERS AND SECURE DEBTS. AND
GIVE THE CALIFORNIA LAW
REVISION COMMISSION ADDITIONAL
TIME TO STUDY THE EFFICACY OF
THESE REVOCABLE TRANSFER ON
DEATH DEEDS TO EVALUATE WHETHER
NEW REFORMS OR OR ADDITIONAL
REFORMS ARE REQUIRED AND MAKE
ADDITIONAL RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
THE CONTINUATION OR TERMINATION
OF THIS PARTICULAR TOOL. ON THE
LINETODAY I HAVE WITH ME THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA LAW REVISION
COMMISSION MISTER BROWN HERE TO
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
MISTER CHAIR THAT YOU OR THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU SENATOR I DO HAVE ONE
WITNESS LISTED BRIAN HE BURKE
FROM THE CALIFORNIA LAW
REVISION COMMISSION. YES GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE- ARE AT THE
ANALYSIS AND SENATOR ROTH
EXPLAINED WHEN THE ROOK WILL
TRANSFER ON DEATH DEED STATUTE
WAS FIRST ENACTED IN IT WAS
GIVEN A FIVE YEAR SUNSET DATE
AND THE LAW REVISION COMMISSION
WAS DIRECTED TO DO A STUDY OF
THE EFFICACY OF THE STATUTE
WITH A FOUR YEAR DEADLINE STE-
AS A GENERAL MATTER THE
COMMISSION DIDN'T FIND EVIDENCE
OF SIGNIFICANT PROBLEMS THAT
WOULD JUSTIFY- REPEALING THE
STATUTE AT THIS TIME. BUT THE
COMMISSION RECOGNIZED THAT FOR
YEARS IT IS A RELATIVELY SHORT
AMOUNT OF TIME TO EVALUATE AN
INSTRUMENT THAT ONLY OPERATES
ON GAS SO THAT'S WHY THE
COMMISSION RECOMMENDED- DESPITE
NOT HAVING IT- DISCOVERED ANY
SERIOUS PROBLEMS AT THIS TIME
RECOMMENDED EXTENDING THE
SUNSET DATE- BY ANOTHER TEN
YEARS AND- REQUIRING A FOLLOW
UP STUDY OF THE COMMISSION
PRIOR TO THE- THE DATE THAT
THAT WOULD OPERATE- GROUND AS
SENATOR RAWSON THE ANALYSIS-
BOTH- EXPLAINS. WE ALSO
RECOMMENDED A NUMBER OF
PROCEDURAL IMPROVEMENTS TO THE
STATUTE WHICH SB THREE FIFTEEN
ONE EMPLOYMENT. AND BEYOND THAT
I AM AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT THE COMMITTEE
MIGHT HAVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM WHO WOULD. LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE ONE
FIVE. C. NONE WERE TEST STAY.
SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR THOSE WHO'D
LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT FOR SB.
THREE ONE FIVE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
ONE FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE ONE FIVE.
S. ONE AND THEN ZERO. NO
COMMENTS IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU WE WILL THEN MOVE TO
OPPOSITION I HAVE NO OPPOSITION
LISTED IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF THREE
ONE FIVE. SEEING NONE THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN ALLIANCE FOR ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE
OPPOSITION TO SB. THREE ONE
FIVE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB THREE ONE FIVE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB THREE
ONE FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AND.
ZERO NO COMMENTS INTO IT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU YOU MAY CLOSE
ALLIANCE THEN I WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SEEING
NONE CENTER YOU MAY CLOSE. WAS
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU I'M LOOKING FOR
A MOTION THAT MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS. THANK YOU WE
DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE. STONE AYE
STONE AYE GALLAGHER CHAU. CHAU
AYE CHIU. DAVIES GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE
KALRA KALRA AYE KILEY KILEY AYE
MAIENSCHEIN REYES. THE BILL IS
OUT THANK YOU MR THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT SO WE'RE LOOKING FOR
SENATOR RUBIO AND WHITE HOUSE
SKI IN THE MEANTIME I WILL TAKE
A MOTION ON THE PER POST
CONSENT AGENDA. THANK YOU WE DO
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE. STONE AYE
STONE AYE GALLAGHER CHAU. CHOW
I CHIU. DAVIES GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE
KALRA KALRA AYE KILEY KILEY ON
MAIENSCHEIN REYES. THANK YOU
THOSE ARE OUT THAT IS S. B. TWO
SEVEN TWO LAYER SB FOUR NINETY
EIGHT NUMBER SB FIVE A ONE WAY
CAB SKI SB SIX FIFTY SEVEN-
CHOI BO. I'M ALSO LOOKING FOR.
A MOTION ON ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTEEN AJ ARE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER S. DO YOU HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND THAT MOTION IS
THAT AJ ARE SIXTEEN BE STOPPED.
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE HI
STONE HI GALLAGHER CHAU. CHAU I
CHIU DAVIES GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE KALRA. KALRA
AYE KILEY. MAIENSCHEIN REYES.
THAT IS ON CALL IN NEEDS ONE
MORE VOTE CENTER CASKEY. WILL
MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN SB.
FOUR THIRTY TWO. SENATOR ALL
COME ON UP. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR SO ADAM FOURTEEN SB FOUR
THIRTY TWO YEAH- GOOD
AFTERNOON- THIS IS A MUCH
SMALLER FOLLOW UP A BILL TO MY-
S. B. THREE TWO THREE- WHICH
MADE SIGNIFICANT SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE ELECTION OF
HOAS. AMONG OTHER THINGS IT
RESTORES THE ABILITY OF A
CHOICE TO HAVE TERM LIMITS SO
LONG AS THIS IS INCLUDING THE
ELECTION OF RULES IT ALSO ADDS
BACK THE CHOICE- BANK STATEMENT
CITY EXISTING LIST OF WHAT IS
CONSIDERED ASSOCIATE RECORDS
AND WITH THAT NIGHTMARE TONIGHT
BOTH. THANK YOU SO I DO NOT
HAVE ANY SUPPORT LISTED IS
THERE ANYONE WHO WOULD LOOK IN
THE HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
THIRTY TWO. SENAD AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY SITE. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB. FOUR
THIRTY TWO. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR THIRTY TWO
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
SB FOUR THIRTY TWO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE. AND THEN ZERO. NO
COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU WE
WILL MOVE TO OPPOSITION I HAVE
NO OPPOSITION LISTED IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM. I
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF US BEFORE THIRTY
TWO. SEEING NONE THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO OPPOSE SB FOUR THIRTY TWO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT AND OPPOSITION
OF SB FOUR THIRTY TWO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION S. B. FOUR
THIRTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. WE HAVE NO
COMMENT IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. THANK
YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND SENATOR YOU MAY CLOSE AS
YOU CAN SEE MISTER CHAIR I'VE
WORKED WITH THE- BOTH SIDES OF
THE ISSUE I THINK I WOULD
CONTEND IT'S THIS IS YOUR THIRD
IT TO WHERE BILL. IS SET A
VICTORY TO HAVE. THE SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION HERE TONIGHT FOLKS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR MOST IN A
SECOND MOTION IS TO PASS A CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE STONE AYE STONE
AYE GALLAGHER. CHAU CHOW I
CHOOSE. STAY GONZALEZ HI
GONZALEZ I HOPE TOLD I'D KALRA
KALRA AYE KILEY. KILEY I'D
MAIENSCHEIN FREEST EXACTLY I
CLOSE OUT THANK YOU ADAM NUMBER
FIFTEEN SB SIX SEVENTY TWO A
MISTER CHAIRED GIVEN THE
LATENESS OF THE HOUR I'LL KEEP
MY COMMENTS BRIEF ON THIS THIS
IS A CLEAN UP BILL TO MY SENATE
BILL SEVEN OH SEVEN THIS
OUTLINED IN THE- STAFF REPORT-
SEVEN A SIX TO ADD TRANSPARENCY
AROUND THE DUE DATE OF THE
ARBITRATION FEES IN ORDER TO
PREVENT UNNECESSARY DELAYS IN
THE RESOLUTION OF DISPUTES FOR
WORKERS AND CONSUMERS IN
ARBITRATION IT'S AN EXCELLENT.
THE ACTUAL COMMITTEE- ANALYSIS
POINTS OUT- THAT THE
AMENDMENTS- TAKING THIS
COMMITTEE ARE MINOR AND I HATE-
EXCEPT THE AMENDMENTS AS
OUTLINED IN THE REPORT THANK
YOU ALTHOUGH I THINK AMENDMENTS
WERE TAKEN PRIOR. RIGHT BUT-
THANK YOU ANYWAY. OKAY I DO
HAVE TWO WITNESSES LISTED CAN
**** OF THE CALIFORNIA
PLACEMENT LAWYERS ASSOCIATION
AND JULIAN BURNS KING OF KING
AND SIEGEL. CAN WEARING ARE YOU
ON THE LINE. I AM GO AHEAD
PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS KEN WEIGHING
IN ON THE LEGISLATIVE POLICY
ASSOCIATE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT LAWYERS ASSOCIATION
HE LED THE PROUD SPONSOR SB
SEVEN SIXTY TWO WHICH WOULD
PROMOTE TRANSPARENCY AND
EXPEDIENCY AND CONSUMER
EMPLOYMENT ARBITRATION. IN
TWENTY NINETEEN THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED SB SEVEN OH SEVEN WHICH
GAVE WORKERS AND CONSUMERS
PROCEDURAL OPTIONS IN THE EVENT
THAT A COMPANY FAILED TO PAY
THEIR SHARE OF ARBITRATION
FEES. BUT THAT LAW LEFT IN
AMBIGUITY ABOUT WHEN
ARBITRATION P. PAYMENTS ARE
DUE. MEANING THAT CONSUMERS AND
EMPLOYEES ARE LEFT IN THE DARK
WHEN A COMPANY PREACHER THIRTY
OBLIGATION. THE CLOUD COMPANIES
TO PRIVATELY OBTAIN AN
EXTENSION OF PAYMENT FROM THE
ARBITRATION PROVIDER IN SOME
CASES EVEN AFTER DUE DATE AND
PASSED. WITH DELAYED
PROCEEDINGS AT LEAST CLAIMANTS
TO WONDER WHETHER THEIR CLAIMS
WILL BE MOVING FORWARD AT ALL.
ASSEMBLY CUTIE FRUSTRATE THE
PURPOSE OF ARBITRATION AS AN
EXPEDIENT FORM TO RESOLVE
DISPUTE. THIS IS WHY SB SEVENTY
TWO IS SO IMPORTANT THIS BILL
WOULD PROMOTE TRANSPARENCY BY
REQUIRING ARBITRATION PROVIDERS
TO DISCLOSE TO ALL PARTIES THAT
MOUNT A FEW DO AND THEIR DUE
DATE. THE BILL WOULD FURTHER
CLARIFY THE RESPONSIBILITIES OF
PARTIES TO OBTAIN EXTENSIONS TO
BE PAYMENT. FINALLY THE BILL
WOULD APPLY DEFAULT TERM FOR
PAYING OUR CREATION FEES WHAT
THE ORIGINAL ARBITRATION
AGREEMENT IS SILENT ABOUT THE
TIMING OF PAYMENT. IF NECESSARY
CLASSIFICATION PROMOTES
TRANSPARENCY IN THE FORM AND
GIVE CLAIMING THE CHANCE TO BE
RESOLUTION OF THE DISPUTE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
AND WITH ME TO DESCRIBE HOW
THIS LOOPHOLE HAS HURT WORKERS
AND CONSUMERS JULIAN BROWN CAME
TO JOIN AS A PARTNER AT KING
AND SEGAL LLP WHICH REPRESENTS
WORKERS FACING DISCRIMINATION
AND HARASSMENT AT WORK. HENRY
MORNING SHARON MEMBERS MORNING.
MY NAME IS JULIAN BARNES KING
AND I AM A LOS ANGELES BASED
ATTORNEY WHO REPRESENTS
EMPLOYEES IN DISCRIMINATION AND
RETALIATION CASES IN COURT AND
ARBITRATION THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA BEFORE THE PASSAGE
OF SB SEVEN OH SEVEN TWENTY
NINETEEN MANY OF OUR CLIENTS
EXPERIENCED FRUSTRATION AND
DELAY IN RESOLVING THEIR
DISPUTES IN ARBITRATION BECAUSE
COMPANIES WERE INTENTIONALLY
DELAYING PAYMENT OF ARBITRATION
FEES. SB SEVEN OH SEVEN HELP
ALLEVIATE SOME OF THESE ISSUES
BUT AN UNNECESSARY AMBIGUITY
AND NOT LIVE TO WIN AN INVOICES
DEAL HAD LEFT OPEN A LOOPHOLE
THAT ALLOWS COMPANIES TO DELAY
PROCEEDINGS BY PRIVATELY
OBTAINING EXTENSIONS TO BE
PAYMENT. THIS PRACTICE HAS
SERIOUSLY HARMED OUR CLIENTS
INCLUDING FOR EXAMPLE A SINGLE
MOTHER WHO WAS FIRED AFTER
COMPLAINING ABOUT ILLEGAL
PRACTICES AT A REVERSE MORTGAGE
LENDER IN HER CASE EVEN THOUGH
THE ARBITRATION PROVIDER
SPECIFIED ON THE INVOICE PER
PIECE THAT PAYMENTS WERE DUE
UPON RECEIPT THE RESPONDENT
FAILED TO PAY FEES FOR NEARLY
SIXTY DAYS AFTER IT WAS DUE
RESULTING AN ARBITRATOR CLOSING
THE CASE AND THEY KIDDING HER
PREVIOUSLY SCHEDULED HEARING
DATE. WITHOUT FURTHER
CLARIFICATION MY CLIENT'S CASE
WAS ON HOLD FOR ALMOST A YEAR
AND WE TRIED TO ASSERT HER
RIGHTS ADDRESS THE SEVEN OH
SEVEN IN COURT ONLY TO LOSE
BECAUSE OF AN AMBIGUITY AS TO
WHEN AN INVOICE IS DUE SB SEVEN
SIXTY TWO WOULD END THE
CONFUSION BY REQUIRING
ARBITRATION PROVIDERS DESPITE
ALL PARTIES WITH THE INVOICE
CONTAINING THE DUE DATE AND THE
AMOUNT DUE AND PREVENTING. THE
CRITICS ACTION IN MY CLIENT
CASE THIS WOULD HAVE ALLOWED
HER TO AFFECT THE PROCEDURAL
OPTIONS AVAILABLE TO HER UNDER
CURRENT LAW WHEN THE COMPANY.
FAILED TO PAY THEIR SHARE OF
THE FEES. THAT'S WHY WE NEED AT
SEVEN SIXTY TWO. THANK YOU. WAS
THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. THANK YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
SIXTY TWO. SEEING NONE THE
REMOTE WITNESS THE REMOTE SITE.
SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR OTHERS WHO
WOULD LIKE TO DECADE SUPPORT
FOR SB SEVEN SIXTY TWO. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
SIXTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN SIXTY TWO.
S. ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I HAVE NO COMMENT TO KEEP.
THANK YOU WE WILL MOVE TO
OPPOSITION I HAVE NO OPPOSITION
LISTED THERE ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN
SIXTY TWO. SEEING NONE AT THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY SIDE. SEEING
NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN
THE LINES WERE OPPOSITION TO SB.
SEVEN SIX TWO. YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB SEVEN SIXTY TWO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN
SIXTY TWO. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN THERE. WE HAVE NO
COMMENT IN THE QUEUE AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. DO WE DO A MOTION
IS THEIR SECOND. AND THE SECOND
SENATOR YOU MAY CLOSE. MESSAGER
WHILE IT'S A MINOR I THINK IT'S
MINOR- CHANGES THERE ARE TWEAKS
TO LEGISLATION THINK THEY'RE
IMPORTANT ABOUT. THE GIFT WE DO
HAVE A MOTION TO SECOND THE
MOTION IS TO PASS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE HI STONE HI
GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER I CHAO.
CHAO AYE CHIU. DAVIES GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE
KALRA KALRA AYE KILEY KILEY AYE
MAIENSCHEIN REYES. THAT DILUTES
OUT. SO WHAT I'M SIXTEEN SB
EIGHT OH SEVEN THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND COLLEAGUES AT THE
EIGHT OH SEVEN IMPROVES- THE
GOVERNMENT EFFICIENCY AND
PROVIDES THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING ACT WITH GREATER
CLARITY AND ORGANIZATIONS
BENEFITING EMPLOYERS AND
EMPLOYEES HOW'S THAT HOUSING
PROVIDERS AND TENANTS BUSINESS
AND CONSUMERS WELL MOST OF THE
CHANGES ARE TECHNICAL IN NATURE
THEY DO HAVE. A STEPS-
SUBSTANTIVE IMPACT AND I WOULD
URGE AND I BOTH. THANK YOU I
HAVE ONE WITNESS LISTED ADAM
ROMERO FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING. I DON'T REMEMBER
WERE YOU IN A LOT. AN GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR STONE AN
HONORABLE MEMBERS ATOMERA THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF EXECUTIVE
PROGRAMS AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING.
OUR DEPARTMENT IS CALIFORNIA'S
CIVIL RIGHTS AGENCY AND WE
ENFORCE THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND
HOUSING ACT THAT IS THE SUBJECT
OF SB EIGHT ZERO SEVEN. THE
ADMINISTRATION DOES NOT HAVE A
POSITION ON THIS BILL BUT I AM
PLEASED TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE- BECAUSE THE
COMMITTEE STAFF ANALYSIS
PROVIDED EXCELLENT AN EXCELLENT
SUMMARY OF THE BILL AND IN
COGNIZANT OF YOUR BUSY SCHEDULE
TO MERELY EMPHASIZED THAT. SB
EIGHT ZERO SEVEN WOULD PROVIDE
CLARITY CONSISTENCY AND
EFFICIENCY THE FIRM PLUMMETED
HOUSING ACT AND I'M AVAILABLE
TO ANSWER ANY. QUESTIONS YOU
MAY HAVE FOR THE DEPARTMENT.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM WHO'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB OF S. B.
C. EIGHT OH SEVEN. SEEING NONE
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR SUPPORT FOR
SB. EIGHT OH SEVEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT
ZERO SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WHICH AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT
ZERO SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. I HAVE NO
COMMENT TO MAKE YOU THINK YOU
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO OPPOSITION.
THIS IS OUR THIRD WHITE HOUSE
CUBILLA AROUND WITHOUT
OPPOSITION I AM NOT SURE I
UNDERSTAND THIS. IS SOMETHING
IS OUR DISPATCHER I'D I'D
PERHAPS IN HELPING THAT I DID
X. I WILL ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS
AS OUTLINED IN PETE SIX I
HAVEN'T SAID THAT BUT THAT'S-
CLEAR IN THERE. YES THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
WHO'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHT OH SEVEN.
AND SEE NOT AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY SITE. SEE NON
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN FOR A
POSITION TO SB EIGHT OH SEVEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SB
EIGHT ZERO SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
BUT AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION SB EIGHT ZERO
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AND
THEN ZERO. WE HAVE NO COMMENT
TO MAKE YOU. THINK YOU WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS COMMENTS. SEEING
NONE. SENATOR YOU MAY CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY URGE AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU I'M LOOKING FOR A
MOTION. THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND THAT MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALDWELL PLEASE.
STONE HI STONE AYE GALLAGHER.
CHAU SHALL I CHOOSE DAVIES
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I HOLDEN. BUT
THEN I KALRA. KALRA AYE KILEY
KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN THE- KILEY
NO MAIENSCHEIN REYES. THE NEEDS
ONE MORE SETTLES ON CALL. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MY WORK IS
DONE HERE. ET THANK YOU TO OUR
FINAL BILL FOR THE DAY ITEM
NUMBER THIRTEEN SB. FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT SENATOR RUBIO. HELLO
WELCOME HELLO. THANK YOU
THERE'S A MOTION TO A SECOND.
AND THE SECOND THANK YOU PLEASE
WELL THAT WAS. THANK YOU I WILL
BE TRY TO BE BRIEF- MEMBERS
TODAY THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HEARING THIS BILL I'M HERE TO
PRESENT SB FIVE THIRTY EIGHT
WHICH IS A CRITICAL MEASURE FOR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SURVIVORS
SEEKING. OUR PROTECTION FROM
THEIR ABUSERS SENATE BILL FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT WILL ALLOW VICTIMS
TO FILE ELECTRONICALLY DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDERS TO
PROVIDE GREATER SAFETY FOR
VICTIMS AS THEY TRY TO LEAVE
DANGEROUS SITUATIONS IT IS
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT JUDGES
WILL ALWAYS HAVE DISCRETION AT
ALL TIMES. IN A CASE BY CASE
BASIS TO ENSURE THAT IF HERE
SHE DEEMS IT'S AN APPROPRIATE
IN THAT CASE THEY CAN THEY
SHOULD THEY WILL NOT ALLOW
REMOTE TESTIMONY. AND I AS WE
ALL KNOW ABOUT THIS PANDEMIC WE
HAVE SEEN THE RISE IN DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE CASES IN MY OWN
COMMUNITY ONE CITY REPORTED OUT
2100% INCREASE IN CASE WORK.
WHICH IS INCREDIBLE. IT'S
CRITICAL TO ALLOW REMOTE
TESTIMONY BECAUSE THE VICTIM IS
ALREADY DEALING WITH A LOT OF
TRAUMA AND IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
TO FACE OUR PEACE OR IS TO BE
ABLE TO SPEAK FREELY. AND
TRUTHFULLY AND WITHOUT FEAR OF
RETALIATION. AT LEAST WE CAN DO
ISTRY TO MAKE THE PROCESS A
LITTLE BIT EASIER FOR THEM TO
FEEL CONFIDENT AND BE ABLE TO
TESTIFY. WE WANT VICTIMS AND
WITNESSES. ONCE AGAIN TO BE
ABLE TO BE PROTECTED. WHAT I DO
NOT PERSONALLY IS THAT DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE TRIGGERS ARE VERY
UNPREDICTABLE. AND YOU NEVER
KNOW IF THAT MOMENT IN FRONT OF
THAT ABUSE OR MAYBE THE LAST
FOR A VICTIM. I WOULD LIKE IF I
MAY TO INTRODUCED OUT TO MY
WITNESSES. I HAVE HERE TIßN
TORII- WHO IS THE INTERIM
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AT THE SAN
DIEGO FAMILY JUSTICE CENTER.
AND MY SECOND WITNESSES. A
SURVIVOR LIST BET. AND IF. THEY
MAY. CAN THEY BEGIN. YEAH OKAY
THANK YOU THOSE ARE WHO WE HAD
LISTED I HAD MORE ROOFTOP
PRINCE DISENTANGLE MAYOR'S
OFFICE AND JULIA WEBER FROM
GIFFORDS LAW CENTER SO THOSE
ARE NOT. THEY WERE SCHEDULED TO
TESTIFY BUT THEY WERE ON HOLD
FOR SO LONG AND THEY ENDED UP
HAVING TO SEND US SOMEONE TO
REPLACE HIMSELF I HOPE THAT'S
OKAY THAT'S FINE JUST. TRY TO
MAKE SURE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE A RECORD OKAY SO THE FIRST
WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR SENATOR
RUBIO'S LEADERSHIP ON DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE ISSUES AGAIN I'M DIANE
TO ALREADY THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE SAN DIEGO
FAMILY JUSTICE CENTER. THE
FAMILY JUSTICE CENTER HAS
HELPED THOUSANDS OF VICTIMS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND NINETEEN HAS
PROVIDED ASSISTANCE TO VICTIMS
OF SEX TRAFFICKING AS WELL. AS
SOMEONE WHO WORKS WITH
SURVIVORS ON A DAILY BASIS I
KNOW FIRST HAND HOW IMPORTANT
IT IS TO PREVENT THEM FROM
BEING RE VICTIMIZED BY THEIR
ABUSERS. STEADY SHOW THAT THE
MOST DANGEROUS TIMES FOR
VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
COMMENT WHEN A VICTIM DECIDES
TO LEAVE THE RELATIONSHIP AND
LAND SEEKING A RESTRAINING
ORDER. COMMITTEE MEMBERS NEED
ADVANCED ANGER THEIR ABUSERS
AND PROVIDE THEM WITH
OPPORTUNITIES TO RETALIATE. BY
TESTIFYING REMOTELY VICTIMS ARE
ABLE TO TELL THIS STORY IN
COURT WITHOUT FEAR OF PHYSICAL
RETALIATION. INTIMIDATION
THREATS AND COERCION BY THE
DEFENDANT AND THE DEFENDANT
FAMILY BEFORE DURING AND AFTER
COURT HEARINGS. AT THE FAMILY
JUSTICE CENTER WE'VE CREATED A
SPACE WHERE CLIENTS CAN STATE
PLEASE SPEAK TO THE COURT. IN A
CALM ENVIRONMENT THAT IS FREE
OF STRESS AND INTIMIDATION BY
THEIR ABUSER AS WELL AS THE
CONFUSION OF THE COURTHOUSE.
GOOD SPACE KEEPS ARE VICTIMS
STATE AND FREE FROM FURTHER
DRAMATIC EXPERIENCES SO THEY
CAN. THAT THEY CAN ENCOUNTER A
COURT. CALIFORNIA HAS NOW HAD
MONTHS OF VALUABLE X. WITH
REMOTE TEST. ABOUT TESTIMONY
ASSISTANT FROM THE MINOR BY
THEM FROM THE FEAR OF THE COURT.
AN ADDITIONAL EIGHT BENEFITS
THE ORDER AND CAR OF THE ROOM.
ON BEHALF UNDERSTANDING THE
CITY ATTORNEY MARA ELLIOTT I
URGE YOU TO PUT VICTIMS FIRST.
AND KEEP THEM AND THEIR
FAMILIES STATE BY VOTING IN
FAVOR OF SB FIVE THIRTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU AND I'M AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. SEPARATED
OUR NEXT SPEAKER THANK YOU
THAT'S BIGGER THAN PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR STONE AND
MEMBERS- MY NAME IS LISBETH
BANNERS AND I'M UP FORMER
UNDOCUMENTED VICTIM OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. WHEN I WAS GOING TO
THE DENTURES WHICH CRISIS OF
LEAVING MY ABUSER I NOT ONLY
FEAR MY ABUSER AND HIS THAT BUT
ALSO REPORTING THE ABUSE
BECAUSE I THOUGHT I WILL GET
DEPORTED ALTHOUGH I FEAR BEING
SEPARATED FROM MY CHILDREN.
THANKFULLY GOING TO THE FAMILY
JUSTICE CENTER I WAS ONE OF THE
VICTIMS WILL BENEFIT FROM IT
FINALLY BY EITHER FAX IN THE
MARKET THE RESTRAINING ORDER TO
THE COURT. ALSO GOING TO THE
FAMILY JUSTICE CENTER AND HELP
ME TERMINATE MY FEAR TO THE
SYSTEM DEPUTATION THREATS
TRANSPORTATION AND CHILD CARE
CHALLENGES AND LASTLY BEING RE
TRAUMATIZED AND MY KIDS I DO SO
ROUNDED WITH A SUPPORTED TEAM
IN THE SAFE LOCATION. I'M NOT
DON'T WANT TO FORGET COMING I
NEVER THOUGHT THAT AND
UNDOCUMENTED INDIVIDUALS WE
HAVE- IS RESOURCES. AVAILABLE
FOR FREE. I GET TO A PLACE OF
AND FIVE EIGHT. IT WILL HELP
PROTECT AND THEY THE LIFE BIG
TIME OF YOU AND IT'S- THANK YOU
AND I'M A- TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT. THANK YOU. IS THERE
ANY IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO
LIKE TO SPEAK AND SO OF S. FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT. SEEING OF THE
WITNESSES. OR THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY SITE. NONE WHICH OPEN
THE FOR THOSE WITH TO INDICATE
SUPPORT S. B. FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT AND SUPPORT.
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE.
AND THEN ZERO. NINE SEVENTY TWO
OKAY I'M SORRY MY SEVENTY TWO
IF YOU COULD- PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AGAIN. NINE TWO
TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MORE RED
TOP ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
SAN DIEGO COSPONSOR AND
PRACTICE SUPPORT THE BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU. MY SEVENTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE SEVENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN YOU MAY BE ON MUTE.
SORRY CAN YOU HEAR ME YES YOUR
HONOR OKAY GREAT THANK YOU ON
THE BALLOT PAPER ON BEHALF OF
THE PARTNERSHIP THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIPS AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IN SUPPORT. AND ONE
MOMENT FOR OUR NEXT COMING.
NINE TWO TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON JAMIE MINOR ON BEHALF
OF THE DIFFERENT COST CENTER
INTO COURT EACH. AND THERE ARE
NO FURTHER COMMENTS IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU WE WILL
MOVE TO OPPOSITION I DO NOT
HAVE ANY OPPOSITION LISTED IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. SB FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT. SEE NON REMOTE TESTIMONY
SITE. SEEING NONE OPERATOR
WOULD YOU FOR THE LINES FOR
OPPOSITION TO FIGHT SB FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR ND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF THE FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT NINE
ZERO. WE HAVE NO COMMENT FROM
THE QUEUE. THANK YOU WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. CIGNA
SENATOR YOU MAKE MISTAKES
SENATE I WANT TO THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
YOU SAY ON DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
DOESN'T END AT THE END OF THE
DAY AND THIS GIVES THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO STAY SAFE-
THANKS FOR THIS AND- I'D BE
HONORED TO CO AUTHOR THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. REDUCE YEAH THANK
YOU SENATOR- ON. I I'VE I THINK
EVERYBODY IS IN A VERY MUCH
AGREE UPON THIS AS FOR THE
SPECIALLY THE FILING FILING-
ONE CONCERN THAT DOES COME UP
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT JUST DOING
WAS WITH TV IN THIS BILL ALSO
DEALING WITH GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS. IS HAVING
REMOTE TESTIMONY AND- WITH ALL
THESE RESTRAINING ORDERS ON.
THAT WAS ALL WITH RESTRAINT
ORDERS THERE'S ALWAYS A ONE OF
THE CONCERNS IT'S RESTRAINED
ORDERS IS THERE YOU CAN THEY
CAN BE GIVEN EVEN ON A LACK OF
NO NOTICE AT ALL. AND WOOD
PEOPLE'S CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS
ARE AT YOU KNOW AT ISSUE IN ANY
KIND OF CRIMINAL PROCEEDING
WHICH IS WHAT THESE ARE- YOU
KNOW THERE'S CONCERNS ABOUT
ENSURING THAT THEY HAVE DUE
PROCESS AND THAT THERE WOULD BE
ABLE TO. YOU KNOW. HEAR FROM
THOSE WHO ARE TESTIFYING
AGAINST THEM. REMOTE I THINK AS
WE ARE AS WE KNOW WHAT THESE
HEARINGS LIKE REMOTE. TESTIMONY
IS NOT ALWAYS. MOST ADEQUATE
WAY OF- PROVIDING THAT SO I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU COULD JUST
SAY A FEW WORDS ABOUT THAT
THEY'LL BE LIKE THE ONLY
CONCERN THAT. THAT I HAVE HERE
IS. GEN CHEVY ISSUE TO PEOPLE
YOU KNOW WHO ARE WHO ARE
OBVIOUSLY BEING- CONFRONTED
WITH ALLEGATIONS OF. A
SITUATION WHERE THEY'RE WHERE
THEY ARE- AT THE END OF THIS
THING THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE A
RESTRAINING ORDER FILED AGAINST
THEM- AND BEING ABLE TO.
ACTUALLY HAD TO PROCESS TO
ADDRESS YOU KNOW THOSE
ALLEGATIONS RIGHT. THANK YOU
FOR THAT NO AND I JUST WANT TO
MAKE IT VERY CLEAR THAT THIS
BILL DOES NOT ALTER ANY DUE
PROCESS IT REMAINS THE SAME IT
ONLY EXPANDS AXES WHEN YOU GO
FILE RESTRAINING ORDER YOU
FILED THE RESTRAINING ORDER
USED TO HAVE TO APPEAR IN COURT
TO PROVE YOUR CASE AND SHOW
EVIDENCE AND- TO YOUR POINT
MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS DUE
PROCESS IN THIS CASE STILL.
AGAIN THIS DOES NOT CHANGE THE
DUE PROCESS IS JUST- ABOUT IT
NOT BEING ABLE TO OFFER E.
FILING AND STILL HAVE TO SHOW
UP REMOTE TESTIMONY AND PROVE
YOUR CASE AND AT ALL TIMES THE
JUDGE HAS DISCRETION OF THE
FEEL THAT. YOU KNOW BY CASE BY
CASE BASIS IF THIS IS NOT GOING
TO WORK YOU KNOW THEY'RE ABLE
TO SENSE THAT THERE'S SOMETHING
INAPPROPRIATE THEY STILL HAVE
DISCRETION TO BE ABLE TO IT TO
CATCH SOME OF THOSE CASES THAT
YOU MAY BE CONCERNED WITH.
THANK YOU SENATOR THANK YOU
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
SENIOR CENTER DO YOU MAKE OF.
YES THANK YOU FOR HEARING THIS-
I JUST WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT AND
YOU KNOW THAT. THE PANDEMIC
REALLY HOUSE CASA PANDEMIC
WITHIN A PANDEMIC AND AS I
NOTED THAT NUMBERS ARE SKY HIGH
AND UNFORTUNATELY FOR VICTIMS
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SAFE AT
HOME ORDERS DIDN'T QUITE MEAN
THE SAME THING ESPECIALLY WHEN
THERE'S VIOLENCE IN THE HOME
AND FILL. THIS IS JUST ONE STEP
TO HELP BRING VICTIMS OUT OF
THE SHUTTLE AND FEEL SAFE THAT
THEY CAN AGAIN BE TRUTHFUL AND
DA. AND JUST WANT TO COME
FORWARD TO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIFLE
THANK YOU THANK YOU WE DO HAVE
A MOTION. AND A SECOND THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO PUBLIC
SAFETY. CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
STONE HI STONE I GALLAGHER.
CHAU CHOW I CHIU DAVIES DAVIES
I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ HI HOLDEN
HOLDEN I KALRA. KALRA AYE KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
REYES. THANK YOU THE BILL WAS
OUT THANK YOU RIGHT. LET'S GO
BACK THROUGH OUR ITEMS WE HAVE
SEVERAL BILLS ON CALL SERVER
BILLS STILL MISSING A MOTION SO
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS WILL START
WITH THE CONSENT AGENDA. COMING
UP TO MEMBERS. GALLAGHER TIED
GALLAGHER AYE CHIU. DAVIES
DAVIES I MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE REYES. OKAY
THEN ITEM NUMBER ONE SB THREE
NINETY TWO WAS A CALL THE
MIDDLE IF THE CALL. CHAU CHOW I
TO. HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I. THE
BILL IS OUT ITEM NUMBER TWO SB
FIVE NINETY ONE OF LOOKING FOR
A MOTION THE MOTION IS TO PASS.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE HI STONE HI
GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER AYE CHAU
CHOW I CHIU DAVIES. DAVIES I
CONSOLIDATE GONZALEZ I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA. KALRA AYE
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
AYE REYES. THE BILLS OUT I DO
NUMBER THREE SB THREE TWENTY
THREE COVER YOUR- LOOKING FOR A
MOTION. THANK YOU WE DO A MOST
IN A SECOND MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
STONE AYE STONE AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE CHAU. CHOW I CHIU
DAVIES. DAVEY SECOND SALAS
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE
KALRA. KALRA AYE KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN. MAIENSCHEIN IRIS.
THE BILL IS OUT. SB THREE
THIRTY TWO IS OUT BUT YOU CAN
CALL ABSENT MEMBERS CHAO CHAO
AYE CHU HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN IRIS.
OKAY ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB SIXTY
TWO WAS ON CALL AND LIFTING THE
CALL. GALLAGHER GALLAGHER NO
CHAU. CHOW I CHIU HOLDEN HOLDEN
AYE MAIENSCHEIN MAIN CHINA THE
BILL IS OUT THANK YOU ITEM
NUMBER SIX SB FOUR FIFTY TWO
GONZALEZ IS ON CALL I'M LIFTING
THE CALL. GALLAGHER GALLAGHER
NOTE CHAU CHOW I CHU. HOLDEN
HOLDEN I'D MAIENSCHEIN MENTION
ON THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SB FIVE
SEVENTY TWO HERTZBERG OUT CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS THOUGH
GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER NO CHAO
CHAO AYE CHIU. KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN HE Q.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT IS SB FOUR
FOUR SEVEN LAYERED THE BILL IS
OUT BUT YOU CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS CHAO. CHOW II
MAIENSCHEIN. THANK YOU ITEM
NUMBER NINE SB THREE NINETY ONE
MIN IS OUT THE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS GALLAGHER. CHAU CHARGE
YOU KILEY MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I THANK YOU ADAM
NUMBER TEN SB SIX FIFTY FOUR
MIN IS OUT CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS GALLAGHER. CHAU CHOW I
CHIU KILEY MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN NIGHT. THANK YOU
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN SB SIX SIXTY
NEWMAN IS ON CALL AND RECEIVE A
CALL. GALLAGHER GALLAGHER NO
CHAO CHAO AYE CHIU DAVIES
DAVIES NO MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE REYES. THE BILL
IS OUT THANK YOU ADAM NUMBER
TWELVE SB THREE ONE FIVE ROTH
IS OUT BUT CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER I
CHIU DAVIES DAVIES I
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN IRIS.
THANK YOU I REMEMBER THIRTEEN
S. B. FIVE THIRTY EIGHT RUBIO
WE JUST DID TO HAVE ABSENT
MEMBERS. I DON'T THINK IN THE
ROOM HERE OKAY. SB FIVE THIRTY
TWO WHITE CAL SKI CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. IS ADAM FORTY
FOUR THIRTY CHEN. YES I'M
FOURTEEN SB FOUR THIRTY TWO
GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER I CHIU.
DAVIES DAVEY FIVE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN CORRECT BUT OF
NUMBER FIFTEEN SB SEVEN SIXTY
TO WORK HOUSEKI CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS TO. DAVIES DAVIES I
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I REYES
RESIDE THANK YOU ITEM NUMBER
SIXTEEN SB EIGHT OH SEVEN Y.
CASKEY IS ON CALL OF LIFTING
THE CALL TO DAVIES DAVIES HI
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
REYES FIVE RAISE I PAY THE
BILLS OUT I REMEMBER SEVENTEEN
EIGHT J. R. SIXTEEN BY RACES ON
CALL OF LIFTING THE CALL.
GALLAGHER GALLAGHER NO CHIU
DAVIES DAVEY NO MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE REYES RAISE ACT
RIGHT THE RESOLUTION THEN IS
ADOPTED. SO WE'RE STILL MISSING
A COUPLE THANK YOU SO. HAVE
SOME AND CRIED RIGHT. THERE'S
THIS. OKAY SO LET'S GO RULE TO
LIST AGAIN YEAH CAN AGENDA AT
RAYOS. REYES AYE AYE NUMBER ONE
SB THREE NO TWO. CHIU OKAY I AM
TWO AS FIVE NINETY CHIU KILEY
KILEY AYE REYES REYES. ADAM
NUMBER THREE SB TWENTY THREE
EURO CHIU KILEY. KILEY AYE
RADIUS RACE I SB THREE TWENTY
THREE CABALLERO. MR TO JUST
UNDER THE RIGHT. ALL RIGHT CHU
I. OKAY WHICH IS HERE LET'S GO.
BACK TO COULD SET JUST TO MAKE
SURE FOR THE WILL CATCH FIRE
FOR SOME SENT CHILDREN I TO II
FAITH I AM NUMBER ONE SB THREE
NINETY TWO. TWO CHUGAI. I
REMEMBER TO SB FIVE NINETY ONE
TO TWO I REMEMBER THREE SB
THREE TWENTY THREE I THINK WE
JUST DID ITEM NUMBER FOR SB
THREE THIRTY TWO DODD CHU. CHU
I RACE RACE I REMEMBER FIVE SB
SIXTY TWO TO ROSA CHU. CHU I.
I'VE NEVER SIX S. B. FOUR FIFTY
TWO GONZALEZ CHU CHU I REMEMBER
SEVEN SB FIVE SEVENTY TWO
HERTZBERG CHU. CHU AYE KILEY
KILEY NOW. I REMEMBER EIGHT SB
FOUR FORTY SEVEN LAYER. WE GOT
EVERYBODY OKAY WE'VE GOT
EVERYBODY I'VE NUMBER NINE SB
THREE NINETY ONE MID TO HIGH TO
AYE KILEY. KILEY AYE. THANK YOU
OUT OF NUMBER TEN SB SIX FIFTY
FOUR MIN. CHU CHU AYE KILEY
KILEY AYE FILE ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN SB SIX SIXTY NEWMAN TO.
CHUGAI RACE RACE I HAVE OVER
TWELVE SB THREE ONE FIVE ROTH
CHU CHU AYE REUS RESIDE. SB
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT RUBIO. TWO BY
TWO BY KILEY. REYES HI CHRIS I.
SB FOUR THIRTY TWO WHITE HOUSE
E. TO. TWO I. SB SEVEN SIXTY TO
WORKOUTS SKI CHU CHU I. SB
EIGHT OH SEVEN MAKOWSKI CHIU
CHU I. AND THEN FINALLY H. A.
R. SIXTEEN PRESS TWO. I GUESS.
TWO I GUESS IS AND I. IT OKAY
THAT COULD SERVICES FOR TODAY
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH AND WE
ARE JERKS.